deep learning has become one of the most
debated technologies in the last decade
it is being widely used in various
sectors of business to ease human tasks
if you're looking to learn deep learning
you're in the right place hi guys
welcome to this complete deep learning
tutorial by simply learn my name is
rahul and today we will learn the
various essential topics deep learning
that you need to know
now let's have a look at the different
topics we'll be covering in this video
first we'll watch a short animated video
to understand ai in five minutes then
we'll learn what is deep learning and
see how to install tensorflow on ubuntu
after that we'll look at what is
tensorflow and understand deep learning
in depth with a use case demo then we'll
see how to detect objects using
tensorflow object detection api and the
different deep learning frameworks
available in python then we'll
understand how convolutional neural
networks and recurrent neural networks
work finally we'll get an idea about the
various deep learning applications and
learn a few important deep learning
interview questions that will help you
build your career in deep learning with
that let's get started ever wondered how
google translates an entire web page to
a different language in a matter of
seconds or your phone gallery group's
images based on their location all of
this is a product of deep learning but
what exactly is deep learning deep
learning is a subset of machine learning
which in turn is a subset of artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence is
a technique that enables a machine to
mimic human behavior machine learning is
a technique to achieve ai through
algorithms trained with data and finally
deep learning is a type of machine
learning inspired by the structure of
the human brain in terms of deep
learning this structure is called an
artificial neural network let's
understand deep learning better and how
it's different from machine learning say
we create a machine that could
differentiate between tomatoes and
cherries if done using machine learning
we'd have to tell the machine the
features based on which the two can be
differentiated these features could be
the size and the type of stim on them
with deep learning on the other hand the
features are picked out by the neural
network without human intervention of
course that kind of independence comes
at the cost of having a much higher
volume of data to train our machine
now let's dive into the working of
neural networks
here we have three students each of them
write down the digit nine on a piece of
paper
notably they don't all write it
identically the human brain can easily
recognize the digits
but what if a computer had to recognize
them
that's where deep learning comes in
here's a neural network trained to
identify handwritten digits
each number is present as an image of 28
times 28 pixels
now that amounts to a total of 784
pixels
neurons the core entity of a neural
network is where the information
processing takes place
each of the 784 pixels is fed to a
neuron in the first layer of our neural
network
this forms the input layer
on the other end we have the output
layer with each neuron representing a
digit with the hidden layers existing
between them
the information is transferred from one
layer to another over connecting
channels
each of these has a value attached to it
and hence is called a weighted channel
all neurons have a unique number
associated with it called bias
this bias is added to the weighted sum
of inputs reaching the neuron
which is then applied to a function
known as the activation function
the result of the activation function
determines if the neuron gets activated
every activated neuron passes on
information to the following layers
this continues up till the second last
layer
the one neuron activated in the output
layer corresponds to the input digit the
weights and bias are continuously
adjusted to produce a well-trained
network so where is deep learning
applied in customer support when most
people converse with customer support
agents the conversation seems so real
they don't even realize that it's
actually a bot on the other side in
medical care neural networks detect
cancer cells and analyze mri images to
give detailed results self-driving cars
what seem like science fiction is now a
reality apple tesla and nissan are only
a few of the companies working on
self-driving cars so deep learning has a
vast scope but it too faces some
limitations the first as we discussed
earlier is data while deep learning is
the most efficient way to deal with
unstructured data a neural network
requires a massive volume of data to
train let's assume we always have access
to the necessary amount of data
processing this is not within the
capability of every machine and that
brings us to our second limitation
computational power training a neural
network requires graphical processing
units which have thousands of cores as
compared to cpus and gpus are of course
more expensive and finally we come down
to training time deep neural networks
take hours or even months to train the
time increases with the amount of data
and number of layers in the network so
here's a short quiz for you arrange the
following statements in order to
describe the working of a neural network
a the bias is added b the weighted sum
of the inputs is calculated c specific
neuron is activated d the result is fed
to an activation function some of the
popular deep learning frameworks include
tensorflow pytorch keras deep learning
4j cafe and microsoft cognitive toolkit
considering the future predictions for
deep learning and ai we seem to have
only scratched the surface in fact horus
technology is working on a device for
the blind that uses deep learning with
computer vision to describe the world to
the users replicating the human mind at
the entirety may be not just an episode
of science fiction for too long the
future is indeed full of surprises and
that is deep learning for you in short i
hope that's got you excited to learn
deep learning we now have richard and
mohan who will explain the various
concepts of deep learning hello and
welcome to the session on installing
tensorflow hello and welcome to this
session on deep learning my name is
mohan and in this video we are going to
talk about what deep learning is all
about some of you may be already
familiar with the image recognition how
does image recognition
work you can train this application or
your machine to recognize whether a
given image is a cat or a dog and this
is how it works at a very high level it
uses artificial neural network it is
trained with some known images and
during the training it is told if it is
recognizing correctly or not and then
when new images are submitted it
recognizes correctly based on the
accuracy of course so a little quick
understanding about artificial neural
networks so this is the way it does is
you provide a lot of training data also
known as labeled data for example in
this case these are the images of dogs
and the network extracts some features
that makes a dog a dog right so that is
known as feature extraction and based on
that when you submit a new image of dog
the basic features remain pretty much
the same it may be a completely
different image but the features of a
dog still remain pretty much the same in
various different images let's say
compared to a cat and that's the way
artificial neural network works we'll go
into details of this uh very shortly and
once the training is done with training
data we then test it with some test data
too which is basically completely new
data which the system has not seen
before unlike the training data and then
we find out whether it is predicting
correctly or not thereby we know whether
the training is complete or it needs
more training so that's not a very high
level artificial neural network works so
this is what we are going to talk about
today our agenda looks something like
this what is deep learning why do we
need deep learning and then what are the
applications of deep learning one of the
main components the secret sauce in deep
learning is neural networks so we're
going to talk about what is neural
network and how it works and some of its
components like for example the
activation function the gradient descent
and so on and so forth so that as a part
of working of a neural network we will
go into little bit more details how this
whole thing works so without much
further ado let's get started so deep
learning is considered to be a part of
machine learning so this diagram very
nicely depicts what deep learning is at
a very high level you have the
all-encompassing artificial intelligence
which is more a concept rather than a
technology or a technical concept right
so it is it's more of a concept at a
very high level artificial intelligence
under the hood is actually machine
learning and deep learning and machine
learning is a broader concept you can
say or a broader technology and deep
learning is a subset of machine learning
the primary difference between machine
learning and deep learning is that deep
learning uses neural networks and it is
suitable for handling large amounts of
unstructured data and the last but not
least one of the major differences
between machine learning and deep
learning is that in machine learning the
feature extraction or the feature
engineering is done by the data
scientists manually but in deep learning
since we use neural networks the feature
engineering happens automatically so
that's a little bit of a quick
difference between machine learning and
deep learning and this diagram very
nicely depicts the relation between
artificial intelligence machine learning
and deep learning now why do we need
deep learning machine learning was there
for quite some time and it can do a lot
of stuff that probably what deep
learning can do but it's not very good
at handling large amounts of
unstructured data like images voice or
even text for that matter so traditional
machine learning is not that very good
at doing this traditional machine
learning can handle large amounts of
structured data but when it comes to
unstructured data it's a big challenge
so that is one of the key
differentiators for deep learning so
that is number one and increasingly for
artificial intelligence we need image
recognition and we need to process
analyze images and voice that's the
reason deep learning is required
compared to let's say traditional
machine learning it can also perform
complex algorithms more complex than
let's say what machine learning can do
and it can achieve best performance with
the large amounts of data so the more
you have the data let's say reference
data or label data the better the system
will do because the training process
will be that much better and last but
not least with deep learning you can
really avoid the manual process of
feature extraction those are some of the
reasons why we need deep learning some
of the applications of deep learning
deep learning has made major inroads and
it is a major area in which deep
learning is applied is healthcare and
within healthcare particularly oncology
which is basically cancer related stuff
one of the issues with cancer is that a
lot of cancers today are curable they
can be cured they are detected early on
and the challenge with that is when a
diagnostics is performed let's say an
image has been taken of a patient to
detect whether there is cancer or not
you need a specialist to look at the
image and determine whether it is the
patient is fine or there is any onset of
cancer and the number of specialists are
limited so if we use deep learning if we
use automation here or if we use
artificial intelligence here then the
system can with a certain amount of the
good amount of accuracy determine
whether a particular patient is having
cancer or not so the prediction or the
detection process of a disease like
cancer can be expedited the detection
process can be expedited can be faster
without really waiting for a specialist
we can obviously then once the
application once the artificial
intelligence detects or predicts that
there is an onset of a cancer this can
be cross-checked by a doctor but at
least the initial screening process can
be automated and that is where the
current focus is with respect to deep
learning in healthcare what else
robotics is another area deep learning
is majorly used in robotics and you must
have seen nowadays robots are everywhere
humanoids the industrial robots which
are used for manufacturing process you
must have heard about sofia who got
citizenship with saudi arabia and so on
there are multiple such robots which are
knowledge oriented but there are also
industrial robots are used in industries
in the manufacturing process and
increasingly in security and also in
defense for example image processing
video is fed to them and they need to be
able to detect objects obstacles and so
on and so forth so that's where deep
learning is used they need to be able to
hear and make sense of the sounds that
they are hearing that needs deep
learning as well so robotics is a major
area where deep learning is applied then
we have self-driving cars or autonomous
cars you must have heard of google's
autonomous car which has been tested for
millions of miles and pretty much
incident-free there were of course a
couple of incidents here and there but
it is
considered to be fairly safe and there
are today a lot of automotive companies
in fact pretty much every automotive
company worth its name is investing in
self-driving cars or autonomous cars and
it is predicted that in the next
probably 10 to 15 years these will be in
production and they will be used
extensively in real life right now they
are all in r d and in test phases but
pretty soon these will be on the road so
this is another area where deep learning
is used and how is it used where is it
used within autonomous driving the car
actually is fed with video of
surroundings and it is supposed to
process that information process that
video and determine if there are any
obstacles it has to determine if there
are any cars in the side will detect
whether it is driving in the lane also
it has to determine whether the signal
is green or red so that accordingly it
can move forward or wait so for all
these video analysis deep learning is
used in addition to that the training
overall training to drive the car
happens in a deep learning environment
so again a lot of scope here to use deep
learning a couple of other applications
are mission translation so today we have
a lot of information and very often this
information is in one particular
language and more specifically in
english and people need information in
various parts of the world it is pretty
difficult for human beings to translate
each and every piece of information or
every document into all possible
languages there are probably at least
hundreds of languages or if not more to
translate each and every document into
every language is
pretty difficult therefore we can use
deep learning to do pretty much like a
real time translation mechanism so we
don't have to translate everything and
keep it ready but we train applications
or artificial intelligence systems that
will do the translation on the fly for
example you go to somewhere like china
and you want to know what is written on
a sign board now it is impossible for
somebody to translate that and put it on
the web or something like that so you
have an application which is trained to
translate stuff on the fly so you
probably this can be running on your
mobile phone on your smartphone you scan
this the application will instantly
translate that from chinese to english
that is one then there could be web
applications where there may be a
research document which is all in maybe
chinese or japanese and you want to
translate that to study that document or
in that case you need to translate so
therefore deep learning is used in such
situations as well and that is again on
demand so it is not like you have to
translate all these documents from other
languages into english in one shot and
keep it somewhere that is again pretty
much an impossible task but on a need
basis so you have systems that are
trained to translate on the fly so
mission translation is another major
area where deep learning is used then
there are a few other upcoming areas
where synthesizing is done by neural
nets for example music composition and
generation of music so you can train a
neural net to produce music even to
compose music so this is a fun thing
this is still upcoming it needs a lot of
effort to train such neural net it has
been proved that it is possible so this
is a relatively new area and on the same
lines colorization of images so these
two images on the left hand side is a
grayscale image or a black and white
image this was colored by a neural net
or a deep learning application as you
can see it's done a very good job of
applying the colors and obviously this
was trained to do this colorization but
yes this is one more application of deep
learning now one of the major secret
sauce of deep learning is neural network
deep learning works on neural network or
consists of neural network so let us see
what is neural network neural network or
artificial neural network is designed or
based on the human brain now human brain
consists of billions of small cells that
are known as neurons artificial neural
networks is in a way trying to simulate
the human brain so this is a quick
diagram of biological neuron a
biological neuron consists of the major
part which is the cell nucleus and then
it has some tentacles kind of stuff on
the top called dendrite and then there
is like a long tail which is known as
the axon further again at the end of
this action are what are known as
synapses these in turn are connected to
the dendrites of the next neuron and all
these neurons are interconnected with
each other therefore they are like
billions of them sitting in our brain
and they're all active they're working
they based on the signals they receive
signals as inputs from other neurons or
maybe from other parts of the body and
based on certain criteria they send
signals to the neurons at the other end
so they they get either activated or
they don't get activated based on so it
is like a binary gates so they get
activated or not activated based on the
inputs that they receive and so on so we
will see a little bit of those details
as we move forward in our artificial
neuron but this is a biological neuron
this is the structure of a biological
neuron and artificial neural network is
based on the human brain the smallest
component of artificial neural network
is an artificial neuron as shown here
sometimes it's also referred to as
perceptron now this is a very high level
diagram the artificial neuron has a
small central unit which will receive
the input if it is doing let's say image
processing the inputs could be pixel
values of the image which is represented
here as x1 x2 and so on each of the
inputs are multiplied by what is known
as weights which are represented as w1
w2 and so on there is in the central
unit basically there is a summation of
these weighted inputs which is like x1
into w1 plus x2 into w2 and so on the
products are then added and then there
is a bias that is added to that in the
next slide we will see that passes
through an activation function and the
output comes as a y which is the output
and based on certain criteria the cell
gets either activated or not activated
so this output would be like a zero or a
one binary format okay so we will see
that in a little bit more detail but
let's do a quick comparison between
biological and artificial neurons just
like a biological neuron there are
dendrites and then there is a cell
nucleus and synapse and an axon we have
in the artificial neuron as well
these inputs come like the dendrite if
you will act like the dendrites there is
a like a central unit which performs the
summation of these
weighted inputs which is basically w1 x1
w2 x2 and so on and then a bias is added
here and then that passes through what
is known as an activation function okay
so these are known as the weights w1 w2
and then there is a bias which will come
out here and that is added the bias is
by the way common for a particular
neuron so there won't be like b1 b2 b3
and so on only weights will be one per
input the bias is common for the entire
neuron it is also common for or the
value of the bias remains the same for
all the neurons in a particular layer we
will also see this as we move forward
and we see deep neural network where
there are multiple neurons so that's the
output now the whole exercise of
training the neuron is about changing
these weights and biases as i mentioned
this artificial neural network will
consist of several such neurons and as a
part of the training process these
weights keep changing initially they are
assigned some random values through the
training process the weights the whole
process of training is to come up with
the optimum values of w1 w2 and wn and
then the b for or the bias for this
particular neuron such that it gives an
accurate output as required so let's see
what exactly that means so the training
process this is how it happens it takes
the inputs each input is multiplied by a
weight and these weights during training
keep changing so initially they are
assigned some random values and based on
the output whether it is correct or
wrong there is a feedback coming back
and that will basically change these
weights until it starts giving the right
output that is represented in here as
sigma i going from 1 to n if there are n
inputs wi into x i so this is the
product of w1 x1 w2 x2 and so on right
and there is a bias that gets added here
and that entire thing goes to what is
known as an activation function so
essentially this is sigma of w i x i
plus a value of bias which is a b so
that entire thing goes as an input to an
activation function now this activation
function takes this as an input gives
the output as a binary output it could
be a zero or a one there are of course
to start with let's assume it's a binary
output later we will see that there are
different types of activation functions
so it need not always be binary output
but to start with let's keep simple so
it decides whether the neuron should be
fired or not so that is the output like
a binary output zero or one all right so
again let me summarize this so it takes
the inputs so if you're processing an
image for example the inputs are the
pixel values of the image x1 x2 up to xn
there could be hundreds of these so all
of those are fed as so these are some
values and these pixel values again can
be from 0 to 56 each of those pixel
values are then multiplied with what is
known as a weight this is a numeric
value can be any value so this is a
number w1 similarly w2 is a number so
initially some random values will be
assigned and each of these weights are
multiplied with the input value and
their sum this is known as the weighted
sum so that is performed in this kind of
the central unit and then a bias is
added remember the bias is common for
each neuron so this is not the bias
value is not one
bias value for per input so just keep
that in mind the bias value there is one
bias per neuron so it is like this
summation plus bias is the output from
this section this is not the complete
output of the neuron but this is a bias
for output for step one that goes as an
input to what is known as activation
function and that activation function
results in an output usually a binary
output like a zero or a one which is
known as the firing of the neuron okay
good so we talked about activation
function so what is an activation
function an activation function
basically takes the weighted sum which
is we saw w1 x1 w2 x2 the sum of all
that plus the bias so it takes that as
an input and it generates a certain
output now there are different types of
activation functions and the output is
different for different types of
activation functions moreover why is an
activation function required it is
basically required to bring in
non-linearity that's the main reason why
an activation function is required so
what are the different types of
activation functions there are several
types of activation functions but these
are the most common ones these are the
ones that are currently in use sigmoid
function was one of the early activation
functions but today relu has kind of
taken over so relu is by far the most
popular activation function that is used
today but still sigmoid function is
still used in many situations these
different types of activation functions
are used in different situations based
on the kind of problem we are trying to
solve so what exactly is the difference
between these two sigmoid gives the
values of the output will be between 0
and 1. threshold function is the value
will be
0 up to a certain value and beyond that
this is also known as a step function
and beyond that it will be 1. in case of
sigmoid there is a gradual increase but
in case of threshold it's like also
known as a step function there is a
rapid or instantaneous change from 0 to
1 whereas in sigmoid we will see in the
next slide there is a gradual increase
but the value in this case is between 0
and 1 as well now relu function on the
other hand it is equal to basically if
the input is 0 or less than 0 then the
output is 0 whereas if the input is
greater than 0 then the output is equal
to the input i know it's a little
confusing but in the next slides where
we show the relu function it will become
clear similarly hyperbolic tangent this
is similar to sigmoid in terms of the
shape of the function however while
sigmoid goes from zero to one hyperbolic
tangent goes from minus one to one and
here again the increase or the change
from -1 to 1 is gradual and not like
threshold or step function where it
happens instantaneously so let's take a
little detailed look at some of these
functions so let's start with the
sigmoid function so this is the equation
of a sigmoid function which is 1 by 1
plus e to the power of minus x so x is
the value that is the input it goes from
0 to -1 so this is sigmoid function the
equation is phi x is equal to 1 by 1
plus e to the power of minus x and as
you can see here this is the input on
the x axis as x is the value is coming
from in fact it can also go negative
this is negative actually so this is the
zero so this is the negative value of x
so as x is coming from negative value
towards zero the value of the output
slowly as it is approaching
zero it it slowly and very gently
increases and actually at the point let
me just use a pen at the point here it
is it is 0.5 it is actually 0.5 okay and
slowly gradually it increases to 1 as
the value of x increases but then as the
value of x increases it tapers off it
doesn't go beyond 1 so that is the
speciality of sigmoid function so the
output value will remain between 0 and
one it will never go below zero or above
one okay then so that is sigmoid
function now this is threshold function
or this is also referred to as a step
function and here we can also set the
threshold in this case it is that's why
it's called the threshold function
normally it is zero but you can also set
a different value for the threshold now
the difference between this and the
sigmoid is that here the change is rapid
or instantaneous as the x value comes
from negative up to zero it remains zero
and at zero it pretty much immediately
increases to one okay so this is a
mathematical representation of threshold
function phi x is equal to one if x is
greater than equal to 0 and 0 if x is
less than 0. so for all negative values
it is 0 which since we have set the
threshold to be 0. so as soon as it
reaches 0 it becomes 1. you see the
difference between this and the previous
one which is basically the sigmoid where
the increase from 0 to 1 is gradual and
here it is instantaneous and that's why
this is also known as a step function
threshold function or step function this
is a relu a relu is one of the most
popular activation functions today this
is the definition of relu phi x is equal
to max of x comma 0. what it says is if
the value of x is less than 0 then phi x
is
0 the moment it increases goes beyond
zero the value of phi x is equal to x so
it doesn't stop at one actually it goes
all the way so as the value of x
increases the value of y will also
increase infinitely so there is no limit
here unlike your sigmoid or threshold or
the next one which is basically
hyperbolic tangent okay so in case of
relu remember there is no upper limit
the output is equal to either 0 in case
the value of x is negative or it is
equal to the value of x so for example
here if the value of x is 10 then the
value of y is also 10 right okay so that
is relu and there are several advantages
of relu and it is much more efficient
and provides much more accuracy compared
to other activation functions like
sigmoid and so on so that's the reason
it is very popular all right so this is
hyperbolic tangent activation function
the function looks similar to sigmoid
function the curve if you see the shape
it looks similar to sigmoid function but
the difference between hyperbolic
tangent and sigmoid function is that in
case of sigmoid the output goes from
zero to one whereas in case of
hyperbolic tangent it goes from minus
one to one so that is the difference
between hyperbolic tangent and sigmoid
function otherwise the shape looks very
similar there is a gradual increase
unlike the step function where there was
an instant increase or instant change
here again very similar to sigmoid
function the value changes gradually
from -1 to 1. so this is the equation of
hyperbolic tangent activation function
yeah so then let's move on this is a
diagrammatic representation of the
activation function and how the overall
data how the overall progression happens
from input to the output so we get the
input from the input layer by the way
the neural network has three layers
typically there will be three layers
there is an input layer there is an
output layer and then you have the
hidden layer so the inputs come from the
input layer and they get processed in
the hidden layer and then you get the
output in the output layer so let's take
a little bit of a detailed look into the
working of a neural network so let's say
we want to classify some images between
dogs and cats how do we do this this is
known as a classification process and we
are trying to use neural networks and
deep learning to implement this
classification so how do we do that so
this is how it works so you have four
layer neural network there is an input
layer there is an output layer and then
there are two hidden layers and what we
do is we provide labeled training data
which means these images are fed to the
network with the label saying that okay
this is a cat the neural network is
allowed to process it and come up with a
prediction saying whether it is a cat or
a dog and obviously in the beginning
there may be mistakes a cat may be
classified as a dog so we then say that
okay this is wrong this output is wrong
but every time it predicts correctly we
say yes this output is correct so that
learning process so it will go back make
some changes to its weights and biases
we again feed these inputs and it will
give us the output we will check whether
it is correct or not and so on so this
is a iterative process which is known as
the training process so we are training
the neural network and what happens in
the training process these weights and
biases you remember there were weights
like w1 w2 and so on so these weights
and biases keep changing every time you
feed these which is known as an epoch so
there are multiple iterations every
iteration is known as an epoch and each
time the weights are dated to make sure
that the maximum number of images are
classified correctly so once again what
is the input this input could be like
1000 images of cats and dogs and they
are labeled because we know which is a
cat and which is a dog and we feed those
thousand images the neural network will
initially assign some weights and biases
for each neuron and it will try to
process extract the features from the
images and it will try to come up with a
prediction for each image and that
prediction that is calculated by the
network is compared with the actual
value whether it is a cat or a dog and
that's how the error is calculated so
let's say there are thousand images and
in the first run only 500 of them have
been correctly classified that means we
are getting only 50 accuracy so we feed
that information back to the network
further update these weights and biases
for each of the neurons and we run this
these inputs once again it will try to
calculate extract the features and it
will try to predict which of these is
cats and dogs and this time let's say
out of thousand 700 of them have been
predicted correctly so that means in the
second iteration the accuracy has
increased from 50 to 70 percent all
right then we go back again we feed this
maybe for a third iteration fourth
iteration and so on and slowly and
steadily the accuracy of this network
will keep increasing and it may reach
probably you never know 90
95 percent and there are several
parameters that are known as hyper
parameters that need to be changed and
tweaked and that is the overall training
process and ultimately at some point we
say okay you will probably never reach
100 accuracy but then we set a limit
saying that okay if we receive 95
percent accuracy that is good enough for
our application and then we say okay our
training process is done so that is the
way training happens and once the
training is done now with the training
data set the system has let's say seen
all these thousand images therefore what
we do is the next step like in any
normal machine learning process we do
the testing where we take a fresh set of
images and we feed it to the network the
fresh set which it has not seen before
as a part of the training process and
this is again nothing new in deep
learning this was there in machine
learning as well so you feed the test
images and then find out whether we are
getting a similar accuracy or not so
maybe that accuracy may reduce a little
bit while training you may get 98
percent and then for tests you may get
95 percent but there shouldn't be a
drastic drop like for example you get 98
percent in training and then you get 50
or 40 percent with the test that means
your network has not learned you may
have to retrain your network so that is
the way neural network training works
and remember the whole process is about
changing these weights and biases and
coming up with the optimal values of
these weights and biases so that the
accuracy is the maximum possible all
right so a little bit more detail about
how this whole thing works so this is
known as forward propagation which is
the data or the information is going in
the forward direction the inputs are
taken weighted summation is done bias is
added here and then that is fed to the
activation function and then that is
that comes out as an output so that is
forward propagation and the output is
compared with the actual value and that
will give us the error the difference
between them is the error and in
technical terms that is also known as
our cost function and this is what we
would like to minimize there are
different ways of defining the cost
function but one of the simplest ways is
mean square error so it is nothing but
the square of the difference of the
errors or the sum of the squares of the
difference of the errors and this is
also nothing new we have probably if
you're familiar with machine learning
you must have come across this mean
square now there are different ways of
defining cost function it need not
always be the mean square error but the
most common one is this so you define
this cost function and you ask the
system to minimize this error so we use
what is known as an optimization
function to minimize this error and the
error itself sent back to the system as
feedback and that is known as back
propagation and so this is the cost
function and how do we optimize the cost
function we use what is known as
gradient descent so the gradient descent
mechanism identifies how to change the
weights and biases so that the cost
function is minimized and there is also
what is known as the rate or the
learning rate that is what is shown here
as slower and faster so you need to
specify what should be the learning rate
now if the learning rate is very small
then it will probably take very long to
train whereas if the learning rate is
very high then it will appear to be
faster but then it will probably never
what is known as converge now what is
convergence now we are talking about a
few terms here convergence is like this
this is a representation of convergence
so the whole idea of gradient descent is
to optimize the cost function or
minimize the cost function in order to
do that we need to represent the cost
function as this curve we need to come
to this minimum value that is what is
known as the minimization of the cost
function now what happens if we have the
learning rate very small is that it will
take very long to come to this point on
the other hand if you have large higher
learning rate what will happen is
instead of stopping here it will cross
over because the learning rate is high
and then it has to come back so it will
result in what is known as like an
oscillation so it will never come to
this point which is known as convergence
instead it will go back and forth so
these are known as hyper parameters the
learning rate and so on and these have
to be those numbers or those values we
can determine typically using trial and
error out of experience we we try to
find out these values so that is the
gradient descent mechanism to optimize
the cost function and that is what is
used to train our neural network this is
another representation of how the
training process works and here in this
example we are trying to classify these
images whether they are cats or dogs and
as you can see actually each image is
fed in each time one image is fed rather
and these values of x1 x2 up to xn are
the pixel values within this image okay
so those values are then taken and for
each of those values a weight is
multiplied and then it goes to the next
layer and then to the next layer and so
on ultimately it comes as the output
layer and it gives an output as whether
it is a dog or a cat remember the output
will never be a named output so these
would be like a zero or a one and we say
okay zero corresponds to dogs and one
corresponds to cats so that is the way
it typically happens this is a binary
classification we have similar
situations where there can be multiple
classes which means that there will be
multiple more neurons in the output
layer okay so this is once again a quick
representation of how the forward
propagation and the backward propagation
works so the information is going in
this direction which is basically the
forward propagation and at the output
level
we find out what is the cost function
the difference is basically sent back as
part of the backward propagation and
gradient descent then adjust the weights
and biases for the next titration this
happens iteratively till the cost
function is minimized and that is when
we say the whole the network has
converged or the training process has
converged and there can be situations
where convergence may not happen in rare
cases but by and large the network will
converge and after maybe a few
iterations it could be
tens of iterations or hundreds of
iterations depending on what exactly the
number of iterations can vary and then
we say okay we are getting a certain
accuracy and we say that is our
threshold maybe 90 percent accuracy we
stop at that and we say that the system
is trained the trained model is then
deployed for production and so on so
that is the way the neural network
training happens okay so that is the way
classification works in deep learning
using neural network and this slide is
an animation of this whole process as
you can see the forward propagation the
data is going forward from the input
layer to the output layer and there is
an output
and the error is calculated the cost
function is calculated and that is fed
back as a part of backward propagation
and that whole process repeats once
again okay so remember in neural
networks the training process is nothing
but the finding the best values of the
weights and biases for each and every
neuron in the network that's all
training of neural network consists of
finding the optimal values of the
weights and biases so that the accuracy
is maximum and i am going to take you
through the process of setting up this
tensorflow development environment as
some of you may be aware it's not that
easy to set up the tensorflow
environment there are several components
there are several possibilities for
example
you can set up on windows you can set up
on ubuntu now ubuntu has multiple
versions which version to use and then
you have python which release of python
to use whether to do a pip install
whether to do install using anaconda and
how do you then link it up with jupiter
notebook these are multiple
possibilities and it takes up a lot of
time to try all of these so today what
i'm going to do is show you a tried and
tested method of setting up the
tensorflow environment and this will
help primarily those who are starting
with tensorflow so that they don't have
to waste so much time on setting up the
environment in experimenting with the
installation and setting up of the
environment now what we are going to do
is i will show you a method by which you
you know it is a tried and tested method
and of course
tensorflow home page has a install page
and it shows you some ways to install
but again the challenge is the same
there are multiple versions multiple
methods shown there so it's highly
confusing for somebody who is new as to
decide which one which path to take so
in today's session what we are going to
do is we will set up tensorflow on
ubuntu and i am going to show you in a
virtual box but then if you are using a
laptop with ubuntu installed you can
straight away use the same method
however we need to keep one thing in
mind that the various releases and
versions of ubuntu and python and
tensorflow not all of them are
compatible with each other so these
versions and releases need to be very
specific so i will tell you which is the
version and releases what combination is
best suited for you to get started and
later on of course you can then
experiment with other possibilities and
other releases and so on once you get
familiar with tensorflow to start with i
would also like to mention that it is a
good idea to install or start with
ubuntu environment or linux any other
linux also but here we will focus on
ubuntu rather than windows so for those
who are already let's say using a
windows system the question may arise
what do we do but there is a easy option
as you can see i'm actually using a
virtual box so you need to install
virtualbox let me just show you so this
is the virtual box oracle vm virtual box
and there are tons of videos on youtube
how to install a virtual box and how to
create ubuntu image i think we will not
spend time on that but if you're using
windows and my preference would be to
set up a virtual box and set up your
environment in ubuntu image so we will
start by assuming that you have an
ubuntu environment especially release
14.04 lts there are multiple ubuntu
versions and again we will not try to
get the latest and the greatest versions
or latest and greatest releases but the
focus here is to take the releases and
versions which are working and where you
will not waste time so the setup process
will be smooth if you stick to these
releases you can of course experiment
later on with other versions and try out
but here we will be working with ubuntu
1404 lts and we will use python 3.4 and
we will use tensorflow 1.5 this is a
tried and tested combination and i would
also recommend that you use the same if
you want a smooth start and so let's get
started with that
let me login to my ubuntu system okay so
we have the ubuntu system running here
now if you go to tensorflow.org there is
a page which
mentions how to install tensorflow and
as you can see there are multiple
possibilities you have ubuntu you have
windows and
mac os and so on and so forth and if you
go to ubuntu for example further you
will get
multiple options whether you want cpu or
gpu and
whether you want to do a pip install or
using a virtual native pip virtual env
anaconda and so on and so forth so all
these options are
very complicated or rather very
confusing i would say not complicated
depending on whether you're expert or of
course i am talking about beginners here
but if you click on some of these
options they may look very easy so for
example if you go back and
if you select for example native pip it
may appear like oh this is just you know
one
single or two steps and that's about it
everything gets installed you see here
it should be just one step install it
you say p3 install tensorflow and
everything gets installed unfortunately
it doesn't work that way so it's not as
easy as so don't get kind of fooled by
the simplicity of the of the
documentation here again it's not their
fault because of the multiple
combinations of releases and so on and
so forth it is not that easy so what we
will do is we will take a slightly
roundabout method which is using
anaconda which has a few more steps but
you're sure that this is going to work
so that is what we are going to do and
that's what i am going to show you so
what are the steps involved of course i
will not go exactly by what they have
mentioned here as i said i will show you
the steps which are again sure shot to
work whereas uh here again if you follow
just this document there will be some
variations which they have kind of not
documented so that's the reason i will
show you the steps separately all right
so these are the main four steps you
need to download and install anaconda
and then create a virtual environment
with python and the release as i
mentioned is python 3.4 and we will
install tensorflow version 1.5 and then
we will install and configure jupyter
which will be our development
environment all right so let's get
started this is our ubuntu and let's get
a terminal started here and
okay yes so
all right so we started the terminal and
then what we'll also do is we'll go to
the anaconda website because we need to
install anaconda we need to download and
install anaconda so for that you need to
go to the anaconda website so you can
just open a browser and
google and you will find anaconda
website
so this is the site anaconda.org
click on this link and it will take you
to the anaconda website
you don't have to sign up or anything
like that just look for the download
anaconda
so just click on that it will take you
to the download pages and it
automatically recognizes that you are on
ubuntu so it will show you the links to
download all right so as you can see it
is
recognized that you are on a linux
operating system so
you can just click on this download and
it will start the download there are two
versions of course python with python
3.6 and 2.7 i
recommend you start with python 3.6 now
just want to clarify that we will be
actually using python 3.4 this is just
for
the
initial installation but subsequently
when we set up the virtual environment
you will see there is one more step
where we set up the virtual environment
there we will actually be using python
3.4 so just that you are not confused
all right so
it has started the download we just say
no thanks for this and it is downloading
while it is downloading you can
click on this
link saying how to install anaconda so
there are a couple of steps mentioned
there that we will be using so let me
just in the meanwhile click on this for
some reason the network is a little slow
so it's taking time all right so
once the download is done we will be
using the options that are mentioned
here now the first step of course is we
we are already doing the first step
which is downloading the installer for
linux the second step is not mandatory
so it's an optional step most often you
can actually skip that and third step is
what we are going to do and
since we are using at this point we are
using python 3.6 we should use this
command so basically the terminal we
have opened here is is to use or to run
this command that's the reason i opened
this terminal however make sure that the
download is complete before you run this
command so we'll just wait for a couple
of minutes and we'll come back once the
download is done all right so as you can
see the download is done this is a
fairly large file so if you are on a
slow internet or low internet bandwidth
then it might take quite a while it's
about uh
578 mb and uh so this is the file now
what you need to do is uh you need to go
back to this installation steps and let
me minimize this and
yeah so
this is the command that you need to run
so you can just directly copy and paste
this command from here
okay so i do copy right mouse like
now it will ask you a bunch of questions
as documented here so most of them you
need to just say enter or yes and that's
about it except for the last step i will
just show you what i mean and here you
need to do press enter multiple times
just to make sure you agree to all these
agreement
the license agreement and so on and so
forth so once you do
multiple
enters it will
bring you to the next step
all right so now here again they say do
you accept the terms you just say yes
and then press enter and here it will
ask you a couple of questions and pretty
much you need to just go for the default
version press enter to confirm you just
say press enter and
this is primarily when it will
pretty much start the installation
process of anaconda this might take a
little while depending again on your
internet speed so you need to have some
patience we will also probably come back
once this installation is done or if it
asks for any further questions
all right so here you'll get again one
more question do you used to
wish the installer to pre-pen
so you just say yes for this question
and
keep going now the last question
i think we are pretty much at the end
and that is about microsoft
vss i guess yeah vs code so for this you
can just say no because we will not be
using this
and
that's it you're done so this is a
completion of installation of anaconda
so it's always a good idea to exit and
start a fresh terminal
okay so
let's start again terminal
so we are done with the
installation of anaconda the next step
is to create a virtual environment with
python 3.4 so for that this is the
command conda create dash n
and this is the name of your virtual
environment you can give any name but
for easy reference i have given us
tensorflow and
we have to specify the python version as
i mentioned earlier we will be using the
combination of python 3.4
and
tensorflow 1.5 now this is not the
latest version python has probably 3.6
at this point at the time of creation of
this video and even tensorflow probably
has the latest version as 1.7 but then
these combinations sometimes may not
work and i found that after several
trials and errors 3.4 with 1.5 seems to
be most reliable and that's the reason i
have chosen this i would recommend you
to try with this first if you are a
beginner and later on maybe you can try
out the other permutations and
combinations all right one step i just
wanted to show you is before we do the
installation or creation of the virtual
environment if you want to just clarify
or confirm whether anaconda has been
installed or not you can run what is
known as anaconda navigator so you just
say anaconda
navigator
okay we need to edit this part hold on
one second i guess it is
all right so you see here when you start
anaconda navigator
this
anaconda navigator will open up that is
the indication that anaconda has been
installed
properly so that's just a quick check
and you don't have to do anything just
you can go back and close it
once this comes up and
then in the meanwhile let me just open
one more terminal
for the creation of the
virtual environment and
yeah so this is your anaconda navigator
and you can just say okay don't show me
just say okay
and
then you can close this
you can say file you can do a file exit
or you can click on close button
whichever
all right so we will exit from here
we have a
terminal open here we will use this for
our next steps all right so what we have
to do now is
type in
this
piece of
code
or this command
for some reason copy paste is not
working so
it's a small command so it shouldn't be
that big of an issue so we say
conda and we say
create
so this is the command for creating a
new environment slash
dash n
and then we give the name of the
environment so we will we can give any
name for
convenience i'm just calling it
tensorflow
but you can actually name it anything
and then we need to specify with the
which version of python so we say pip
python
and then that is equal
3.4 okay so it will create an
environment this will take a little
while it will ask you a question just
say yes and then it will be done
so this is just a warning you can simply
ignore that
and
for the question that it asks you just
say yes and i think you should be good
all right so it says uh do you want to
proceed you say yes then enter
this will again take a little bit little
time so we will probably move forward
and then come back once this is done
all right so
the environment has been created now
it's always a good idea to whenever some
of these steps get over or each step
gets over you just exit the terminal and
start afresh with the new terminal for
some reason sometimes it causes problem
if you continue so i found that it is
a safe practice to each time exit the
terminal and start afresh now that we
have an environment created
we can by the name tensorflow
you can
enter that environment by calling the
command source
activate
tensorflow to name whatever name you
have given so you'll see here once you
do that you will get this the name of
the environment will be shown here so it
is like your own again a special
environment within within the system and
uh from here onwards you can do other
stuff like actually installing
tensorflow and so on and you will see
that it has installed python 3 here so
3.4 right so it is installed that's what
we during creation of this environment
we wanted python 3.4 so that is what it
is showing but we are not yet done so we
need to still install tensorflow so in
this environment you need to
run a command which will actually
install the correct combination of
tensorflow now this is as you can see
it's a slightly complicated command pip
install
dash dash ignore install so
what we can do is
from within here we can go and
go to tensorflow
install page and there is a sample code
there you can pick up from there so that
you don't have to type in
so much
so we say tensorflow
tensor
flow
dark and i'll also open up probably a
notepad here so that we can construct
that command and go here
you say
ubuntu if you come further down there
will be by the way we are doing cpu
installation i think
that is clear we are not there is a
possibility to do gpu as well we will
probably create a separate video for
that and
if we go here
yeah so
again you probably if you follow the
entire document out here it may still
not work so i do not recommend that for
now at least for beginners but just to
copy this command because this is a
fairly complicated command so this is
much easier to copy it from here that's
the reason
on this page
and we will
then modify it according to yes okay
let's say
copy
and don't do it directly here because
that is probably not yet the right
command
let us go and create a notepad
page
empty document
i'll just say
tf.txt
okay this is just a temporary file what
we need to do here is we need to adjust
this command to suit the
versions that we are installing here so
let me just explain what it is what you
need to do
so first thing you can get rid of this
one yes okay
now here these parts you can simply
ignore
here you need to go and change it to
version
1.5
and i think we are good with that okay
so the cp34 indicates your python 3.4
so later on when you're trying to
experiment and if you want to
do
other combinations of tensorflow and
python version then you can change this
for example you can change this to 3 6
both these places you need to change
this to 3 6 if you are using with python
3.6 and similarly if you want the latest
version which is of tensorflow which is
1.7 you need to change this to 1.7 and
so on but at this point to start with if
you're a beginner i would recommend that
you stick to this tensorflow 1.5 with
python 3.4 this is tried and tested and
it works okay just a word of caution
that just by changing these versions
the whole thing
will not work there may be
other places where you may have to some
of the steps may change so just a word
of caution that just by changing this if
you want to try out with a different
version some of the steps may also
change so don't think that just by
changing this just one particular
command you will be uh fine okay so
that's been my experience so to start
with i would recommend use this
particular combination all right so it
looks good
uh tensorflow 1.5 and
let me
just reconfirm with my notes and i think
it looks good so this is install ignore
1.5 cp34 cp34
and so on okay
okay so let's hit enter
so it started the process again this
might take a little while so we will
pause the recording and then get back
when the
installation is done okay so
looks like this installation is done
and as always let us
exit and then come back now
you're currently in the environment
virtual environment um and it's a good
practice before you exit out of the
terminal to come out doctor out of the
virtual environment so just like you did
source activate you need to do source
deactivate
and
the name tensor
flow okay you will come back to the
original command prompt and then from
here you can
do an exit now we need to validate
whether the tensorflow installation has
gone through properly or not so
the way to validate is to
first start python and then import
tensorflow library see if it imports
without error so that's the best way to
validate so we'll open a terminal
and whenever you want to get into
the
environment this is how you have to do
come to environment and then say source
and obviously you can also use existing
so source activate
tensorflow okay
so we do this and you need to run python
from here remember you should say
python3 because you have installed item
3.4 now here when you say import
tensorflow
as df
when you get back a prompt like this
without any errors that means tensorflow
installation has been successful if
tensorflow was not installed properly
you will get an error saying tensorflow
is not available or module doesn't exist
or something like that so tensorflow
installation is done but now we will go
through the process of installing
jupyter notebook so that you can do your
development so let me just exit
and in order to install your jupyter
notebook which is your which is going to
be your development environment we will
first
install ipython using conda so conda
install ipython and then pip install
jupiter so let's first do the
ipython conda
install
python
again it will ask you a question saying
these are the components do you want to
install you just say yes
all right you say yes
once again it will take a little while
so we might pause the recording and come
back once it is done
great so that did not take much
time anyways so we will
as usual we will
exit which is
source deactivate
tensorflow
exit and then we will start a fresh
terminal
in order to install
jupiter
now uh in some places uh they may say um
install jupiter using pic3 but in my
experience it did not work with big
three and that's the reason we will use
pip
however just keep in mind you need to
first go to the environment so
source activate
tensorflow
and you need to use this command which
is pip install jupyter usually when you
are on python3 you use pip3 but as i
said it did not work so
in my experience it works with pip
install and not p3 so pip install
jupiter
i hope you already noticed that it is
j-u-p-y d-e-r
and not jbi
so again it's probably taking a little
while we will pause the recording and
come back once it is done
okay so jupiter installation is also
done
once again
you need to it's a good idea not you
need to but it's a good idea to
come out of this terminal session and
then start afresh
so we exit and we have a fresh terminal
already available here
and we will once again
go to tensorflow
and we say
jupiter
notebook
that's how you start your jupiter
so this looks good now only thing is
since we are running
uh for the first time what you need to
do is if you come back to your command
prompt
it will show you that if you are running
it for the first time it will say that
you need to copy paste this link so you
you can just for the first time only
once you need to do this
copy this
and
paste it in your
browser
and remember this is only the first time
when you're running jupyter you need to
do this
subsequently you don't have to it will
automatically
open up all right so now that we have
jupyter installed and
it starts up we need to test whether
tensorflow
is working fine or not and in order to
do that you can create a new
notebook
and you say
import
tensorflow
as tf and shift enter if everything is
fine tensorflow is installed properly
you don't get any errors and then it
works fine this is
an indication that tensorflow got
installed successfully
and that's about it so
that's all about installing tensorflow
with python 3.4 so remember this is
installation of tensorflow 1.5 with
python 3.4
on ubuntu and
once again in case you have a windows
system in fact i have also done it on a
windows system you can
use virtual blocks to create a virtual
environment
ubuntu environment and then follow these
steps and there are tons of videos to
create virtual box and that's the reason
uh we have not included those steps in
this
and if there are any comments there are
better ways to do this please mention it
in the comment section below or if you
need any further help just mention it
and with your email they will respond to
you in order to develop a deep learning
application how do you go about
primarily there are two or three
components that are required in order to
develop deep learning application you
need obviously a programming language so
typically python is used and that's what
we are going to use in this particular
video but you can also use other
languages like java or c plus plus and
so on and there are some libraries that
are readily available and different
primarily for doing
machine learning and deep learning
programming so these are a list of
libraries these are by no means the
exhaustive list but some of the most
common ones like keras thiano tensorflow
and so on and so forth tensorflow has
nowadays become very very popular this
is developed by google and it is an open
source library and keros was there
before now keras has actually now become
a part of tensorflow as well so it is
one player about tensorflow so in that
sense they're well integrated so
combination of keras and tensorflow is
pretty good then of course you have a
torch and tl4j and so on and so forth so
there are multiple libraries but this
video is about tensorflow and we will be
focusing on tensorflow what are the
benefits of tensorflow and what are its
components and our towards the end we
will show you a code in python we've
written a code in python by the way
tensorflow can be used with multiple
languages it supports multiple languages
though python is by far the most popular
language so let's take a look at what
exactly is tensorflow and why we are so
excited about tensorflow so tensorflow
offers um apis now we can earlier
without when these libraries none of
these libraries were there even then we
were doing people were doing machine
learning and deep learning and so on but
the coding mechanism was much more
complicated what these libraries like
tensorflow offer is they provide kind of
a high level api so that we don't have
to go really deep into writing all the
stuff that is required let's say to
prepare a neural network and to even
configure or even to program a neuron
and so on right so these are done by the
library so all you need to do is they
offer a higher level api you need to use
that api and call that api and maybe
pass the data and that would pretty much
it's much easier rather than actually
going down and writing everything by
yourself so tensorflow that way it
offers apis for to write your code in
python or even c plus plus and so on
other languages java as well it has an
integration with r as well apparently
okay and it supports cpus as well as
gpus now deep learning applications are
very compute intensive especially the
training process needs a lot of
computation it takes very long as you
can imagine that because the the data
size is large and there are so many
iterative processes there are so much of
mathematical calculations matrix
multiplication and so on and so forth so
for that if you perform these activities
on a normal cpu typically it would take
much longer but gpus are graphical
processing units you must have heard
gpus in the context of games and so on
because where you need the screen needs
to be of high resolution and the images
need to be of high resolution and so on
so gpus there as the name such as
graphical processing unit were
originally designed for that but since
they are very good at handling this kind
of iterative calculations and so on now
they are kind of they are being used or
leveraged rather for doing or developing
deep learning applications and
tensorflow supports gpus as well as cpus
so i think that's one of the major
advantages of tensorflow as well now
again what is exactly tensorflow it's a
open source library developed by google
and open source and primarily for deep
learning development but tensorflow also
supports traditional machine learning by
the way so if you want to do some
traditional machine learning we can do
it however it is probably a bit of a
overhead to use tensorflow for doing
traditional machine learning and this is
really good for performing deep learning
activities and again if you want to get
into more details about what's the
difference between machine learning and
deep learning there is another video
about it you can probably take a look at
that video what else it is developed
originally for large numerical
computation so originally when
tensorflow was developed they never
thought of it as keeping deep learning
in mind but ultimately it so happened
that it's really very good for deep
learning development and therefore
google has open sourced it and
tensorflow as the name suggests the data
is in the form of what is known as
tensors these are like multi-dimensional
arrays and they are very handy in
handling large amounts of data and we
will see that as well as we move forward
and then of course the execution
mechanism is in the form of graphs so
that makes it much easier to execute
this code in a distributed manner across
a cluster of computers and and also
using gpus and so on and so forth right
so that's a quick overview about what is
tensorflow we will see a little bit more
detail the two major components that is
basically the tensors and the graphs
let's take a look at what they are so
what are tensors tensor is as i
mentioned earlier it is like a
multi-dimensional array in which the
data is stored now when we are doing
deep learning especially the training
process you will have large amounts of
data and the data is in typically in a
very complicated format and it really
helps when you're able to put this use
this or store it in a compact way and so
tensors actually offer a very nice and
compact way of storing the data handling
the data during computation this is not
really for storing on your hard disk or
things like that but in memory when you
are doing the computation tenses are
really really very handy in terms of
keeping the data compact because they
are like multi-dimensional arrays so the
data is stored in tensors and then it is
fed into the neural network and then you
get the output all right so there are
some terms associated with tensors let's
get ourselves familiarized one is uh the
dimension and another is the rank so
what is dimension typically dimension is
like the number of elements in a way so
for example this is a five by four
dimension tensor and then you can have
again the multi dimensions right so you
can this can be like three by three by
three so that is uh the dimension and
then you have ranks so what are tensor
ranks ranks are basically traditionally
we would have thought of as dimensions
that is actually in this case it is
called rank so it becomes easier when we
see examples so a tensor's rank is
supposed to be zero when there is only
one element we also call this as scalar
so just one element and this is not
really a vector it's just an element
like 200 it's also known as a scalar so
such a tensor is supposed to be having a
rank of zero then you have let's say a
one dimensional array this is a vector
with a row of elements this has rank of
one now if you have traditionally what
we called as a two dimensional like a
matrix for example then the rank is two
and in this case the rank is three and
it can have more ranks as well as i
mentioned it is like a multi-dimensional
array so you can have rank five six and
so on okay so those are the
terminologies in tensorflow terms
dimensions and ranks so this is just to
make sure that we are picking the same
language so whenever we talk about the
rank of a tensor you understand what
exactly is meant by that now in addition
to tensors in which the data is actually
stored all right so the data is stored
in the tensors and then once you have
the data there is a computation that
needs to be done now the computation
happens in the form of graphs so what we
typically in a tensorflow program what
we do is it's not like traditional
programming where you just write a bunch
of lines and then everything gets
executed in sequence here we prepare
graphs various nodes and then these are
executed in the form of a session and
they use the data from these tensors now
i know this is a slightly new concept
for a lot of you so it may be a little
difficult to probably understand in the
first cut but when we look at the code
when we go into the tutorial the code
walkthrough i think that time it will
become much clearer as well but to start
with just uh we need to keep in mind
that we have to first prepare a graph
and when you're preparing the graph no
none of the code is actually getting
executed you write the code to prepare
the graph and then you execute that
graph so that's the way by creating a
session that's the way tensorflow
program works so and each of these
computation is represented as what is
known as a data flow graph and we will
also see that whenever you start
tensorflow when you create an object
tensorflow object there will be what is
known as the default graph and then if
required i know probably in the
beginning it may not be required but in
more advanced programming you can
actually have multiple graphs instead of
the default graph you can create your
own graph and have multiple graphs and
use it as well but there is always
whenever you create a tensorflow object
there will be a default graph and this
will be very nicely illustrated in the
example code that we will take to
explain this so there it becomes much
clearer than in these slides so the
graph gets executed and it processes all
the data that we are feeding all the
external data will be fed in the form of
what is known as placeholders and then
you have variables and constants again
this will also become clear when we take
a look at the code and once you have the
graph then the execution can be enabled
either on regular cpus or on gpus and
also in a distributed mode so that the
processing becomes much faster as i
mentioned the training of the models in
deep learning takes extremely long
because of the large amount of data and
therefore using tensorflow actually
makes it much easier to write the code
for gpus or cpus and then execute it in
a distributed manner so this is how the
tensorflow program looks so there is uh
you need to build a computational graph
that's the first step and then you
execute that graph so the first step is
to write the code for preparing the
graph and then you create what is known
as a session and then in that session
you ask the session to execute this
graph so this will again become much
clearer when we look at the code now
what are the various elements of a
tensorflow program as i mentioned
tensorflow program is slightly different
from regular programming that we do so
even if you're familiar with python this
may still be new for you the way you
write a tensorflow program is different
from the regular python programming that
you would have done or even machine
learning program you would have written
some machine learning program using
scikit-learn or regular python libraries
this is different from even that so let
us see what are the various elements so
first of all the way we handle data
inside of a program itself is a little
different from how we normally do in a
normal programming language a variable
is a variable in your program right so
you have anything that can keep changing
you just create as a variable or even
constants in fact are actually created
as variables but in tensorflow the
storage in the program consists of three
types one is constants another is
variable and the third is a placeholder
so and they are there is a lot of
difference between these types and we
will see how they vary and how they are
used and so on so constants are like
variables which cannot be changed so for
example if you define a constant like
this this is how you define a constant
by the way the simplest format is like
this like for example b is equal to
tf.constant and then you give a value
here the slightly more advanced version
is you also specify the type so you say
tf dot constant 2.0 tf load 32 so the
type is of type float now in case of
constants you cannot during the
computation you cannot really change
these values so for example if you want
to change the value of b from 3 to 5 or
any other number it is not possible so
that is the meaning of constant all
right so then we have variables so
variables we are all familiar with what
are variables whenever we use
programming we use variables so this is
pretty much the same this is the way you
define variables df dot variable now one
thing you need to note is this is the
only type in which we have v capital
okay constant has c small c and
placeholder as small p but variable as
capital v and tf.variable and then you
give the a value and then you can
specify what is the type and then you
can use the variable change the variable
at any point in time with a different
value and so on you can update the
variable and so on so we will see all of
this in the code i will illustrate how a
variable is defined and how it can be
changed whereas the constant cannot be
changed and so on and so forth and then
we have placeholders placeholders are
really a special type and this may be
something completely new for many of us
who have been doing programming but in
tensorflow this is a completely new
concept so this is very important to
understand this placeholders are like
variables but only thing is that they
are used for feeding the data from
outside so typically when you are
performing some computations you need to
load data from a file or from an image
file or from a csv file or whatever so
there is a provision with the special
kind of variables which can be fed in a
regular basis because the reason one of
the reasons for having this kind of
provision is that if you get the entire
input in one shot typically it may be
very difficult to handle memory and so
on so i think that was the reason they
came up with this mechanism where you
can feed in patches and there is a
certain way of populating the
placeholder we call this feed dig feed
underscore dick and this is a parameter
name by the way and you feed the
placeholders right that is the meaning
here so there is a certain way of
feeding the placeholders and we will
again see this in the example code as we
move forward okay so there are three
types one is the constant which cannot
be changed once you assign a value then
you have variables which are like normal
variables we are all familiar with and
then you have placeholders this is
primarily for feeding data from usually
from outside but of course you can also
for temporary testing purpose you can
feed within the program as well but
primarily the purpose of a placeholder
is to get data from outside so all right
so those were the constants variables
and placeholders that is how you
handle data within the tensorflow
program and then you create a graph and
once you create a graph then you have
what is known as a session and then you
create a session object and you create a
session and then you run a particular
computation or a node or an operation
and so typically what you need to do is
every variable or a computation that you
perform is like an operation or a node
within a graph so initially the graph
will be what is known as the default
graph the moment you create a tensorflow
object or tf this tf here you see this
is the tensorflow object and again in
the code when we go into the code it
will become much easier to understand so
when you create a tensorflow object
there is like a default graph which
doesn't have any operations no nodes or
anything like that so it's like a clean
slate the moment you
assign variables or constants or
placeholders each of them is in
tensorflow terms it is known as an
operation again you need to get familiar
with these terms and they are not very
intuitive this is not really an
operation you are just creating a
constant or a variable but and this c is
equal to a into b would traditionally or
would intuitively be an operation here
you're actually performing an operation
but in tensorflow terms each of these
everything is an operation so if you're
creating a constant that is an operation
another constant or variable that's an
operation so you can actually run each
of these and they are also known as
referred to as nodes and when you are in
your session you will actually
run each of these you can potentially
run each of these nodes okay so a
typical example would look like this so
you have two constants created a is
equal to tf.constant its value is 5 b is
equal to this and then you say c is
equal to a into b and then you create a
session now remember all this you're
just creating a graph at this point no
execution has happened all right so only
at this point once you create a session
and then you say session or says dot run
c is when actually this whole thing will
get executed all right so that is a
different way of programming compared to
our traditional way of writing programs
so you need to get used to this new
format and when we look at the code as
we move forward and when we look in the
jupiter notebook it will become much
easier probably to understand this
rather than in the slide so these are
the slides showing the code but what we
can do is go straight into the
lab and take a look at the various
examples that are there and starting
from the very basic one how you create
variables and so these are some of the
slides that are showing so this is about
how to create variables how to create
constants and the variables or constants
can also be strings so this is like our
first hello world program and we will
talk about placeholders how to define a
placeholder and how to execute and
populate the placeholder values into
placeholder we will see these examples
in the lab actually i will run the code
and
we will also perform a small computation
of adding and multiplying these
variables and
we will in the end we will take up a use
case implementation using tensorflow so
let's first go and see those examples
and then come back and i'll explain this
use case and then we will execute the
use case in the lab so let's go and
check our lab okay so i'm in the jupiter
notebook environment and this is one of
the development environments we can use
this is regular python anytime you do
python programming we use gypted
notebook or there are rather of course
there are other ways of using other
tools like pycharm and so on but for
this particular tutorial i'm comfortable
using jupiter notebook so i will show
you in jupyter notebook so this is the
very basic example to demonstrate how to
create variables and constants and
placeholders and what is the difference
between them how they behave and so on
and as i mentioned the assumption here
is that you know at least some basic
python programming or some programming
language so at least you understand the
code here and first two pieces of code
you will not need machine learning
background but when we do the use case
or the case study there it is expected
that you know at least some basic
machine learning concepts so in case you
need to brush up the machine learning
part you may have to do that before you
go to the third one but here just at
least some idea of programming will be
sufficient so what are we doing here in
this particular line or in this
particular cell we are importing
tensorflow it is uh as i mentioned it is
a library so we are importing tensorflow
and we are calling it tf so this is this
just a name you can give it any name but
it is very common and everywhere
wherever tensorflow programming is done
it is always named as tf but you can
name anything actually okay so this will
import the tensorflow into my session
now this is the way to create a variable
so let's start by creating a variable
and this is the name of my variable i am
starting by giving a name called 0 and i
say 0 is equal to tf dot variable and
then i'm giving the value of the
variable here so this is the very basic
way and the simplest way to create a
variable we will see a little later
there are other formats as well but the
bare minimum way of creating a variable
is this so i'm creating a variable by
the name zero and as i mentioned you
need to pay attention to the capital v
here in case of variable it is a capital
v uppercase constant and placeholders
are
lowercase now i'm creating a constant
and the constant i'm naming it as 1 and
the way to create a constant is tf dot
constant and then you give the value of
the constant so the value of the
variable here is zero and the value of
constant here is one and again constant
you can also have additional parameters
like a name and so on probably you must
have seen in other tutorials or in other
places where the code is written but the
basic format construct to create a
constant is this this is sufficient to
create a constant so i created one
variable and one constant now what else
can we do again here there is no real
execution happening we are just building
a graph we have not yet executed any
tensorflow code we are building a graph
and i will show you how the graph looks
as well first let us understand the
constants and variables and so on and
then i will show you how the graph is
generated and so on so what i want to do
here is i want to add 0 and 1 and put it
into a new variable called new value so
what i do here tensorflow offers these
methods like add assign multiply or you
have matrix multiplication matmul and so
on right so i will use one of those
methods which is tf.add and then pass
these two as parameters so we can add a
variable and a constant there are no
restrictions on that so this is a
variable and this is a constant so if i
do this it will be okay i did not
execute this code so it is giving an
error now we are good okay so what it
has done is new value will be equal to
tf dot add 0 1 so then we have one
variable and one constant now let's say
i want to change the value of the
variable because that is possible right
so we want to change the value of the
variable to something some new value so
we have in this case new value has one
because we added a zero and a one so new
value has one now i want to assign this
to this originally what we called as 0.
so i will call that as update is equal
to tf dot assign so assign is basically
changing the value so that's what we are
going to do here now it has not
complained we'll just say fine right
there are no issues now let us try this
something similar
with this 1 as well so 0 is a variable
so we were able to change the value and
we will in a little while we will see
what exactly those values are but before
doing that now let's say i will
uncomment this part and i want to do
something similar for my constant right
1 is a constant now i want to let's say
change the value of the constant and
make that also something different okay
so if i execute this piece of code it
will give an error now again the error
message may not be very intuitive this
doesn't say that you cannot do this for
a constant it will just say tensor
object has no attribute assign now that
sometimes may be confusing especially
when you're starting but the meaning
here is that one is a constant and
you're trying to modify the constant so
it will not allow that's the reason it
is complaining so let's put that back in
the comment and
okay so that is done so only variables
you can modify now what you have to do
let's skip this piece of code i'll come
back to this in a bit
but let's say we start by creating you
remember i told you we need to create a
session so the way to create a session
there are a couple of ways of creating a
session but this is for beginners this
is the easiest way all you need to do is
assign a variable called says or you can
give any name and that is equal to tf
dot session that is the session method
here and you create a session object by
the name says now what i'll do is i'll
skip this as well i there is a purpose
behind that now let's go ahead and run
this piece of particular operation
remember i mentioned that everything you
need to run so as of now the code has
not really got executed tensorflow code
has not got executed you only created
the graph so only when you
run through the session is when that
actually the program gets executed so
when you do this now you see observe
that it is giving an error okay the
reason behind that is remember we skip
these two lines of code for variables
okay this and then this now this is
something very very important to observe
if you have variables in your code what
i mean by that is let's say you are not
using variables but you have only
constants and placeholders then this
will not complain and you will not get
this error but in our case we also have
variables so whenever you have variables
in that case you need to do an
initialization and this is just a
standard code there is nothing that we
need to add or modify or anything like
that this is a standard piece of code
you create this name of course can be
anything you can give us any name but
this global variables initializer is
what you need to call tf.global
variables initializer this will kind of
initialize all the variables that you
may be using and then again remember
this doesn't execute anything right so
all you're doing here is you're creating
an operation but in order to run that
operation you need to also run this
known as run init underscore op so this
operation you need to run after creating
the session all right so we executed
this now let us execute this and now
when i run this piece of code it will
run successfully okay i hope you
observed that so it is whenever you use
variables these two lines of code one is
the operation you need to create an
operation for saying global variables
initializer and then you need to run
before running anything else you need to
do a session.run this operation okay
again only if you're using
variables of course you invariably in
all your programs you will use variables
you cannot just write a program with
constants and placeholders so you can
pretty much assume that this has to be
there in pretty much all the programs
now again why
this has not been taken care of in the
library that's a different question but
you need to keep in mind and always
remember if you don't do this for
whatever reason if you're forgotten you
will get an error and the error won't be
intuitive so you need to remember this
that this could be because of the
variables okay good so we have seen how
to create a constant and we have seen
how to create a variable and we have
seen that you cannot modify or update a
constant and we have also seen if you
have variables that you need to execute
or have these two lines of code to
initialize the variables and then we
have seen that after creating a graph
how to run the graph in a session and i
will show you a little bit more in
detail how exactly the graph gets
created and how it gets executed but
this was the first very quick code on
creating variables and constants now we
will keep going and
we will also show you or i will show you
the placeholders but before that one
more small piece of code so this is how
you write a for loop okay so we are
saying five times you run this piece of
code now like any python program this is
nothing different so you have a for loop
and this is indented that's the reason
and therefore you say session.run update
so this will run five times and it will
get printed that's all so update will
run for five times each time it will
come and do this particular operation
that's all we are we are asking the
system to do so let me just run that and
show you let me yeah so it will
okay so it has done five times
one that's for it is basically adding if
you recall it starts from zero it adds
one to zero then one to one one to two
and so on so it's nothing but it is
generating five numbers one two three
four five that's it okay so then
you can also have your constants as
strings for example so you can also work
in a similar way you can work with
string so most of the computation
happens
mainly on numerical values so we
normally hand handle numbers but there
will be situations where you may have to
handle strings as well or text as well
so this is an example of text operation
so you can similar to numbers you just
create strings or store
in constants instead of a number you say
hello is equal to tf.constant and then
you assign the string that you want it
to be assigned and then the next one is
one more string which is for world and
then you say add these two so it is
nothing but concatenation of these two
words hello and
world so we will do that and remember
this is only creation of the graph right
so in order to actually execute this
graph you need to run the session now
you need to keep in mind we don't have
to create the session once again because
once you create a session till you close
the session it remains valid okay so we
have created this session here now till
you say says dot close it will remain
for you so that's why we did not create
one more so we are just reusing that
session says dot run hello world so in
this hello world what is the operation
that we are doing here the operation is
add these two concatenate these two so
if i run this it will print hello world
okay now that's string operation now we
will take a look at placeholders so this
is slightly more complicated and
something new even for people who have
been writing programs so but i'll just
explain it with uh with a quick example
first of all how do you declare or
create a placeholder you just do
tf.placeholder and the p is lowercase
only in case of variables the v is
uppercase but otherwise constant and
placeholders it is lowercase and you
just say because as i mentioned this is
a placeholder it doesn't have any value
so you unlike a constant or your
variable you can't usually you will not
specify any value you just say what type
of placeholder you want and very often
most of the cases it is a floating point
so we just say placeholder of type
float32 so this tf dot float32 tells the
system that it is a floating point okay
and then so let me just run this and
then you can do some or define some
computation like for example b is equal
to a into 2. now remember here right now
a has no value but what we are saying
here is at any point later on when a
gets some value then b should be equal
to twice the value of a that's all we
are saying here okay and also as i
mentioned earlier we are not yet
executing anything we are just creating
the graph here okay so now you have that
now how do you feed the value or
populate the placeholder there is a
certain syntax in which you can populate
the placeholder and you do that using
what is known as a dictionary you're all
probably familiar those with python
especially must be familiar with the
dictionaries so you need to create a
dictionary and then pass that
in order to feed the placeholder so in
this particular example if i want to run
something if i want to calculate or
compute b obviously i need to feed the
value of a so the value of a i'm feeding
using this dictionary and i'm saying
that a is equal to 3. now there are
multiple ways of populating the value of
a because it typically this won't be
just a single a scalar value like in
this case right remember scalar so it's
just one value one number typically it
would be a vector or or a tensor very
often it is a tensor so we will see step
by step so we can start with the very
basic example
where a can be a scalar so in this case
a is equal to 3 that's what we are
saying feed underscore dict in this case
feed underscore dict is the
name of a variable by the way so you
can't give anything else here so if you
just say feed is equal to this it will
give you an error all right so keep that
in mind either you specify feed
underscore dick is equal to and give the
dictionary pass the dictionary or you
straight away like in this case this is
another format so let's see first let me
execute this it has given six okay i
think let me see if i can clear out this
particular cell so it becomes easier to
understand okay so it is giving you six
let me do that once again clear out this
and then okay and let me change the
format so this is one way of doing it
another way is you don't even have to
specify the name of this parameter feed
underscore deck you just pass the
dictionary and it will
execute okay but typically this makes
the code readable so that's the reason
most of the places whenever you find
tensorflow code you will see that they
explicitly mention feed underscore date
so that the code is readable otherwise
it can get confusing so i will also
comment this and retain the other format
okay so i hope it's clear so what we are
doing here we are running the operation
b and what exactly is bb is twice a a
into 2 so therefore what we are doing
and a has not been
doesn't have any value out here right so
that is why we are feeding the value of
a and then the operation gets completed
so a gets a value of 3
and then it gets multiplied by 2 because
that is what we said here therefore b
gets a value of 6 and that's what is
being fed into result and that's what is
getting printed here okay now as i
mentioned a need not be just a scalar
value it can be a vector with a
multi-dimension
array and so on and so forth so let's
start showing you examples of that again
let me just clear out the outputs let me
clear this and let me also clear this
for now okay you can also do
before running up this you could we
could also do
clear all output all output clear it
will clear everything but that will will
have to start all over again so i am
just doing individually all right so
in this example we are taking a one
dimension array where rank is equal to 1
and i'm feeding 3 4 5. now let us see
what happens if i run this right as you
can imagine it gets multiplied each
number gets multiplied so the result is
6 8 10 okay now as i said it can get
more complicated now let's say this is a
multi-dimensional
vector so if you what happens if you
feed this okay so as you can see this is
pretty complicated no but if you feed
this again all you're doing is
there is okay there is a slight change
here again you can also
create your dictionary outside and feed
that here you don't have to directly do
it here like in this case you see there
are variations of the exact syntax in
the way you write it right so there is a
slight variation so in this case you are
creating the dictionary straight away
here kind of inline but here you created
the dictionary separately because it is
more complicated and then you are
passing that dictionary here so i said
dictionary is equal to a and then i'm
saying this is what should be the value
of a
this is and i'm feeding that and then
i'm using directly that dictionary here
okay so this is equivalent to putting
this code here right so if we execute
this what happens same so you get
because a was a let's say this is a
3 by
4 by 2 right so that is one yeah 3 by 4
by 2 right so you see here this is a
multi-dimensional array so you feed that
and the values you see here there's one
two three it became two four six four
five six became eight ten twelve seven
eight nine became 14 16 18 and so on and
so forth okay i hope now you got an idea
about placeholders and in real life what
happens is you typically won't create
these dictionaries manually and since
this is a quick demo we did this you
will actually
read the data into this dictionary and
then you feed that when you're doing the
computation okay so it could be a csv
file or it could be a image file so the
input is basically
read and fed in
usually it is also done in patches so
you don't read the entire thing because
they can be large amount of data so that
is the idea behind having these
placeholders and the way we feed these
placeholders there is a provision there
is a deliberately that has been made a
provision for
this kind of getting data into the
program in chunks okay now in this
particular example we will close the
session here and then i will show you
what is the other way of creating a
session right so now if i close the
session here now if i try to do anything
with the session it will give us an
error so i will probably not do that
right now now there is another way or
another format and this is a very common
way of using the session but i didn't
want to start off with this because this
could get a little confusing the a
simpler way was to create session saying
says is equal to tf.session but
typically you will do it in what is
known as a width block this is a very
common way of creating sessions so once
you have the graph you would execute the
graph in a session using a width block
and this is the syntax so you say with
df dot session as says all right and
then you put all your code here so what
will happen is you don't have to
explicitly close the session the moment
this width block gets
completed the session gets closed okay
so let's just take a quick look at this
example now if i uh let me clear this
current output be clear okay so this is
the hello world example a little bit
earlier we did that so i'm doing
with tf.session assessment result is
equal to says dot run hello plus world
and then i say print result okay so
within this with block i'm doing all my
computation and this gets executed now
let's say i try to run remember i
created a session here now if i want to
let's say do something like run sesh dot
run a it is giving an error because the
session is no longer valid
right so you cannot either you have to
run this if you want to run this you
have to run this in this width block
or you shouldn't have closed the session
here right you remember this we said
session dot close so since we have
closed the session there is no active
session therefore it is giving an error
okay now there is a third way of
creating a session but for now i will
skip it because that is very very
specific to the notebooks and and so on
so we will just avoid it you start with
for beginners i think the best way is to
start with creating a separate session
and then writing your code and then
closing your session now of course
remember if you don't do this part says
dot close it will not give any error or
anything like that only thing is that
it's a good practice and your resources
will get released otherwise
if you do multiple of these programs if
they are running then your resources
will get blocked that's the only thing
and to start with this it is simpler to
do it this way so initially when you're
doing you start with this but as you
move forward as you become familiar with
tensorflow programming i would recommend
all of you to get into this model most
of the programming tensorflow
programming is done like this with df
dot session as ss okay all right so that
was one book or one page of a code that
we have done explaining about variables
constants and placeholders now let me
explain how the graph works so in this
example we are going to see how the
graph is created how the graph gets
executed and so on okay now that we got
a understanding of constants and
variables and placeholders okay so we
will start as usual by importing our
library and as i said whenever you
create a tf or tensorflow object there
will be what is known as a default graph
and you can get a handle of that by
saying get default graph so let's do
that and you can display the operations
remember every node in the graph is
considered as an operation right so as
of now as you can see
we have not done anything we have not
created a constant or variable or
nothing right so there was there is no
operation so by the way let's do one
thing let's start with the
all output clear so that
i don't have to again do individually so
we i'll just run these two lines of code
okay now so yeah so we have the default
graph and as of now there are no
operations so there is a method called
get underscore operations which will
kind of display
or show what are the various operations
that have been performed on the graph so
as i said to start with they have no
operations being performed so when i try
to display it's empty there are no
nothing is there no operations okay now
let's see what happens when we slowly
step by step start writing or building
the graph so my first step may be to
create a constant okay remember in the
previous example i have shown you how to
create a constant in the most simple or
the simplest way which is like constant
and then the number right now a small
extension of that is you can actually
give a name to your constant now again
this need not be the same i can say a is
equal to name and xyz i can give
anything here okay this is just for your
reference but here for simplicity
because there is a purpose why i am
using the same name as the name of the
variable and there are other reasons as
well why you would give a name again to
a constant or a variable this is again
useful when we are using what is known
as tensorboard otherwise it doesn't have
much value this additional name doesn't
have much value in this our case also we
will be seeing the graph and that's why
i'm using this but otherwise this having
additionally a name usually doesn't add
much value all right so let's create a
constant i created a constant now let us
see what's going on in the graph so i
will just say operations is equal to get
operations and if you see here now
you remember here it was blank now you
see the first operation is showing up
and this a that's the reason i put here
so it is showing as a and it says that
okay you have performed an operation
and there is a constant you have created
a constant okay all right so let's move
on let's say we want to create a second
constant and this is b so if i see what
does what are the operations list of
operations that have been performed you
see here there are two of them so you
have operation a which is a constant
then you have an operation b another
constant you recall we in the term
operation here is not very intuitive
right so we are just creating constants
or numbers or variables and it is saying
it's an operation but that's that's a
terminology in tensorflow everything is
an operation here okay all right so then
what else let's say i want to create a
third operation
and that is basically adding which is
this is a real operation in normal sense
as well so let's say i'm creating c
which is
adding a and b and the c value obviously
will be a plus b
okay now if we want to see what is in c
and we say c you see here it is not
showing
30. it just says it is a tensor and it
is of type in 32 right because
we have not executed the graph we are
still only building the graph i hope
this makes it easy to understand okay so
we are just building the graph we have
till we do remember till we do a session
and run a particular operation you're
not actually executing anything okay
you're just building the graph all right
so now let us see what are the
operations we have done a b and now c so
you will see there are three of them a b
and c okay now let's do one more
operation which is d
and here i am doing multiplication
remember we did a t f dot add now i will
do tf.multiply and i'm multiplying a and
b and i'm calling this operation as d so
a has
i think
10 and b has 20 so
d will be actually 200 when we execute
it right now it is just a tensor and it
is of shape in 32 okay and once again we
can see what are the operations abcd and
let's do one last operation here which
is e which is once again multiplication
of c and d now that c has 30 which is a
plus b and d has 200 which is a into b
so
now c into d will be 30 into 200 which
is which is equal to 6000 but as we have
seen earlier that multiplication will
not happen right now so now you have
built a
fairly simple but operation graph which
consists of
a b c d e one two three four five
operations okay so you built a small
it's not a very complicated one but a
simple graph now you need to execute
these operations so what you need to do
you need to create a session okay so
says dot tf is equal to session and then
you can
run these session
print says dot run e now am i missing
something do i have to initialize the
variables that's a question for you
thing can tell me do i have to
initialize the variables that remember i
ran one piece of code i think you must
have got the answer i don't have to
because i am just using
all constants here i have not used any
variable here right so i don't have to
write execute that piece of code to
initialize the variables so i can just
create a session and run any of the
operations that i want to run so in this
case i am running session e operation e
right this operation e now i can
actually run individually instead of
doing directly e i could have run only a
or i could have run b and so on and so
forth but in this case i have run e
which in turn will do all the required
computations which is for example
assigning the value to a and b and c
doing the multiplication and so on all
those operations will be performed which
are required to do the computation of e
okay now there is a small piece of code
that you can use to find out what are
the various operations that are there in
this particular graph in this case of
course it was very easy very
straightforward i have created abcde but
in normal programming in real life this
can sometimes help to see how
what is there in your graph what kind of
operations are going on in your graph so
you can write this piece of code and it
may sometimes help debugging as well
okay all right so i finished my session
what do we have to do we need to close
the session right because i did not use
the width block so i need to close the
session as a good practice
so i close the session good so that's
how the graph works
i hope it was helpful in understanding
how variables and constants and
placeholders are created in the previous
example we saw and how exactly you
create a graph and then you actually
execute that graph that's the way
tensorflow program works that's the
structure of tensorflow program okay so
now that we understood the structure of
tensorflow programming let's take an
example and a classification example and
take some real
data from from outside external data csv
file and
try to solve a classification problem
for that let's first go back to the
slides and understand what is the
problem statement and then we will come
back okay so what is the case here we
have some census data and which has all
these features or variables like um the
age of a person
what class work class what is his
education what is his marital status
gender and so on and so forth so there
are a bunch of a bunch of features that
are available and
we have to basically classify or not
classify we have to build a model for
classifying whether the income of this
person
is above 50k or below 50k okay so there
is actually a label data available we
will then try to build a model and then
see what is the accuracy so that this is
a typical machine learning problem
actually but as i said tensorflow can be
used for doing machine learning as well
so we will as a simple example we will
take uh machine learning so this is how
the high level the code looks and in
tensorflow programming we also take a
help of regular python libraries like
for example
it could be numpy or it could be
scikit-learn or it could be pandas in
this case and because before you
actually develop or before you train
your model create your model you need to
prepare the data into a certain format
and sometimes if you're doing machine
learning activity you all are familiar
those familiar with machine learning
will know you need to split your data
into training and test data sets so all
that can be done using regular
non-tensorflow libraries right so these
are like regular python libraries and
scikit-learn and so on so we use that
and then prepare the data and then use
tensorflow for performing either the
machine learning or deep learning
activity now so what is the advantage of
using tensorflow the main advantage is
that tensorflow offers high level apis
right we talked about that so in this
case we will be using i'll explain what
is in the slide but before that i wanted
to just show you what is the api that we
will be using
so we will be using the estimator api we
will be using the estimator api to
create a classifier what is known as a
linear classifier now in order to do
that you need to prepare the data and
you need to prepare the data into a
certain structure or format and the api
itself needs to be fed in a certain way
so that is exactly what we are doing
before we get into the regular
tensorflow code okay so these slides
will quickly show you what exactly is
happening but i will take you into
jupiter notebook and run that code and
show you so here we are importing the
data the data is the name of the file is
census underscore data.csv it's a csv
file and then there is
income bracket is one of the columns
which basically is our target that is
what is used that is the label rather
but this doesn't have numeric values so
it has the income so
we need to convert that into binary
values either 0 or 1. so that's what we
are doing here and then we are splitting
using scikit-learn we are doing
splitting of the data into test and
training right so this is a standard
scikit-learn people some of you who are
familiar with machine traditional
machine learning and you have done
machine learning in python using
scikit-learn will immediately recognize
this this is a sk learning cycle and
there is a readily available method to
split the data into training and test
that's what we are doing here and then
you need to create what is known as
feature columns and input functions
before you can call the api estimator
api that's what we are doing here and
data and also there is there are uh
different ways of creating the feature
columns for
numeric values and for categorical
values or rather for continuous values
and categorical values okay so that's
what has been
two types we are doing here
we will see again in the code as well
and
then you create your model so this is
basically model is equal to df.estimator
linear classifier and then you're
feeding the feature columns and also
subsequently you will call the training
by passing the input function and you
specify how many iterations to be done
for the training process and again this
is all typical machine learning process
so there is nothing specific for
tensorflow here and then you evaluate
your model because this is
classification model so you can again
take help of the scikit-learn to test
the accuracy and get the reports
evaluation perform the evaluation and
get the report like this one right so
this is the classification report and
you will see what is the precision
recall f1 score and so on again this is
a standard machine learning process all
right so that's pretty much as far as
the code here is concerned once again
let me take you into our
lab and
we will get started with this particular
code now let me clear out the outputs so
that you can step by step you can see
the output so this is our data and
we will actually be this is just a
display here the code starts from here
so before when we start with our
tensorflow part of it as i mentioned we
now remember in the previous examples
the data was kind of cooked up
internally we created some data and we
were using it right the constants
variables and so on here is a real life
example so you are actually getting data
from outside so you know before we get
into tensorflow this is actually regular
python code so we are using pandas for
example to create our data frame so we
will import pandas and then we will
basically read our file into a pandas
data frame and this is how the data
looks right and if you do a head it will
give you about six
readings or observations five or six
observations and then you can take a
look at how your data is looking so for
example you have age work class
education and so on and so forth and you
see here this last column income
underscore bracket it says whether the
income is greater than 50k or less than
50k so this cannot be
understood or this cannot be fed into
our
model or
you know so that's the reason we need to
convert this this will not be understood
right so this needs to be converted
saying okay
maybe less than 50 k is 0 and greater
than 50 k is 1 so that conversion needs
to be done before we feed it into our
model so that's what we are going to do
as we move forward so this is the code
for doing that okay so we take this and
then we define a function
and then we run that function so now we
have wherever it is
less than 50k
it will have 0 and greater than 50k it
will have 1. so we have now updated the
data then the next part is to split our
data into training and test data set so
how are we going to do that we again
will take the standard python library
which is scikit-learn sk-learn library
and
we use an existing
function there which is a train test
plate and what we are doing here is
basically splitting the data into i'm
sorry i need to run this
and then this
okay sorry about that so
once i run this what is what are we
doing here again those are familiar with
scikit learn will immediately recognize
i am splitting this into test and train
i'm saying test size is 30 so 30 of the
data should go into test and training
should have 70 okay so that's all we are
doing point 3 indicates 30
so you can again this can be individual
preferences some people do it like 50 50
some people 20 80 and in our case we are
doing
70 30. so training is 70 and test is 30.
okay all right so
we have so far we've been doing regular
non-tensorflow stuff so preparing the
data so that we can now use for
tensorflow and in tensorflow what we are
doing is
we will be using the api called
estimator now estimator in order to call
estimator you need to prepare what is
known as feature columns so feature
columns have to be in a certain format
basically it is nothing but the columns
we have to put them in a certain format
and then when we are calling the the
training we need to pass what is known
as an input function again a certain way
in which you need to pass that function
so that is what we need to do before we
create the model and
run the model for training so the next
few lines will be doing that quick look
at before we even get in once again into
the
tensorflow code so this is just showing
us what are the various columns names of
the columns of this data okay so that is
what is shown here and this is more for
when i was writing the code i could copy
paste from here that's the reason i this
line of code is there instead of typing
in these values okay good so now is
where
the actual tensorflow action starts so i
import tensorflow and now i will use
this feature column functionality to
create my feature columns and there is a
certain construct how you create the
feature columns again probably the
details of that is out of scope here but
just that you need to know that we need
to create feature columns and the way
you create feature columns for
continuous values and for categorical
values is slightly different and that's
the reason you have two different blocks
okay so for categorical values you need
to use what is known as tf dot feature
column dot categorical column with
vocabulary list and again within this
again there are two ways in which you
can create for categorical values one is
a vocabulary list where you know
how many types are there so for example
gender column can have only male and
female so in such a case if there are
let's say a finite number of values for
a given column then you use a column
with vocabulary list okay so and then
you say what is the name of the column
and what are the possible values so in
this case male and female now there will
be situations where the the values that
this column can have okay first of all
it is a categorical column that means it
can have names or some non-numerical
values but the number of values is
probably unknown or undefined so for
example occupation now occupation can
have any value it can be self-employed
it can be a software professional bank
a teacher doctor so so many
possibilities are there and we don't
know in the given data how many
occupations have been listed right so
that is where you use what is known as
categorical column with hash bucket and
you specify the hash bucket size so what
it what this says is there can be a
maximum of thousand such values so
typically if you give a safe number
safely large number so that you don't
run out of these number of occupations
so i think thousand is a safe number i
don't think there will be more than
thousand occupations in a given data so
that's the idea behind it but that's a
judgment call we need to take what
should be the size of this bucket size
right hash bucket size so these are two
different types for categorical values
for creating the feature column so we
will execute this for all the
categorical columns obviously you need
to know the type of the columns and that
is where if you see right at the
beginning this information was provided
what is the data type and you see here
the column name and what whether it is
continuous or categorical this
information is provided in the census
data wherever we pick this census data
from by the way this was picked from
online from a government website and we
stored locally so on that website it is
mentioned the details of this data were
mentioned and they have mentioned
whether each of these columns is
categorical or continuous so that
information we have to use and we have
to create feature columns using this
categorical method for the categorical
type of columns and then for numeric or
continuous values you just use
what is known as feature column dot
numeric column okay so these are all
continuous or numeric values like age
education number capital gain capital
loss hours per word these are all
numerical values or continuous values
right so you just say tf.feature
underscore column.numeric underscore
column and then give the name of the
column so once you do that i think i
have executed the previous one yeah this
one now so your feature columns are
ready and
you need to basically create a vector of
all these columns and we call that as
feet underscore calls which is which is
like a short form for feature columns
now as you have seen i've mentioned
earlier also there are two things that
are needed one is the feature columns
and another is the input function so
feature columns to first create the
model and then to train the model you
need to create an input function so now
we have the feature columns ready next
is to create an input function and there
is a certain way in which you need to
this construct is pretty much very
common construct so we will use that so
the input function takes these x and y
values for training and tests you
remember these are the x strain is the x
values of the training data set and
white rain is the labels of the training
data set so that's what we are using
here extreme y train and then we specify
what is the batch size batch size you
remember i mentioned this is what will
say how many records need to be read
each time right so typically in when we
are doing the training process we don't
get the entire data in one shot we do it
in batches so what size you specify here
number of epochs in this case we just
say none but number of epochs is again
probably the definition is not required
here but at a very high level how many
times the entire data has to be passed
through the model right so if you have
thousand records and you pass all the
thousand records three times for
training purpose then you call that as
three epochs right so there is a
difference between the batch size and
epochs so when let's say we have
thousand records and you are saying
batch size is 100 that means there will
be 10 batches right so if you take 10
batches then that is one epoch gets
completed okay then you the training
obviously doesn't get completed in one
round okay so you need to pass this data
again maybe a second time or a third
time till you get the right accuracy
that is known as epochs okay again if
you need more details about this you may
have to go through the machine learning
tutorial i think it becomes much clearer
okay so you have your input function as
well let's execute that okay and now we
are ready to create the use the api
right so what will we do we will create
the linear classifier using
tf.estimator.linearclassifier
and this guy needs feature columns right
so that's why we created we did all that
so much of
manipulations to create this feature
columns so we have feature column so we
pass that and we create our model there
may be a few warnings don't worry about
that so we will just ignore that and now
we use that model and we actually what
we did is we created an instance of the
model we have not really run anything we
just created a instance of the model now
we will create the node for training so
model dot train and this needs the input
function remember we we created the
input function so we need to pass the
input function and then we say
the steps is now telling how many
iterations this training
has to be run so we are saying 5000 and
this may be it will probably take a
little long so we will okay but that's
fine i think we will leave it 5000
sometimes if you have probably a less
powerful machine you can cut it down to
maybe thousand or something like that
but in this case i have a fairly
powerful system so i think it shouldn't
take much long let's uh go ahead and
give couple of minutes for it to get
over okay so let us go back yeah i think
this is done you see here the the
hourglass has
disappeared that means this computation
is done yes okay this is done right
saving checkpoint for 5000 that means it
is done so training is done so now what
we have to do we need to do the
evaluation so
again this is a standard machine
learning method so
methodology rather so training has been
done with the training data set now you
need to evaluate using your test data
set so that's what we are doing here for
example you see here x underscore test
is your the test data set remember we
used scikit-learn to split the data into
training and test data set so x
underscore test and a quick question why
are we not using y underscore test here
like we did in case of training
obviously we are expecting the model to
predict the values y values right so
that's why we don't pass the y values
here all right so let's execute this for
doing the evaluation all right and then
we
put them in a proper format because the
output doesn't come out in a proper
format so we put it in a list format and
then we can just check yeah so this is
done and
we can check what is the first element
in this what is the probabilities and so
on so it's just
a quick way to see if the values are
there or not you can take any value here
right any element here all right now
that the testing is done what we need to
do again we will probably put them in
some kind of this is more of a
formatting thing we will just uh
run through quickly and then we will use
once again scikit learn for finding out
the accuracy and so on because
scikit-learn offers what is known as a
classification report functionality so
we will use that and find out how well
our model has performed so you see here
again people with
machine learning background will be
immediately able to recognize this so it
gives us what is the precision what is
the recall
and f1 score
this is pretty much like you're getting
like almost 85 percent accuracy which is
pretty okay and
there are other ways to increase the
accuracy for example you can run the
training for more iterations that is one
way get more data and so on and so forth
or use a this is a linear classifier we
could you have used a non-linear
classifier and so on so again multiple
ways of doing it to increase the
accuracy but the idea here was to
quickly show you a piece of
tensorflow code so what is the
tensorflow object detection api it is an
open source framework which is actually
provided by the tensorflow team and
there are trained models available and
the sample code is also available which
we can use in order to easily detect
objects in images and videos this is
pretty robust and can
detect objects fairly quickly and this
is very easy for people to use as well
people with very less or no knowledge of
machine learning or deep learning can
also with a little bit of python
programming knowledge can actually use
this api this library to build object
detection applications this is a list of
libraries that are required and they
have been shown in the code as well the
exact purpose of each of this library
why it is required is
out of the scope of this tutorial but we
will see in the code as we walk through
some of these libraries how and why they
are used the cocoa data set coco stands
for common objects in context so this
data set consists of 300 000 images of
90 most commonly found objects like
chairs and tables and so on and so forth
so
this model has been trained or in fact a
set of models have been trained on this
data set and this is pretty good to
detect the most common objects in the
images and videos so with that let's get
into the code all right so the first
part is to import all these libraries
and this we have shown you in the slides
as well again a bunch part of this will
be for doing some helper functions and
maybe for visualizing the images and so
on and so forth so that's the reason
they are required as i said the exact
details of each and every library
probably is out of scope but these are
needed so as a first step maybe you just
go ahead and include these libraries and
run the code and maybe a later point we
can discuss what each of these libraries
does now this will work with tensorflow
version higher than 1.4 so if you are
having tensorflow version below 1.4 you
may have to upgrade to a higher version
so let me go ahead and execute the cell
and
we also need this line of code to make
sure that once we
run this object detection the labeled
images are displayed within this
notebook and many of you by now must be
familiar with this and we will import a
few utility libraries and you will see
that we will be using some of these
for visualization purpose so once the
objects are detected we need to display
the information what that object is and
then what percentage of confidence the
model has so all these details that's
the utility functions that stored here
and then the next part is to prepare the
model as i mentioned we will be using an
existing trained model
the tensorflow team has actually
provided these models the one that we
will be using is ssd with the mobile net
but you can actually use any one of the
ones that are listed in this url let me
just quickly take you through this url
these are a bunch of models trained
models that are readily available for
anybody to use it is open source and let
me scroll down the only thing is that if
there are some of them with the accuracy
is much higher but they take longer and
there are some where the accuracy is not
so high and they are much faster so they
are faster but the accuracy may not be
that very high so you can play around
with some of these and we in this
particular exercise or in this
particular tutorial we are using this
ssd model which is ssd mobile at
question one so that's the model that
we'll be using so in this cell we are
primarily
creating a bunch of variables with the
various for example the name of the
model the path and so on and so forth so
that we will be using these names in the
next step which is to download this
model and install it locally these are
also referred to as frozen model so once
they are trained and then you kind of
extract or you freeze the model so
that's the reason they are called frozen
model so that others can just use this
without any further training so this is
where we download and extract our model
locally so this will take a little while
let me see if i can wait or maybe pause
the video and come back once it is done
might take a little while let's see if
it
completes i have a pretty high speed
network but even then it takes some time
so that's good but this part is over now
let us see this part and yes both are
done so once that is done we need to
load some label mapping our basically
what this will do is your model as you
may be aware by now if you do some
classification the model will actually
not give any output
text it will give some numbers so if
there are five classes it will say okay
this belongs to modern class one or two
or three or five and so on the numbers
now each of these will obviously the
numbers will not make any sense to the
outside world so we need to do some
small mapping so in this case let's say
one may be a chair two maybe a table
three maybe a balloon and so on so that
kind of number to text mapping we need
to do and that is what is being done in
this particular cell and then we have a
helper code which will load the image
and convert it into a numpy array so
that the number array is what gets
processed and used by the model to do
the detection part of it so that is what
this
method is all about so we will be the
later on we will be calling that
function and next is preparation for
detection so here we are basically
telling where the images are stored and
how many images or what is the naming
convention or format of the images now
if you want you can modify this code for
example currently i have test underscore
images as my folder so let me go and
show this to you so this is under my
object detection folder i have another
subfolder where i am storing my images
which is text underscore images now you
can rename this folder and give some
other name and then in your code you can
probably give that particular name for
the subfolder similarly the format of
these files what is the name and format
of this files here it is in a very
simple format which is the names of the
files are like beach one beach two b3
and so on so i have taken beach as the
theme so i have images which are related
to beaches so this is beach one beach
two and then beach three a few others
but we will use these three for our demo
and so that's what i'm saying here the
name of the images will be beach
something dot jpeg which is uh jpeg
format and in this curly braces
basically we will will be filled with
either
one two or three based on in this
particular for loop okay so that is what
this is doing all right so the next step
is to run inference on these images in a
loop and what we are basically doing
here is um getting these images one by
one and then running through the model
to find out what are the objects that
can be detected and then against each of
the object a box will be drawn and it
will be labeled with the name and the
percentage of accuracy or confidence
that the model detects these objects
okay so that is
the function here and so let me just run
that piece of code and here is basically
where we are calling this function so we
are loading these images and then we are
calling this function for each image and
then we are displaying this using the
matplotlib library so let's run this it
will take one image at a time and then
detect the images now the beauty is that
the same format of the code can be used
for doing object detection in a video so
we have another video for doing object
detection in a video so most of the code
out there will be reused from here and
the only thing is that instead of
reading the images from the local
storage we read the frames from the
video and there is a neat little video
reader that is available and it will be
shown in the other video and frame by
frame we read the video and then pass on
to this function and it will act as if
each of these frames is an image and
then it will do the same object
detection on the entire video so that's
in a separate video just look out for
that and actually the information about
that is provided
in the cards the eye symbol so that's
the the video object detection in video
that's the separate tutorial all right
so now that we have all the pieces
together this the last cell is where the
whole action takes place so let's run
this and see how it looks so
it will take probably a little while and
there are about three images let's see
what it detects there we go so good so
the first one it has detected a person
and that too with 97 percent accuracy
which is i think pretty good okay and
then the next image it detects
umbrella and chair there are a few other
objects but it's not able to detect it
has detected umbrella with 63 percent
accuracy or confidence rather and the
chair with 58
again not bad
then let's see the next image so here
these are actually balloons hot air
balloons but the model thinks it is a
kite which is uh probably not that bad
it sees there is something in the sky
and therefore probably it thinks it is a
kite and it detects that with 65 percent
confidence okay so that was pretty much
all i wanted to show you in this
particular tutorial about object
detection in images in this video i will
walk you through the tensorflow code to
perform object detection in a video so
let's get started this part is basically
we are importing all the libraries we
need a lot of these libraries for
example numpy
we need image i o date time and pill and
so on and so forth and of course
matplotlib so we import all these
libraries and then there are a bunch of
variables which have some paths for the
files and folders so this is regular
stuff let's keep moving then we import
the matplotlib and make it inline and
a few more imports all right and then
these are some warnings we can just
ignore them so if i run this code once
again we could go away all right and
then here onwards we do the model
preparation what we're going to do is
we're going to use an existing neural
network model so we are not going to
chain a new one because that really will
take a long time and it needs a lot of
computation resources and so on and it
is really not required there are already
models that have been trained and in
this case it is the ssd with mobilenet
that's the model that we are going to
use and
this model is trained to detect objects
and it is readily available as open
source so we can actually use this and
if you want to use other models there
are a few more models available so you
can click on this
link here and
let me just take you there there are a
few more models but we have chosen this
particular one because this is faster it
may not be very accurate but that is one
of the faster models but on this link
you will see a lot of other models that
are readily available these are trained
models some of them would take a little
longer but they may be more accurate and
so on so you can probably play around
with these other models okay so we will
be using that model so this piece of
code this line is basically importing
that model and this is also known as
frozen model the term we use is frozen
model so we import download and import
that and then we will actually use that
model in our code all right so these two
cells
we have downloaded and import the model
and then
once it is available locally we will
then load this into our program all
right so
we are loading this into memory and
you need to perform a couple of
additional steps which is basically we
need to to map the numbers to
text as you may be aware when we
actually build the model and when we run
predictions the model will not give a
text the output of the model is usually
a number so we need to map that to a
text so for example if the network
predicts that the output is 5 we know
that 5 means it is an airplane things
like that so this mapping is done in
this next cell all right so let's keep
moving and then we have a helper code
which will basically load the data or
load the images and transform into numpy
arrays this is also used in doing object
detection in images so we are actually
going to reuse because video is nothing
but it consists of frames which in turn
are images so we are going to pretty
much use reuse the same code which we
used for doing object detection in
images so this is where the actual
detection starts so here this is the
path for where the images are stored so
this is here once again we are reusing
the code which we wrote for detecting
objects in an image so this is the path
where the images were stored and this is
the extension and this was done for
about two or three images so we will
continue to use this and
we go down i'll skip this section so
this is the cell where we are actually
loading the video and converting it into
frames and then using frame by frame we
are detecting the objects in the image
so in this code what we are doing
basically is there are a few lines of
code what they do is basically once they
find an object a box will be drawn
around those
each of those objects and the input file
the name of the input video file is
traffic it is the extension is mp4 and
we have this video reader it's a
excellent object which is basically part
of this class called image i o so we can
read and write videos using that and the
video that we are going to use is
traffic.mp4 you can use any mp4 file but
in our case i picked up video which has
uh like car so let me just show you so
this is in this object detection folder
i have this mp4 file i'll just quickly
play this video it's a little slow yeah
okay so here we go this is the video
it's a short one relatively small video
so that for this particular demo and
what it will do is once we run our code
it will detect each of these cars and it
will annotate them as cars so in this
particular video we only have cars we
can later on see with another video i
think i have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's first check with
this traffic video so let me go back so
we will be reading this frame by frame
and
you know actually we will be
reading the video file but then we will
be analyzing it frame by frame and we
will be reading them at 10 frames per
second that is the rate we are
mentioning here and analyzing it and
then annotating and then writing it back
so you will see that we will have a
video file named something like this
traffic underscore annotated and
we will see the annotated video so let's
go back and run through this piece of
code and then we will come back and see
the annotated video this might take a
little while so i will pause the video
after
running this particular cell and then
come back to show you the results all
right so let's go ahead and run it so it
is running now and it is also important
that at the end you close the video
writer so that it is similar to a file
pointer when you open a file you should
also make sure you close it so that it
doesn't hog the resources so it's very
similar at the end of it the last piece
or last line of code should be video
underscore writer dot close all right so
i'll pause and then i'll come back okay
so i will see you in a little bit all
right so now as you can see here the
processing is done the hourglass has
disappeared that means the video has
been processed so let's go back and
check the annotated video we'll go back
to my file manager so this was the
original traffic.mp4 and now you have
here traffic underscore annotated mp4 so
let's go and run this and see how it
looks
you see here just got each of these cars
are getting detected let me pause and
show you so we pause here it says car 70
let us allow it to go a little further
it detects something on top what is that
truck okay so i think because of the
board on top it somehow thinks there is
a truck let's play it some more and see
if it detects anything else so this is
again a car looks like so let us yeah so
this is a car and
it has confidence level of 69 percent
okay this is again a car all right so
basically till the end it goes and
detects each and every car that is
passing by now we can quickly repeat
this process for another video let me
just show you the other video which is a
cat again there is uh this cat is not
really moving or anything but it is just
standing there staring and moving a
little slowly and
our application will our network will
detect that this is a cat and uh even
when the cat moves a little bit in the
other direction it will continue to
detect and show that it is a cat okay so
yeah so this is how the original video
is let's go ahead and change our code to
analyze this one and see if it detects
our network detects this cat close this
here we go and i'll go back to my code
all we need to do is change this traffic
to
cat the extension it will automatically
pick up because it is given here and
then it will run through so very quickly
once again what it is doing is this
video reader video underscore reader has
a neat little feature or interface
whereby
you can say for frame in video
underscore reader so it will basically
provide frame by frame so you are in a
loop frame by frame and then you take
that each frame that is given to you you
take it and analyze it as if it is an
image individual image so that's the way
it works so it is very easy to handle
this all right so now let's once again
run just this cell the rest of the stuff
remains the same so i will run this cell
again it will take a little while so the
r classes come back i will pause and
then come back in a little while all
right so the processing is done let's go
and check the annotated video go here so
we have get annotated dot mp4 let's play
this all right so you can see here it is
detecting the cat and in the beginning
you also saw it detected something else
here there looks like it detected one
more object so let's just go back and
see what it has detected here
let's see
yes so
what is it trying to show here it's too
small not able to see but uh it is
trying to detect something i think it is
saying it is a car i don't know
all right okay so in this video there's
only pretty much only one object which
is the cat and uh let's wait for some
time and see if it continues to detect
it when the cat turns around and moves
as well just
in a little bit that's going to happen
and we will see there we go and in spite
of turning the other way i think our
network is able to detect that it is a
cat so let me freeze and then show here
it is actually still continues to detect
it as a cat all right so that's pretty
much it i think that's the only object
that it detects in this particular video
okay so close this so that's pretty much
it thank you very much for watching this
video welcome to simply learns deep
learning frameworks my name is richard
kirschner with the simply learn team
that's www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead let's cover some
of the big players in deep learning
today and deep learning is just so
exciting this is the forefront of our
machine learning and artificial
intelligence and where it's at as far as
the cutting edge and what's coming next
that doesn't mean ignore all the machine
learning tools because certainly they've
been around a long time and are a basis
for a lot of deep learning platforms
along with solving the more basic
problems but deep learning is the
cutting edge it is the one that's
finding new solutions to things we never
thought were solvable before and today
we're going to look at just a quick look
at tensorflow probably the biggest
package out there right now cross which
is probably one of the biggest growing
packages out there right now pi torch
theano dl4j cafe chainer and the cntk
now all these packages center on deep
learning and neural networks if you
haven't studied our neural networks and
how they function send a note down below
in the youtube video and we'll post some
more information or one of our other
videos just so you have an idea what
deep learning is but let's go ahead and
dive in let's take a look at tensorflow
and as we look at these things i want
you also to notice that a lot of this
overlaps you'll see companies are
investing in all of these different
products to see where they go so these
are all huge players no matter where
you're coming from so let's look at
tensorflow tensorflow was developed by
google brain team it supports languages
both python and r that's a big you'll
see python is probably one of the
biggest players in the data science
neural networks across all the packages
that doesn't discount in the other ones
certainly a lot of these packages like
tensorflow you can set up an interface
into java and other places but it was
designed and has a very high
functionality in both python and r and
it uses data flow graphs to process data
this is nice because as you build these
neural networks you can actually look at
how the data flows through the neural
network they're easy to build machine
learning models robust machine learning
production powerful experimentation for
research i can't even emphasize that
enough it's very easy to go in there and
switch a couple lines in your tensorflow
setup to try out a new setup a new
neural network to see how it works with
your data going through and if it gives
you better results tensorboard for data
visualization and this is another huge
package that people kind of forget as
part of tensorflow put out by google
brain team and tensorflow is now open
source the tensorflow data visualization
is makes it so quick and easy to put out
your data for visual effects uh when
you're working with your ceo or with
your shareholders and of course you can
use both the r and python
visualization packages too since you're
usually running it in python or r let's
go ahead and talk about cross we
mentioned overlapping earlier cross is
probably the most overlapping package
out there and i'll show you why in just
a minute let's start with the creator of
cross or the founder now cross was
originally developed by francois chole
he's the author of cross and it has over
350 000 users and 700 plus open source
contributors that's big cross is um
tensorflow might be the biggest or well
most well-known package out there cross
because it overlaps so many other areas
and it's such a high-end development it
is probably the fastest growing package
out there right now and it's got a
high-level neural network api written in
python
so for all python lovers and data
science a great package to go from there
what makes it interesting is that it
runs on top of tensorflow theano cntk so
it uses their neural networks underneath
and then you use your definition in
cross to define all these packages so
now if you're running tensorflow and you
put cross on top of it you have both the
benefits of cross and all the tools in
tensorflow this is why cross is the
fastest growing neural network or deep
learning package out there and it's used
in several startup research labs and
companies uh microsoft research you'll
see microsoft is invested in all of
these now so any place you have any of
these coming out microsoft is part of it
and of course microsoft with the cntk is
their package and they're highly
invested in that netflix nasa
cern are all using cross for using their
data processing and their deep learning
it's user friendly as it offers simple
apis and provides clear and actionable
feedback upon user error provides
modularity as a sequence of a graph of
standalone fully configurable modules
that can be plugged together with as few
restrictions as possible these two
things makes it so easy to write a cross
code a lot of times you might be messing
with tensorflow and you turn around you
can do the same cross code in a few
lines or let you know significantly less
than you'd write the same code in
tensorflow so you could use cross on top
of tensorflow and cross it's easily
extensible as a new modules are simple
to add this feature makes cross suitable
for advanced research so from uh karass
we're going to go into pi torch and it's
authored by adam pasquay sam gross
sumith cantala and gregory shannon lua
based scientific computing framework for
machine learning and deep learning
algorithms so this is coming from the
scientific teams they took and they can
guess it's uh pi so it's in python but
it's based on the scientific computing
and so they're looking at answers for
science uh and it employed cuda along
with cc plus libraries for processing
was designed to scale the product of
building models and overall flexibility
if you're a c c plus plus um programmer
and that's your programmer programming
of choice you can see why pi torch might
be really
big jump for you because you know the
back end and you can get in there and
see what's going on with that particular
framework and it's widely used in
companies like facebook twitter google
and you find this interesting because
google
like i said you'll see microsoft and
google has their hands in all of these
and i'm guessing that facebook and
twitter have probably investigated the
best use
and use these different frameworks
depending on what they're working on so
it provides a flexibility and speed due
to its hybrid front end enable scalable
distributed training and performance
optimization in research and production
using torch.distributed backend deep
integration into python allows popular
libraries and packages to be used for
clear writing neural network layers in
python so remember it's got that dual
layer uh so if you're running in c plus
or c great language and you can skip
over to python then there's theano and i
had to look this up how to pronounce it
even though i played with it i've only
read the word i've never heard someone
say it and i finally went in there and
looked it up it is theano there's a lot
of pronunciations theno and different
things
so theano uh it's developed by the
university de montreal and it's written
in python and really centers on nvidia
and so you have your integration there
to your gps's which is huge you'll see
the gps uh modules like in tensorflow
there's a gps module in there and in
cross obviously since it sits on
tensorflow most of these that's where
they're going is the gps can process so
much faster than a cpu so the python
library that allows to define optimize
and evaluate mathematical expressions
involving multi-dimensional arrays
efficiently so when we look at this we
have numpy theano has a tight
integration with numpy for data
computations so if you're a major python
lover and you love the numpy which is uh
you know the number python such a
central aspect of python and data
science numpy's the way to go and then
he uses the gpus to perform data
intensive computations which are much
faster than on a cpu and it has
extensive unit testing and
self-verification that can detect and
diagnose many types of errors so seattle
is a pretty solid package
and the fact is written in python and is
designed pretty solid on the gpu makes
it a very big contender in our deep
learning array of uh platforms out there
and then we have deep learning for java
or the dl for they usually call it dl4j
deep learning for java was developed by
a machine learning group led by adam
gibson a wonderful group i got to meet
them they're a lot of fun it's written
in java and scala and that is big if you
are working in big data and the hadoop
and the spark framework those who jump
out at you right off the bat so we have
our dl4j supports different neural
networks like cnn rnn and lstm cnn is
your convolutional neural network arid
in is your recurrent neural network and
lstm is your long short term memory for
the neural network so you'll see cnn
lstm a convolutional neural network with
a long short term memory it's connected
to the eclipse foundation so the dl4j
was contributed to eclipse foundation
integrated with hadoop and apache spark
i talked about that earlier since scala
spark is written in scala so we're
talking about big data and big data
processing that's a big name to have on
there and the fact that a lot of
hadoop your mapreduce is based in java
you can see the connection for the
dl4j and big data and so dl4j brings ai
to business environments for use to
distributed cpus and gpus and right
there distributed cpus and gpus so this
can be run across a huge cluster of
computers quite easily it's designed for
that so if you're working in spark and
you have 100 computers set up on
different racks this would be a really
solid roll it out the
doorway set up for you so he provides a
distributed computing framework as
training with dl4j occurs in a cluster
as we were talking about cluster
computations includes an n-dimensional
array class using nd 4j that allows
scientific computing in java and scala
offers a vector space modeling and topic
modeling toolkit that is designed to
handle large text sets and perform in lp
natural language processing so we looked
at dl4j let's take a look at the cafe
developed at bear that's berkeley
artificial intelligence research so
berkeley's at it again cafe stands for
convolutional architecture for fast
feature embedding it's written in c plus
plus within python interface so again we
have another contender for people who
work in the c plus plus realm and want
to be able to go back and forth between
that and python generally used for image
detection and classification use an
academic research projects which makes
sense this is coming out of berkeley
start-up prototypes and large-scale
industrial applications in vision speech
and multimedia and really when you see
vision speech and multimedia all of
these deep learning are addressing these
particular aspects and more
so it's not a big jump when you talk
about vision there is a little bit there
as far as which ones handle the vision
better because then you're doing
different matrixes you know you have a
xy plot coming in and that's a big deal
that's you'll see that in tensorflow
especially cafe supports gpu and
cpu-based acceleration computational
kernel libraries such as nvidia cudn and
intel mlk so it's integrated a little
bit more on the multiprocessor and the
gpu setups in there we're seeing that
all come together most of the packages
now well nvidia is almost in all of
these as far as a gpu acceleration but
we're starting to see the other ones
migrate in there it offers a high speed
can process over 60 million images per
day with a single nvidia k40 gpu that's
huge 60 million images per day
so when you're training this thing and
you spend a lot of time training and i
mean that's just huge that's amazing so
let's take a look at chainer uh chainer
is one of those that kind of
i don't hear a lot about but it's still
a contender in our setup in here it is
developed by preferred networks in
collaboration with ibm intel microsoft
and nvidia and there we see nvidia again
they've got their hands and everything
and so does intel microsoft and ibm
that's what puts this at one of the top
contenders it has such a huge backing in
the industrial world it's written purely
in python it runs on top of numpy and cu
pi python libraries so that's
straightforward if you're
like i said most of stuff in our machine
learning is heading towards the python
environment because it's so flexible
it's currently one of the top used
setups in there and the chain is written
right on top of it in python and it
provides a number of extended libraries
we have the chain or mn and the chainer
rl and the chainer cv and you'll find in
deep learning these little abbreviations
are so many unless you're working with a
specific setup and you're running it i
wouldn't worry too much about memorizing
all of them maybe get your flash cards
out but we have chain or mn which is
multiple uh nodes rl which is your
reinforced learning and cv which is your
computer vision library
so your images and so when you're
working with with chainer you definitely
want to know what those mean and as you
dig in deeper into it but these are they
have tons of extended libraries these
are a few of the libraries they have
these are the top ones that are used so
it supports cuda computation it only
requires a few lines of code to leverage
a gpu there's our gpu which we're seeing
across the board on all of our different
neural networks and how the how they
apply that is important because some of
them do a better job than others it also
runs on multiple gpus with little effort
so just by its name chainer is designed
to send it out there to the different
aspects and bring them back together
that's what makes this one of the
reasons chainer is being developed so it
provides various network architectures
including feed forward nets conv nets
recurrent nets and recursive nets and
again now we're starting to dig in deep
into
the neural networks and deep learning as
opposed to the different main players
and most of these cover different
aspects of these you have to really dig
deep to see where these go but chainer's
coming up and it's got some heavy
hitters backing it um it has you know
like i said ibm intel microsoft and
nvidia are part of the development team
there and we're getting down to the end
here we have our microsoft cntk
developed by microsoft research and the
cntk is a deep learning framework that
builds a neural network as a series of
computational steps via directed graph
it supports interfaces such as python
and c plus plus so again now we have one
of the nice things about this is you'll
see it's it's the interfaces are really
spread out so those are the two main
players with python being the more
commonly used one but we're starting to
see c plus coming in there's a lot of
programmers out there who use c plus
plus and it's used mainly for our
handwritten and you can see some
examples here for what it's used mainly
for so it's designed for speed and
efficiency and that's always that's a
big thing because neural networks just
eat up so much processing power for all
the calculations it takes to program
them so it's designed for speed and
efficiency cntk scales well in
production using gpus but has limited
support from the community so again we
have the big hitters behind it microsoft
research but does not have a huge
community support yet it supposed both
rnn and cnn type of neural models
capable of handling image a nice picture
of the guy writing there handwriting and
speech recognition problems so let's
take a look at implementation in
tensorflow and we're going to build a
neural network to identify handwritten
digits using the
mnist database or the mnist database and
that stands for modified national
institute of standards and technology
database it is a collection of seventy
thousand handwritten digits and the
digit labels identify each of the digits
from zero to nine this is a cool example
because it's simple enough that you
could actually run this through some
basic machine learning categorizing
algorithms and train them and you'll get
about the same answer because again it's
simple grid the digits on the grid don't
have a huge amount of variation like you
would say an automated driving car
looking at the environment so you can
still do this with a lot of your
different linear models and stuff like
that you can solve this and you'll get
about the same answer when i ran a
comparison between tensorflow and
between some basic regression models or
category models in machine learning they
came up pretty even as far as their
output
so this is kind of where we start to see
the complexity of something coming in in
this case a tensor you know or a grid of
information where the deep learning
model does as good as the regular models
and when you get past this kind of
complexity and features suddenly the
neural networks come up with better
answers better solutions and a better
build and that's why there's such a move
into neural networks is we live in a
complicated world and it's just really
cool we can do with this so the
handwritten digits from the nist
database they come in the data set is
used to train the machine a new image of
a digit is fed and the digit is
identified and if you've looked at any
of our other machine learning tools
where we're doing training where we
train our model to fit and then you test
it out this will look pretty familiar
and there is some tools out there for
say untrained categorizing uh where it's
just looking for features that fit
together so there are tools that don't
need that training but this is where we
talk about neural networks we do need to
train them and this is what we're
looking at for this i'm going to use the
anaconda navigator just because it's a
very nice visual tool you might be in
pycharm or one of your other ides for
editing python because we are looking at
python tensorflow and under anaconda we
have the notebook which is something we
use pretty regularly and they have the
jupiter lab the jupiter lab is the
jupiter notebook but with tabs and a few
new features so we'll be using the
jupiter lab today and under the
environment you'll want to go ahead and
and if you haven't yet you'll see that i
have a number of different setups in
here right now i have the python version
three six and the tensorflow in this
case i have tensorflow 1.12 if we scroll
down you can see that here we go
tensorflow and it's version 1.12 and in
here if you haven't yet you'll need to
install those and go in and just open
our terminal and if you've never used
the anaconda or if you're in your other
thing you might have something simple
like pip conda is what i use for my
install and you can simply do conda
install tensorflow that should bring in
the most current version now when i
installed this a few months ago python
version i'm not going to run this
because i already have installed on here
python version 3.7 the newest one out
still had a couple glitches with the
tensorflow i believe they fixed it as of
writing of this but um i'm going to
stick with 3 6 just so i don't get any
surprises on there so this is python
version 3.6 with tensorflow 1.12 on here
and if you haven't installed it yet you
also want to install numpy for this
example that's numbers python or
numpy
you just simply run install on there
keep in mind if you're in anaconda and
you've created one of these environments
specific to this keep with conda if
you're going to use conda if you're
going to use pip keep with pip don't
install one package with pip and one
under conda because that's how they
track those version numbers and how they
fit together and you can end up with a
problem they don't pip doesn't see conda
and vice versa so just keep that in mind
when you're running your installs we'll
go ahead and open up jupiter lab we're
going to launch that so here's my
jupiter lab one of the really cool
features of jupiter lab is you have tabs
now so you can open up multiple
notebooks this is nice because i have my
notes i'm working on and then our actual
window we're looking in and we'll go
ahead and zoom in a little bit here
there we go so you have a nice
hopefully easy to see fonts and then
we'll go ahead and do a simple or get
our imports out of the way and so we're
going to import our tensorflow as tf
that's pretty much a standard for
tensorflow numpy our number is python as
py and we'll import our matte plot
library as plt again these are very
common so if you see tf or py or plt
this is a standard that most people use
do you have to no you could just do
import numpy instead of doing as py and
then from tensorflow
this is always nice because they
actually include data set we're going to
play with so we're going to import input
data so there's our data coming in
that's all we're doing is telling it
this is where it's coming from and if we
can tell where it's coming from we need
to go ahead and create a variable with
that information in it and we'll just
call this uh mnist nist or minst you
know i don't really know how they
pronounce that i should probably look
that up it's a very common data set to
use and there's our input data and we're
going to read data sets and this is if
you look at this we imported input data
from our tensorflow and so this is a
tensorflow read statement for their
tutorials so this isn't like some
special python setup just is just their
setup makes it easy to pull it in so
once we get into their data sets we need
to go and tell what kind of data set and
again this is what we brought in but
it's going to be the ninth data and this
part is very important one
hot equals true this means that instead
of importing a value from zero to nine
we evaluate the data set it's going to
bring it in as one hot whenever you see
one hot encoder we're flattening that
out and we have true false for zero true
false for one true false for two so our
output if you remember from our output
from the slide we did earlier in this
case i grabbed the one for bike price
doesn't really matter which one we use
this has one output so we have our bike
price on this we're going to have
instead of one output we're going to
have 10 outputs representing each of the
digits in there and this code really
isn't going to show us anything it's
good to see what we're actually looking
at so let's go ahead and do a figure ax
equals go into our plot library subplots
10 comma 10. and that is if you remember
we talked about tensor tensor being data
coming in this is a 10 by 10 grid or 100
pixels on there and if we're going to
display it let's go do k
0 for i in range 10 just a simple loop
through on the data let's do what is it
in range 10. so i actually misquoted
that 10 uh 10 by 10 is not the actual
size of the pixels uh the actual pixels
are going to be um we look at the shapes
and we'll get to that in just a second
here we'll take a quick look at the
shape on there uh turns out they're
what are they are i believe 28 by 28. uh
so let's take a look at that and we're
just going to plot these what are we
looking at what are we working with as a
data scientist you should always be
looking back at your data and seeing
what it looks like and get that human
perspective because you just never know
you know the the computer might put
something out that looks makes no sense
and at that point you want to go back
and reevaluate what you did uh so we're
going to go ahead and plot we're going
to plot 10 digit you know 10 of the
digits by 10 of the digits and here's
our ax we'll create the ij on our
subplots and we're going to do an image
show we're going to look at the training
image for images of k
and then we want to reshape this we're
going to reshape this and we're going to
reshape this 28 by 28. that's how i knew
i had it wrong is because i looked down
my notes it's like oh no that says 28
it's not 10 by 10. and i should know
that already because i've done enough
messing with this data set that i should
remember but it's 28 by 28 and the
aspect we're going to do is auto and
this is all if you look at this here's
our variable nist the nist is coming
from data set so this is all part of the
tf tensorflow learning or examples
tutorial in there and then we'll go
ahead and do k
plus equals one so we just keep paging
through our different images and let's
see what that looks like let's go ahead
and do a plot
show and we'll go ahead and run this so
we take a look and see what we have here
and so we have a nice plot here and you
can just see that we have uh some random
numbers showing up in each one these
little subplots if you're wanting a copy
of this code put a note down in the
youtube video and let us know or come
visit us at
www.simplylearn.com and we'll send you
out a copy of what we're working on and
get a copy of that for your own setup uh
so now we've taken a look we can just
see we have here's our pictures they're
coming on we plotted them so we have an
idea of what we're looking at let's go
ahead and print let's look at the shape
of the features uh so when we have this
we have our nist train images and we'll
do the shape on there let's take a look
and just see what we're looking at
as far as uh our count and everything
and so you can see here we have 55 000
that's basically how many images we have
and this by 784 and in this data set
there's also our labels so let's take a
look at that we have our next train
labels shape let's take a look and see
what that looks like and there we have
10 because there's 10 digits so we
brought in that's our output we're
looking at and so we have there we go 55
000 they match they should match because
you should have equal numbers in both of
those you know here's our data in and
here's our answer if you remember this
is a bunch of zeros and with one each
each one will be zero zero zero one
would be what letter four or something
like that so let's take a look at what
our one hot encoding did for the first
observation and this is when we're
exploring data you really wanna dig in
there and just see what the heck am i
looking at so we're gonna look at the
labels and this would be the first label
that comes up and we'll go ahead and run
this and we look at that you can see
this is what i'm talking about zero zero
our one is zero two is zero three is
zero four zero five is zero six is zero
seven equals one so our very first label
is a seven but a very first label comes
up that it's a seven and so we don't
have like zero through nine we have a
bunch of zeros and just the one to mark
it as a seven on here so now we've kind
of looked a quick look at the data and
in here you might ask some questions
like what is 784 24 times 24 remember
that's the size of our grid on there or
our tents are coming in so 784 is a
setup on there and we've gone through
all this viewing the data we'll go ahead
and start looking at our tensorflow so
let's take our x variable this is going
to be our training set we'll do a
placeholder and then we're going to have
these come in as float now if i remember
correctly they're actually you know 0 or
1 for the values because they're either
but we have them coming in as a float
value and we have a little bit of a
shape coming in here and there's our 784
uh so we let it know that this is what's
what our input is for our tensorflow and
this is our training set so we'll just
put a label on there to help us track
that train set and then w and with w
we'll go ahead and do tf variables and
we'll do this as uh zeros variables to
have zeros and we'll set this as
784 by 10 10 being the output 784 being
our number of variables in and this is
our weights remember we have a bias in
there too and i'll go back over this in
just a second as we see how that fits
together in our tensorflow and we'll do
this one with our variables again we
have 10 so we're going to do the bias we
do it the same kind of format and setup
on here and so we'll do that as as tf 0s
of 10. so just create an array of 10
there and this is our bias so with these
three lines um and there's actually
they're coming out with the eager
execution which would bypass some of
what we're doing but this is important
to understand is the first thing you
have to do with tensorflow is we have to
allocate a space for the variables in
our tf placeholder and our tf variable
with our weights and our biases this
actually hasn't done anything yet so all
it is is placeholders that's why it's
okay to use zeros you could have just as
easily used ones or anything else and it
wouldn't matter the next stage is to go
ahead and set up some of the functions
going on but before we do that just note
that this hasn't done anything even if i
execute it all it's done is created
placeholders until we
a note here so we can keep track of
what's going on we're finding weighted
sum of inputs plus the bias uh so
there's our plus b the bias and then we
need to go ahead keep um let's do y
underscore and again another placeholder
and this one will set up it's actually
we'll put in as tf placeholder on here
tf placeholder float none 10. there's
our one hot encoder going on there so
our 10 values coming out and we'll do a
cross
entropy on here and this is going to be
minus tf reduce
sum and we'll do y here's our y
underscore which is remember we have
your y output and your actual output uh
so this will be our y underscore times
the t f log of y and then finally
before we do the actual initialization
of all our variables we'll set up our
train step this equals our gradient
descent optimizer very important
remember we looked at that chart on our
slides and so we've set up all these
formulas and here's our gradient descent
optimizer and as it keeps looking it
keeps looking for that zero value that's
what we're doing with that particular
formula so let's take a look and see
what we're doing here we just put
together all of our pieces for
tensorflow and you know the devil's in
the details we have here our training
set coming in we have to put a
placeholder on there we have our
variables with our weights we have our
biases coming out and then we put in our
the weighted sum so here's uh summizing
our summation here then we have our y
variable output so there's our y um how
it works and then of course the actual
output on there and then we have our
cross entropy coming in and that's our
minus tf dot reduced sum the y times the
tf log of y and then the training step
gradient descent optimizer and we're
using a 0.01 in this and we're going to
minimize cross entropy so we're going to
let it do all the work so once we've set
up all of these different layers we've
allocated for them we need to go ahead
and initialize them so we're going to do
an init tf initialize and it's going to
be all variables one of the cool things
is they're in the process of doing away
with this so all these steps would be
bundled into one instead of having to
add placeholders you initialize them in
the same process going on and then
finally everything in tensorflow is
based on your session now this is
changing that there's other options to
be able to run this but we want to go
ahead and do a session there's our tf
which is a tf session and then we want
to go ahead and do session run and what
are we going to run well we did
initialization of all our variables so
this is what we're running and this is
we're actually once we do this we
actually create our tensorflow object so
this whole piece of code right here is
our tensorflow object we have our input
coming in with our weighted variables
coming in our soft max for our metamol
going out how does it added together for
our y value and then we have the actual
uh float value coming out checking on
our all the way down so you can see all
the different stages going through that
we're setting up and this is one of the
reasons that a lot of people like
tensorflow is because you can designate
all these different pieces one step at a
time this is also one of the reasons
people don't like tensorflow is because
you have to designate all the different
layers coming down and there's a lot of
steps being made right now to minimize
this to make it either easier to
automate it or to allow you to do more
complicated things and all those steps
are still at play so it's worth looking
into the more advanced version and
what's going on with cross on top of
tensorflow it's also important to
understand what's going on in these
individual levels if you're going to
play with them it's important to
understand hey what's going on with the
finding the weighted sum of the inputs
plus the bias because there's other ways
to do that there's all kinds of other
tools in there now but this is the basic
setup that you want to do on a
tensorflow coming in and we want to go
ahead and just run and init our
tensorflow so let's go ahead and do that
let's run this we do get a warning here
because there's a move to use global
variables this is one of the changes
they're making but as far as this
example is not going to make a
difference because we're doing once we
initialize it this is initializing our
variables and again these are only
placeholders up here until we initialize
them and i would highly suggest put a
note down there or go over to
simplylearn.com and let them know and
have them email you a copy of the code
so you can actually play with this code
right here because this is the body of
what's going on in tensorflow this is
the build in neural networks and then
once we've done that now comes kind of
the fun part is we need to go ahead and
train it so we've created our tensorflow
we've created our network and now we
need to go ahead and train it uh so
let's put together that training code
and let's just do uh for i and range uh
1000 0 to 1 000. so we're just going to
look at the first 1000 in our training
and the way we pull that data from our
mints train next batch of 100 so you
look at this we're going to be doing
groups of 100 and then there's going to
go through a thousand of them this is
very important that tensorflow builds
this in this is one of the downsides of
doing sklearn or one of the older
packages is they don't let you batch
groups in they wanted to have it all up
front and then you have to build your
own batch programs right now uh this
lets us go ahead and do that and you can
see here we have batch x of s batch y of
s so there's our x and our y you can
look at this as our training of x and
our train of why or the data in and the
answer in uh and then we simply do our
session run uh so here's our session
that we've created we're gonna run it
and we wanna do the train step where we
initialized our train step up here in
our tf and so there's our train step
feed it's a dictionary dictionary coming
in which we're going to create right
here is x is our batch x of our sample
comma and our y underscore is going to
be our batch of our y sample and so this
goes through and we've now hit the run
button and we've trained our session
we've trained this setup on here and
once we've trained it then we need to go
ahead and find out how good our accuracy
was and actually start running some
predictions through there so we'll go
ahead and create a correct prediction
when this is where our tf.equal we'll
use our arg max y of 1 and tf argmax of
y of underscore of 1 to help us get the
correct predictions on there and we want
to use that to feed into an accuracy and
so our accuracy is going to be tf reduce
mean and we'll take that we'll do a cast
and this is the correct prediction that
we're sending in there and it is a
float value keep it simple and let's go
ahead and print this out so we can see
where we're looking at so what are we
printing out uh we need to do a session
run this session runs going to be on the
accuracy what accuracy comes from this
is our we're casting our tf on there
with the correct predictions on that so
here's our accuracy feed in so it needs
a dictionary for the data coming in
we're going to create our dictionary and
x is going to be our nist test images
and y underscore there is going to be
our nist dot test labels let me just
double check and make sure i have that
typed in there correctly there we go and
let's go ahead and run that and see what
comes up and we end up with a
0.9165 for our accuracy which means our
trained neural network does a pretty
good job letting us know what these
different symbols are and guessing that
a seven and a three and a four uh
something that as humans we kind of take
for granted i even have trouble reading
this so i don't know if i would be able
like that first one i would sit there
for a long time figuring out that's a
seven versus a two that could have
easily been a two to me so you see we
did a pretty good job analyzing this
data and this is used to analyze
something very complicated on these
images very different than uh just a
straight value of uh cost of sales and
here's our return and our marketing we
can now create this nice neural network
that does all kinds of cool things today
we're going to be covering the
convolutional neural network tutorial do
you know how deep learning recognizes
the objects in an image and really this
particular neural network is how image
recognition works it's very central one
of the biggest building blocks for image
recognition it does it using convolution
neural network and we over here we have
the basic picture of a hummingbird
pixels of an image fed as input you have
your input layer coming in so it takes
that graphic and puts it into the input
layer you have all your hidden layers
and then you have your output layer and
your output layer one of those is going
to light up and say oh it's a bird we're
going to go into depth we're going to
actually go back and forth on this a
number of times today so if you're not
catching all the image don't worry we're
going to get into the details so we have
our input layer accepts the pixels of
the image as input in the form of arrays
and you can see up here where they've
actually labeled each block of the bird
in different arrays so we'll dive into
deep as to how that looks like and how
those matrixes are set up here hidden
layer carry out feature extraction by
performing certain calculations and
manipulation so this is the part that
kind of reorganizes that picture
multiple ways until we get some data
that's easy to read for the neural
network this layer uses a matrix filter
and performs convolution operation to
detect patterns in the image and if you
remember that convolution means to coil
or to twist so we're going to twist the
data around and alter it and use that
operation to detect a new pattern there
are multiple hidden layers like
convolution layer rel u is how that is
pronounced when that's the rectified
linear unit that has to do with the
activation function that's used
pooling layer also uses multiple filters
to detect edges corners eyes feathers
beak etc and just like the term says
pooling is pulling information together
and we'll look into that a lot closer
here so if you're if it's a little
confusing now we'll dig in deep and try
to get you squared away with that and
then finally there is a fully connected
layer that identifies the object in the
image so we have these different layers
coming through in the hidden layers and
they come into the final area and that's
where we have say one node or one neural
network entity that lights up that says
it's a bird
what's in it for you we're going to
cover an introduction to the cnn what is
convolution neural network how cnn
recognizes images we're going to dig
deeper into that and really look at the
individual layers in the convolutional
neural network and finally we do a use
case implementation using the cnn we'll
begin our introduction to the cnn by
introducing the pioneer of convolutional
neural network jan lecun he was the
director of facebook ai research group
built the first convolutional neural
network called lynette in
1988 so these have been around for a
while and have had a chance to mature
over the years it was used for character
recognition tasks like reading zip code
digits imagine processing mail and
automating that process
cnn is a feed forward neural network
that is generally used to analyze visual
images by producing data with a
grid-like topology a cnn is also known
as a convent and very key to this is we
are looking at images that was what this
was designed for and you'll see the
different layers as we dig in near some
of the other some of them are actually
now used since we're using tensorflow
and cross in our code later on you'll
see that some of those layers appear in
a lot of your other neural network
frameworks but in this case this is very
central to processing images and doing
so in a variety that captures multiple
images and really drills down into their
different features in this example here
you see flowers are two varieties orchid
and a rose i think the orchid is much
more dainty and beautiful and the rose
smells quite beautiful i have a couple
rose bushes in my yard uh they go into
the input layer that data is then sent
to all the different nodes in the next
layer one of the hidden layers based on
its different weights and its setup it
then comes out and gives those a new
value those values then are multiplied
by their weights and go to the next
hidden layer and so on and then you have
the output layer and one of those nodes
comes out and says it's an orchid and
the other one comes out and says it's a
rose depending on how it was well it was
trained what separates the cnn or the
convolutional neural network from other
neural networks is a convolutional
operation forms the basis of any
convolutional neural network in a cnn
every image image is represented in the
form of arrays of pixel values so here
we have a real image of the digit 8.
that then gets put on to
its pixel values represented in the form
of an array in this case you have a
two-dimensional array and then you can
see in the final in form we transform
the digit eight into its
representational form of pixels of zeros
and 1 where the ones represent in this
case the black part of the 8 and the 0s
represent the white background to
understand the convolution neural
network or how that convolutional
operation works we're going to take a
side step and look at matrixes in this
case we're going to simplify it and
we're going to take two matrices a and b
of one dimension now kind of separate
this from your thinking as we learned
that you want to focus just on the
matrix aspect of this and then we'll
bring that back together and see what
that looks like when we put the pieces
for the convolutional operation here
we've set up two arrays we have in this
case our single dimension matrix and we
have a equals five three seven five nine
seven and we have b equals one two three
so in the convolution as it comes in
there it's going to look at these two
and we're going to start by doing
multiplying them a times b and so we
multiply the arrays element wise and we
get 5 6 6
where 5 is the five times one six is
three times two and then the other six
is two times three and since the two
arrays aren't the same size they're not
the same setup we're going to just
truncate the first one and we're gonna
look at the second array multiplied just
by the first three elements of the first
array now that's gonna be a little
confusing remember a computer gets to
repeat these processes hundreds of times
so we're not gonna just forget those
other numbers later on we'll see we'll
bring those back in and then we have the
sum of the product in this case 5 plus 6
plus 6 equals 17. so in our a times b
our very first digit in that matrix of a
times b is 17. and if you remember i
said we're not going to forget the other
digits so we now have three two five we
move one set over and we take three two
five and we multiply that times b and
you'll see that uh three times one is
three two times two is four and so on
and so on we sum it up so now we have
the second digit of our a times b
product in the matrix and we continue on
with that same thing so on and so on so
then we would go from 375 to 759 to 597.
this short matrix that we have for a
we've now covered all the different
entities in a that match three different
levels of b now in a little bit we're
going to cover where we use this math at
this multiplying of matrixes and how
that works
but it's important to understand that
we're going through the matrix of
multiplying the different parts to it to
match the smaller matrix with the larger
matrix i know a lot of people get lost
at is what's going on here with these
matrixes uh oh scary math not really
that scary when you break it down we're
looking at a section of a and we're
comparing it to b so when you break that
down your mind like that you realize
okay so i'm i'm just taking these two
matrixes and comparing them and i'm
bringing the value down into one matrix
a times b we're deucing that information
in a way that will help the computer see
different aspects let's go ahead and
flip over again back to our images
here we are back to our images talking
about going to the most basic
two-dimensional image you can get to
consider the following two images the
image for the symbol backslash when you
press the backslash the above image is
processed you can see there for the
image for the forward slash is the
opposite so we click the forward slash
button that flips uh very basic we have
four pixels going in can't get any more
basic than that here we have a little
bit more complicated picture we take a
real image of a smiley face
then we represent that in the form of
black and white pixels so if this was an
image in the computer it's black and
white and like we saw before we convert
this into the zeros and one so where the
other one would have just been a matrix
of just four dots now we have a
significantly larger image coming in so
don't worry we're going to bring this
all together here in just a little bit
layers in convolutional neural network
we're looking at this we have our
convolution layer and that really is the
central aspect of processing images in
the convolutional neural network that's
why we have it and then that's going to
be feeding in and you have your relu
layer which is you know as we talked
about the rectified linear unit we'll
talk about that a little bit later the
relu is in how it act is how that layer
is activated is the math behind it what
makes the neurons fire you'll see that a
lot of other neural networks when you're
using it just by itself it's for
processing smaller amounts of data where
you use the atom activation feature for
large data coming in now because we're
processing small amounts of data in each
image the relu layer works great you
have your pooling layer that's where
you're pulling the data together pooling
is a neural network term it's very
commonly used i like to use the term
reduce so if you're coming from the map
and reduce side you'll see that we're
mapping all this data through all these
networks and then we're going to reduce
it we're going to pull it together and
then finally we have the fully connected
layer that's where our output is going
to come out so we have started to look
at matrixes we've started to look at the
convolutional layer where it fits in and
everything we've taken a look at images
so we're going to focus more on the
convolution layer since this is a
convolutional neural network a
convolution layer has a number of
filters and perform convolution
operation every image is considered as a
matrix of pixel values consider the
following 5x5 image whose pixel values
are only 0 and 1. now obviously when
we're dealing with color there's all
kinds of things that come in on color
processing but we want to keep it simple
and just keep it black and white and so
we have our image pixels so we're
sliding the filter matrix over the image
and computing the dot product to detect
the patterns and right here you're going
to ask where does this filter come from
this is a bit confusing because the
filter
is going to be derived
later on we build the filters when we
program or train our model so you don't
need to worry what the filter actually
is but you do need to understand how a
convolution layer works is what is the
filter doing filter and you'll have mini
filters you don't have just one filter
you'll have lots of filters that are
going to look for different aspects and
so the filter might be looking for just
edges it might be looking for different
parts we'll cover that a little bit more
detail in a minute right now we're just
focusing on how the filter works as a
matrix remember earlier we talked about
multiplying matrixes together and here
we have our two dimensional matrix and
you can see we take the filter and we
multiply it in the upper left image and
you can see right here one times one one
times zero one times one we multiply
those all together then sum them and we
end up with the convolved feature of
four we're going to take that and
sliding the filter matrix over the image
and computing the dot product to detect
patterns so we're just going to slide
this over we're going to predict the
first one and slide it over one notch
predict the second one and so on and so
on all the way through until we have a
new matrix and this matrix which is the
same size as the filter has reduced the
image and whatever filter whatever
that's filtering out it's going to be
looking at just those features reduced
down to a smaller matrix so once the
feature maps are extracted the next step
is to move them to the relu layer so the
relu layer the next step first is going
to perform an element-wise operation so
each of those maps coming in if there's
negative pixels so it says all the
negative pixels to zero and you can see
this nice graph where it just zeros out
the negatives and then you have a value
that goes from zero up to whatever value
is coming out of the matrix this
introduces non-linearity to the network
so up until now we have a we say
linearity we're talking about the fact
that the feature has a value so it's a
linear feature this feature
came up and has let's say the feature is
the edge of the beak you know it's like
or the backslash that we saw um you'll
look at that and say okay this feature
has a value from negative 10 to 10 in
this case if it was one it'd say yeah
this might be a beak it might not might
be an edge right there a minus five
means no we're not even going to look at
it to zero and so we end up with an
output and the output takes all these
features all these filtered features
remember we're not just running one
filter on this we're running a number of
filters on this image and so we end up
with a rectified feature map that is
looking at just the features coming
through and how they weigh in from our
filters so here we have an input of a
looks like a toucan bird
very exotic looking real image is
scanned in multiple convolution and the
relu layers for locating features and
you can see up here is turn it into a
black and white image and in this case
we're looking in the upper right hand
corner for a feature and that box scans
over a lot of times it doesn't scan one
pixel at a time a lot of times it will
skip by two or three or four pixels uh
to speed up the process that's one of
the ways you can compensate if you don't
have enough resources on your
computation for large images and it's
not just one filter slowly goes across
the image you have multiple filters have
been programmed in there so you're
looking at a lot of different filters
going over the different aspects of the
image and just sliding across there and
forming a new matrix
one more aspect to note about the relu
layer is we're not just having one value
coming in uh so not only do we have
multiple features going through but
we're generating multiple relu layers
for locating the features that's very
important to note you know so we have a
quite a bundle we have multiple filters
multiple railway which brings us to the
next step forward propagation now we're
going to look at the pooling layer the
rectified feature map now goes through a
pooling layer pooling is a down sampling
operation that reduces the
dimensionality of the feature map that's
all we're trying to do we're trying to
take a huge amount of information and
reduce it down to a single answer this
is a specific kind of bird this is an
iris this is a rose so you have a
rectified feature map and you see here
we have a rectified feature map coming
in
we set the max pooling with a 2x2
filters and a stride of two and if you
remember correctly i talked about not
going one pixel at a time well that's
where the stride comes in we end up with
a two by two pooled feature map but
instead of moving one over each time and
looking at every possible combination we
skip a st we skip a few there we go by
two we skip every other pixel and we
just do every other one and this reduces
our rectified feature map which is you
can see over here 16 by 16 to a 4x4 so
we're continually trying to filter and
reduce our data so that we can get to
something we can manage and over here
you see that we have the max
three four one and two and in the max
pooling we're looking for the max value
a little bit different than what we were
looking at before so coming from the
rectified feature we're now finding the
max value and then we're pulling those
features together so instead of thinking
this is image of the map think of this
as how valuable is a feature in that
area how much of a feature value do we
have we just want to find the best or
the maximum feature for that area they
might have that one piece of the filter
of the beak said oh i see a one in this
beak in this image and then it skips
over and says i see a three in this
image and says oh this one is rated as a
four we don't want to sum it together
because then you know you might have
like five ones and it'll say ah five but
you might have uh four zeros and one ten
and that ten says well this is
definitely a beak where the ones will
say probably not a beak a little strange
analogy since we're looking at a bird
but you can see how that pulled feature
map comes down and we're just looking
for the max value in each one of those
matrixes pooling layer uses different
filters to identify different parts of
the image like edges corners body
feathers eyes beak etc i know i focus
mainly on the beak but obviously each
feature could be each a different part
of the bird coming in so let's take a
look at what that looks like structure
of a convolution neural network so far
this is where we're at right now we have
our input image coming in and then we
use our filters and there's multiple
filters on there that are being
developed to kind of twist and change
that data and so we multiply the
matrixes we take that little filter
maybe it's a 2x2 we multiply it by each
piece of the image and if we step 2 then
it's every other piece of the image that
generates multiple convolution layers so
we have a number of convolution layers
we have
set up in there just looking at that
data we then take those convolution
layers we run them through the relu
setup and then once we've done through
the relu setup and we have multiple
values going on multiple layers that are
relu then we're going to take those
multiple layers and we're going to be
pooling them so now we have the pooling
layers or multiple poolings going on up
until this point we're dealing with
sometimes multiple dimensions you can
have three dimensions some strange data
setups that aren't doing images but
looking at other things they can have
four five six seven dimensions
so right now we're looking at 2d image
dimensions coming in into the pooling
layer so the next step is we want to
reduce those dimensions or flatten them
so flattening flattening is a process of
converting all of the resultant
two-dimensional arrays from pooled
feature map into a single long
continuous linear vector so over here
you see where we have a pooled feature
map maybe that's the bird wing and it
has values 6847 and we want to just
flatten this out and turn it into 6847
or a single linear vector and we find
out that not only do we do each of the
pooled feature maps we do all of them
into one long linear vector so now we've
gone through our convolutional neural
network part and we have the input layer
into the next setup all we've done is
taken all those different pooling layers
and we flatten them out and combine them
into a single linear vector going in so
after we've done the flattening we have
just a quick recap because we've covered
so much so it's important to go back and
take a look at each of the steps we've
gone through the structure of the
network so far we have our convolution
where we twist it and we filter it and
multiply the matrixes we end up with our
convolutional layer which uses the rel u
to figure out the values going out into
the pooling as you have numerous
convolution layers that then create
numerous pooling layers pulling that
data together which is the max value
which one we want to send forward we
want to send the best value and then
we're going to take all of that from
each of the pooling layers and we're
going to flatten it and we're going to
combine them into a single input going
into the final layer once you get to
that step you might be looking at that
going boy that looks like the normal
intuit to most neural network and you're
correct it is
so once we have the flattened matrix
from the pooling layer that becomes our
input so the pooling layer is fed as an
input to the fully connected layer to
classify the image and so you can see as
our flattened matrix comes in in this
case we have the pixels from the
flattened matrix fed as an input back to
our toucan or whatever that kind of bird
that is i need one of these to identify
what kind of bird that is it comes into
our ford propagation network
and that will then have the different
weights coming down across and then
finally it selects that that's a bird
and that it's not a dog or a cat in this
case
even though it's not labeled the final
layer there in red is our output layer
our final output layer that says bird
cat or dog so quick recap of everything
we've covered so far we have our input
image which is twisted and multiplied
the filters are multiplied times the
matrix and the two matrixes multiplied
all the filters to create our
convolution layer our convolution layers
there's multiple layers in there because
it's all building multiple layers off
the different filters then goes through
the relu as this activation and that
creates our pooling and so once we get
into the pooling layer we then and the
pooling look for who's the best what's
the max value coming in from our
convolution and we take that layer and
we flatten it and then it goes into a
fully connected layer our fully
connected neural network and then to the
output and here we can see the entire
process how the cnn recognizes a bird
this is kind of nice because it's
showing the little pixels and where
they're going you can see the filter is
generating this convolution network and
that filter shows up in the bottom part
of the convolution network and then
based on that it uses the relu for the
pooling the pulling then find out which
one's the best and so on all the way to
the fully connected layer at the end or
the classification in the output layer
so that'd be a classification neural
network at the end so we covered a lot
of theory up till now and you can
imagine each one of these steps has to
be broken down in code so putting that
together can be a little complicated not
that each step of the process is overly
complicated but because we have so many
steps we have one two three four five
different steps going on here with sub
steps in there we're going to break that
down and walk through that in code so in
our use case implementation using the
cnn we'll be using the cfar10 set from
canadian institute for advanced research
for classifying images across 10
categories unfortunately they don't let
me know whether it's going to be a
toucan or some other kind of bird but we
do get to find out whether it can
categorize between a ship a frog deer
bird airplane automobile cat dog horse
truck so that's a lot of fun and if
you're looking anything in the news at
all of our automated cars and everything
else you can see where this kind of
processing is so important in today's
world and very cutting edge as far as
what's coming out in the commercial
deployment i mean this is really cool
stuff we're starting to see this just
about everywhere in industry so great
time to be playing with this and
figuring it all out let's go ahead and
dive into the code and see what that
looks like when we're actually writing
our script
before we go on let's do uh one more
quick look at what we have here let's
just take a look at data batch one keys
and remember jupiter notebook i can get
by with not doing the print statement if
i put a variable down there it'll just
display the variable and you can see in
our data batch one for the keys since
this is a dictionary we have the batch
one label data and file names so you can
actually see how it's broken up in our
data set so for the next step or step
four as we're calling it uh we want to
display the images using matte plot
library there's many ways to display the
images you can even well there's other
ways to drill into it but matplot
library is really good for this and
we'll also look at our first reshape
setup or shaping the data so you can
have a little glimpse into what that
means uh so we're going to start by
importing our map plot and of course
since i am doing jupiter notebook i need
to do the matplot inline command so it
shows up on my page so here we go we're
going to import matplot library.pipelot
as plt and if you remember matplot
library the pie plot is like a canvas
that we paint stuff onto and there's my
percentage sign matplot library inline
so it's going to show up in my notebook
and then of course we're going to import
numpy as np for our numbers python array
setup and let's go ahead and set
x equals to data batch one so this will
pull in all the data going into the x
value and then because this is just a
long stream of binary data uh we need to
go a little bit of reshaping so in here
we have to go ahead and reshape the data
we have 10 000 images okay that looks
correct and this is kind of an
interesting thing it took me a little
bit to i had to go research this myself
to figure out what's going on with this
data and what it is is it's a 32 by 32
picture and let me do this let me go
ahead and do a drawing pad on here so we
have 32 bits by 32 bits and it's in
color so there's three bits of color now
i don't know why the data is
particularly like this it probably has
to do with how they originally encoded
it but most pictures put the three
afterward so what we're doing here is
we're going to take uh the shape we're
going to take the data which is just a
long stream of information and we're
gonna break it up into ten thousand
pieces and those ten thousand pieces
then are broken into three pieces each
and those three pieces then are 32 by
32. you can look at this like an
old-fashioned projector where they have
the red screen or the red projector the
blue projector and the green projector
and they add them all together and each
one of those is a 32 by 32 bit so that's
probably how this was originally
formatted was in that kind of ideal
things have changed so we're going to
transpose it and we're going to take the
three which was here and we're going to
put it at the end so the first part is
reshaping the data from a single line of
bit data or whatever format it is into
10 000 by 3 by 32 by 32 and then we're
going to transpose the color factor to
the last place so it's the image then
the 32 by 32 in the middle that's this
part right here and then finally we're
going to take this which is three bits
of data and put it at the end so it's
more like we do process images now and
then as type this is really important
that we're going to use an integer 8.
you can come in here and you'll see a
lot of these they'll try to do this with
a float or a float 64. what you got to
remember though is a float uses a lot of
memory so once you switch this into uh
something that's not integer eight which
is goes up to 128 you are just gonna the
the amount of ram let's just put that in
here is going to go way up the amount of
ram that it loads so you want to go
ahead and use this you can try the other
ones and see what happens if you have a
lot of ram on your computer but for this
exercise this will work just fine and
let's go ahead and take that and run
this so now our x variable is all loaded
and it has all the images in it from the
batch one data batch one and just to
show we were talking about with the as
type on there if we go ahead and take x0
and just look for its max value let me
go ahead and run that uh you'll see it
doesn't oops i said 128 it's 255. uh
you'll see it doesn't go over 255
because it's basically an ascii
character is what we're keeping that
down to we're keeping those values down
so they're only 25 00 to 255 versus a
float value which would bring this up
exponentially in size and since we're
using the matplot library we can do
oops that's not what i wanted since
we're using the map plot library we can
take our canvas and just do a plt dot im
for image show and uh let's just take a
look at what x0 looks like and it comes
in i'm not sure what that is but you can
see it's a very low grade image broken
down to the minimal pixels on there and
if we did the same thing oh let's do uh
let's see what one looks like hopefully
it's a little easier to see run on there
not enter let's hit the run on that
and we can see this is probably a semi
truck that's a good guess on there and i
can just go back up here instead of
typing the same line in over and over
and we'll look at three uh that looks
like a dump truck unloading uh and so on
you can do any of the 10 000 images and
just jump to 55 looks like some kind of
animal looking at us there probably a
dog and just for fun let's do just one
more uh
run on there and we can see a nice car
for our image number four uh so you can
see we pace through all the different
images it's very easy to look at them
and they've been reshaped to fit our
view and what the
matplot library uses for its format so
the next step is we're going to start
creating some helper functions we'll
start by a one hot encoder to help us or
processing the data remember that your
labels they can't just be words they
have to switch it and we use the one hot
encoder to do that and then we'll also
create a
class
cfar helper so it's going to have an
init and a setup for the images and then
finally we'll go ahead and run that code
so you can see what that looks like and
then we get into the fun part where
we're actually going to start creating
our model our actual neural network
model so let's start by creating our one
hot encoder we're going to create our
own here
and it's going to return an out and
we'll have our vector coming in and our
values equal 10. what this means is that
we have the 10 values the 10 possible
labels and remember we don't look at the
labels as a number because a car isn't
one more than a horse i'd be just kind
of bizarre to have horse equals zero car
equals one plane equals two cat equals
three so a cat plus a car equals what uh
so instead we create a numpy array of
zeros and there's going to be 10 values
so we have a 10 different values in
there so you have uh 0 or 1. 1 means
it's a cat 0 means it's not a cat
in the next line it might be that one
means it's a car 0 means it's not a car
so instead of having one output with a
value of 0 to 10 you have 10 outputs
with the values of 0 to 1. that's what
the one hot encoder is doing here and
we're going to utilize this in code in
just a minute so let's go ahead and take
a look at the next helpers we have a few
of these helper functions we're going to
build and when you're working with a
very complicated python project dividing
it up into separate definitions and
classes is very important otherwise it
just becomes really ungainly to work
with so let's go ahead and put in our
next helper which is a class and this is
a lot in this class so we'll break it
down here and let's just start uh oops
we put a space right in there there we
go that was a little bit more readable
at a second space so we're going to
create our class the cipher helper and
we'll start by initializing it now
there's a lot going on in here so let's
start with the init part uh self.i
equals zero that'll come in a little bit
we'll come back to that in the lower
part we want to initialize our training
batches so when we went through this
there was like a meta batch we don't
need the meta batch but we do need the
data batch one two three four five and
we do not want the testing batch in here
this is just the self all train batches
so we're gonna come make an array of all
those different images and then of
course we left the test batch out so we
have our self.test batch
we're going to initialize the training
images and the training labels and also
the test images and the test labels so
these are just this is just to
initialize these variables in here then
we create another definition down here
and this is going to set up the images
let's just take a look and see what's
going on in there now we could have all
just put this as part of the
init part since this is all just helper
stuff but breaking it up again makes it
easier to read it also makes it easier
when we start executing the different
pieces to see what's going on so that
way we have a nice print statement to
say hey we're now running this and this
is what's going on in here we're going
to set up the self training images at
this point and that's going to go to a
numpy array v stack and in there we're
going to load up uh in this case the
data for d itself all train batches
again that points right up to here so
we're going to go through each one of
these uh files or each one of these data
sets because they're not a file anymore
we've brought them in data batch one
points to the actual data and so our
self training images is going to stack
them all into our into a numpy array and
then it's always nice to get the
training length and that's just the
total number of self training images in
there and then we're going to take the
self training images let me switch
marker colors because i am getting a
little bit too much on the markers up
here oops there we go bring down our
marker change
so we can see it a little better and at
this point this should look familiar
where did we see this well when we
wanted to uh look at this above and we
want to look at the images in the
matplot library we had to reshape it so
we're doing the same thing here we're
taking our self training images and uh
based on the training length total
number of images because we stacked them
all together so now it's just one large
file of images we're going to take and
look at it as our three video cameras
that are each displaying a 32 by 32
we're going to switch that around so
that now we have each of our images that
stays the same place and then we have
our 32 by 32 and then by our three our
last are three different values for the
color and of course we want to go ahead
and they run this where we say divide by
255 that was from earlier it just brings
all the data into zero to one that's
what this is doing so we're turning this
into a zero to one array which is uh all
the pictures 32 by 32 by three and then
we're going to take the self training
labels and we're going to pump those
through our one hot encoder we just made
and we're going to stack them together
and
again we're converting this into an
array that goes from uh instead of
having horse equals 1 dog equals 2 and
then horse plus dog would equal 3 which
would be cat
now it's going to be you know an array
of 10 where each one is 0 to 1. then we
want to go ahead and set up our test
images and labels and when we're doing
this you're going to see it's the same
thing we just did with the rest of them
we just changed colors right here this
is no different than what we're doing up
here with our training set
we're going to stack the different
images
we're going to get the length of them so
we know how many images are in there you
certainly could add them by hand but
it's nice to let the computer do it
especially if it ever changes on the
other end and you're using other data
and again we reshape them and transpose
them and we also do the one hot encoder
same thing we just did on our training
images so now our test images are in the
same format so now we have a definition
which sets up all our images in there
and then the next step is to go ahead
and batch them or next batch and let's
do another breakout here for batches
because this is really important to
understand tends to throw me for a
little loop when i'm working with
tensorflow or keras or a lot of these we
have our data coming in if you remember
we had like 10 000 photos let me just
put 10 000 down here we don't want to
run all 10 000 at once so we want to
break this up into batch sizes and you
also remember that we had the number of
photos in this case uh length of test or
whatever number is in there we also have
32 by 32
by 3. so when we're looking at the batch
size we want to change this from 10 000
to
a batch of in this case i think we're
going to do batches of 100 so we want to
look at just 100 the first hundred of
the photos and if you remember we set
self i
equal to
zero
so what we're looking at here is we're
going to create x we're going to get the
next batch from the very initialize
we've already initialized it for 0. so
we're going to look at x from 0 to batch
size which we set to 100 so just the
first 100 images and then we're going to
reshape that into
and this is important to let the data
know that we're looking at 100 by 32 by
32 by 3. now we've already formatted it
to the 32 by 32 by 3. this just sets
everything up correctly so that x has
the data in there in the correct order
and the correct shape and then the y
just like the x uh is our labels so our
training labels again they go from zero
to batch size in this case they do sell
five plus batch size because the selfie
is going to keep changing and then
finally we increment the self i because
we have 0 so we so the next time we call
it we're going to get the next batch
size and so basically we have x and y x
being the photograph data coming in and
y being the label and that of course is
labeled through one hot encoder so if
you remember correctly if it was say
horse is equal to zero it would be
one for the zero position since this is
the horse and then everything else would
be zero in here let me just put lines
through there there we go there's our
array
hard to see that array so let's go ahead
and take that and uh we're going to
finish loading it since this is our
class and now we're armed with all this
our setup over here let's go ahead and
load that up and so we're going to
create a variable ch with the cfar
helper in it and then we're going to do
ch dot setup images
now we could have just put all the setup
images under the init but by breaking
this up into two parts it makes it much
more readable and also if you're doing
other work there's reasons to do that as
far as the setup let's go ahead and run
that and you can see where it says uh
setting up training images and labels
setting up test images and that's one of
the reasons we broke it up is so that if
you're testing this out you can actually
have print statements in there telling
you what's going on which is really nice
uh they did a good job with this setup i
like the way that it was broken up in
the back and then one quick note you
want to remember that batch to set up
the next batch says we have to run
batch equals ch next batch of 100
because we're going to use the 100 size
but we'll come back to that we're going
to use that just remember that that's
part of our code we're going to be using
in a minute from the definition we just
made so now we're ready to create our
model first thing we want to do is we
want to import our tensorflow as tf i'll
just go ahead and run that so it's
loaded up and you can see we got a
warning here
that's because they're making some
changes it's always growing and they're
going to be depreciating one of the
values from float 64 to float type or is
treated as an np float 64. nothing to
really worry about this doesn't even
affect what we're working on because
we've set all of our stuff to a 255
value or zero to one and do keep in mind
that zero to one value that we converted
to 255 is still a float value but it'll
easily work with either the numpy float
64 or the numpy d type float it doesn't
matter which one it goes through so the
depreciation would not affect our code
as we have it and in our tensorflow uh
we'll go ahead and just increase the
size in there just a moment so you can
get better view of the um what we're
typing in uh we're going to set a couple
placeholders here and so we have we're
going to set x equals tf placeholder tf
float 32 we just talked about the float
64 versus the numpy float we're actually
just going to keep this at float 32 more
than a significant number of decimals
for what we're working with and since
it's a placeholder we're going to set
the shape equal to and we've set it
equal to none
because at this point we're just holding
the place on there we'll be setting up
as we run the batches that's what the
first value is and then 32 by 32 by 3
that's what we reshaped our data to fit
in and then we have our y true equals
placeholder tf float 32 and the shape
equals none comma 10. 10 is the 10
different labels we have so it's an
array of 10. and then let's create one
more placeholder we'll call this a hold
prob or hold probability and we're going
to use this we don't have to have a
shape or anything for this this
placeholder is for what we call drop out
if you remember from our theory before
we drop out so many nodes is looking at
or the different values going through
which helps decrease bias so we need to
go ahead and put a placeholder for that
also and we'll run this so it's all
loaded up in there so we have our three
different placeholders and since we're
in tensorflow when you use keras it does
some of this automatically but we're in
tensorflow direct cross sits on
tensorflow we're going to go ahead and
create some more helper functions we're
going to create something to help us
initialize the weights initialize our
bias if you remember that each layer has
to have a bias going in we're going to
go ahead and work on our conversional 2d
our max pool so we have our pooling
layer our convolutional layer and then
our normal full layer so we're going to
go ahead and put those all into
definitions and let's see what that
looks like in code and you can also grab
some of these helper functions from the
mnist the uh nist setup let me just put
that in there if you're under the
tensorflow so a lot of these already in
there but we're going to go ahead and do
our own and we're going to create our
init weights and one of the reasons
we're doing this is so that you can
actually start thinking about what's
going on in the back end so even though
there's ways to do this with an
automation sometimes these have to be
tweaked and you have to put in your own
setup in here now we're not going to be
doing that we're just going to recreate
them for our code and let's take a look
at this we have our weights and so what
comes in is going to be the shape and
what comes out is going to be
random number so we're going to go ahead
and just knit some random numbers based
on the shape with a standard deviation
of 0.1 kind of a fun way to do that and
then the tf variable uh init random
distribution so we're just creating a
random distribution on there that's all
that is for the weights now you might
change that you might have a higher
standard deviation in some cases you
actually load preset weights that's
pretty rare usually you're testing that
against another model or something like
that and you want to see how those
weights configure with each other now
remember we have our bias so we need to
go ahead and initialize the bias with a
constant
in this case we're using 0.1 a lot of
times the bias is just put in as one and
then you have your weights add on to
that but we're going to set this as 0.1
uh so we want to return a convolutional
2d in this case a neural network this is
uh would be a layer on here what's going
on with the con 2d is we're taking our
data coming in
we're going to filter it strides if you
remember correctly strides came from
here's our image and then we only look
at this picture here and then maybe we
have a stride of one so we look at this
picture here and we continue to look at
the different filters going on there the
other thing this does is that we have
our data coming in as 32
by
3 and we want to change this so that
it's just this is three dimensions and
it's going to reformat this as just two
dimensions so it's going to take this
number here and combine it with the 32
by 32. so this is a very important layer
here because it's reducing our data down
using different means and it connects
down i'm just going to jump down one
here it goes with the convolutional
layer so you have your your kind of your
preformatting and the setup and then you
have your actual convolution layer that
goes through on there and you can see
here we have a knit weights by the shape
a knit bias shape of three because we
have the three different uh here's our
three again and then we return the tfnn
relu with the convention 2d so this
convolutional has this feeding into it
right there it's using that as part of
it and of course the input is the x y
plus b the bias so that's quite a
mouthful but these two are the are the
keys here to creating the convolutional
layers there the convolutional 2d coming
in and then the convolutional layer
which then steps through and creates all
those filters we saw then of course we
have our pooling uh so after each time
we run it through the convectional layer
we want to pull the data if you remember
correctly on the on the pool side and
let me just get rid of all my marks it's
getting a little crazy there and in fact
let's go ahead and jump back to that
slide let's just take a look at that
slide over here uh so we have our image
coming in we create our convolutional
layer with all the filters remember the
filters go um you know the filter is
coming in here and it looks at these
four boxes and then if it's a step let's
say step two it then goes to these four
boxes and then the next step and so on
uh so we have our convolutional layer
that we generate or convolutional layers
they use the uh relu function there's
other functions out there for this
though the relu is the uh most the one
that works the best at least so far i'm
sure that will change then we have our
pooling now if you remember correctly
the pooling was max uh so if we had the
filter coming in and they did the
multiplication on there and we have a
one and maybe a two here and another one
here and a three here three is the max
and so out of all of these you then
create an array that would be three and
if the max is over here two or whatever
it is that's what goes into the pooling
of what's going on in our pooling uh so
again we're reducing that data down
reducing it down as small as we can and
then finally
we're going to flatten it out into a
single array and that goes into our
fully connected layer and you can see
that here in the code right here we're
going to create our normal full layer so
at some point we're going to take from
our pooling layer this will go into some
kind of flattening process and then that
will be fed into the full the different
layers going in down here and so we have
our input size you'll see our input
layer get shape which is just going to
get the shape for whatever is coming in
uh and then input size initial weights
is also based on the input layer coming
in and the input size down here is based
on the input layer shape so we're just
going to already use the shape and
already have our size coming in and of
course uh you have to make sure you knit
the bias always put your bias on there
and we'll do that based on the size so
this will return
tf.matimole
input layer w plus b this is just a
normal full layer that's what this means
right down here that's what we're going
to return so that was a lot of steps we
went through let's go ahead and run that
so those are all loaded in there and
let's go ahead and create the layers
let's see what that looks like
now that we've done all the heavy
lifting and everything we get to do all
the easy part let's go ahead and create
our layers we'll create a convolution
layer one and two two different
convolutional layers and then we'll take
that and we'll flatten that out create a
reshape pooling in there for our reshape
and then we'll have our full
layer at the end so let's start by
creating our first convolutional layer
then we come in here and let me just run
that real quick and i want you to notice
on here the 3 and the 32 this is
important because coming into this
convolutional layer we have three
different channels and 32 pixels each
so that has to be in there the four and
four you can play with this is your
filter size so if you remember you have
a filter and you have your image and the
filter slowly steps over and filters out
this image depending on what your step
is for this particular setup 4 4 is just
fine that should work pretty good for
what we're doing for the size of the
image and then of course at the end once
you have your convolutional layer set up
you also need to pull it and you'll see
that the pooling is automatically set up
so that it would see the different shape
based on what's coming in so here we
have max toolbar 2x2 and we put in the
convolutional one that we just created
the convolutional layer we just created
goes right back into it and that right
up here as you can see is the x that's
coming in from here so it knows to look
at the first model and set the the data
accordingly set that up
so matches and we went ahead and ran
this already i think i read let me go
and run it again and if we're going to
do one layer let's go ahead and do a
second layer down here and it's uh we'll
call it convo 2.
it's also a convolutional layer on this
and you'll see that we're feeding
convolutional one in the pooling so it
goes from convolutional one into
convolutional one pooling from
convolutional one pooling into
convolutional two and then from
convolutional two into convolutional to
pooling and we'll go ahead and take this
and run this so these variables are all
loaded into memory and for our flattened
layer
let's go ahead and we'll do since we
have 64 coming out of here and we have a
4x4 going in let's do 8 by 8 by 64. so
let's do
4096. this is going to be the flat layer
so that's how many bits are coming
through on the flat layer and we'll
reshape this so we'll reshape our
convo 2 pooling and that will feed into
here the combo 2 pulling and then we're
going to set it up as a single layer
that's 4096 in size that's what that
means there we'll go ahead and run this
so we've now created this variable the
convo 2 flat and then we have our first
full layer this is the final
neural network where the flat layer
going in and we're going to again use
the relu for our setup on there on a
neural network for evaluation and you'll
notice that we're going to create our
first full layer our normal full layer
that's our definition so we created that
that's creating the normal full layer
and our input for the data comes right
here from the this goes right into it
the convo too flat so this tells it how
big the data is and we're going to have
it come out it's going to have 10 24
that's how big the layer is coming out
we'll go ahead and run this so now we
have our full layer one and with the
full layer one we want to also define
the full one dropout to go with that so
our full layer one comes in uh keep
probability equals whole probability
remember we created that earlier and the
full layer one is what's coming into it
and this is going backwards and training
the data we're not training every weight
we're only training a percentage of them
each time which helps get rid of the
bias so let me go ahead and run that and
finally we'll go ahead and create a y
predict which is going to equal the
normal full 1 drop out and 10 because we
have 10 labels in there now in this
neural network we could have added
additional layers that would be another
option to play with you can also play
with instead of 10 24 you can use other
numbers for the way that sets up and
what's coming out going into the next
one we're only going to do just the one
layer and the one layer drop out and you
can see if we did another layer it'd be
really easy just to feed in the full one
drop out into full layer two and then
full layer two dropout would have full
layer two feed into it and then you'd
switch that here for the y prediction
for right now this is great this
particular data set is tried and true
and we know that this will work on it
and if we just type in y predict and we
run that
we'll see that this is a tensor object
shape question mark 10 d type 32 a quick
way to double check what we're working
on so now we've got all of our we've
done a setup all the way to the y
predict which we just did we want to go
ahead and apply the loss function and
make sure that's set up in there create
the optimizer and then
trainer optimizer and create a variable
to initialize all the global tf
variables so before we dive in to the
loss function let me point out one quick
thing or just kind of a rehab over a
couple things and that is when we're
playing with this these setups
we pointed out up here we can change the
4 4 and use different numbers there they
change your outcome so depending on what
numbers you use here will have a huge
impact on how well your model fits and
that's the same here with the 10 24 also
this is also another number that if you
continue to raise that number you'll get
possibly a better fit you might overfit
and if you lower that number you'll use
less resources and generally you want to
use this in
the exponential growth an exponential
being 2 4 8 16 and in this case the next
one down would be 5 12. you can use any
number there but those would be the
ideal numbers when you look at this data
so the next step in all this is we need
to also create a way of tracking how
good our model is and we're going to
call this a loss function and so we're
going to create a cross entropy loss
function and so before we discuss
exactly what that is let's take a look
and see what we're feeding it
we're going to feed it our labels and we
have our true labels and our prediction
labels so coming in here is where the
two different variables we're sending in
or the two different probability
distributions is one that we know is
true and what we think it's going to be
now this function right here when they
talk about cross entropy
in information theory the cross entropy
between two probability distributions
over the same underlying set of events
measures the average number of bits
needed to identify an event drawn from
the set that's a mouthful uh really
we're just looking at the amount of
error in here how many of these are
correct and how many of these are
incorrect so how much of it matches and
we're going to look at that we're just
going to look at the average that's what
the mean the reduced to the mean means
here so we're looking at the average
error on this
and so the next step is we're going to
take the error we want to know our cross
entropy or our loss function how much
loss we have that's going to be part of
how we train the model so when you know
what the loss is and we're training it
we feed that back into the back
propagation setup and so we want to go
ahead and optimize that here's our
optimizer we're going to create the
optimizer using an atom optimizer
remember there's a lot of different ways
of optimizing the data atoms the most
popular used
so our optimizer is going to equal the
tf train atom optimizer if you don't
remember what the learning rate is let
me just pop this back into here here's
our learning rate when you have your
weights you have all your weights and
your different nodes that are coming out
here's our node coming out
it has all its weights and then the
error is being prop sent back through in
reverse on our neural network so we take
this error we adjust these weights based
on the different formulas in this case
the atom formula is what we're using we
don't want to just adjust them
completely we don't want to change this
weight so it exactly fits the data
coming through because if we made that
kind of adjustment it's going to be
biased to whatever the last data we sent
through is instead we're going to
multiply that by .001 and make a very
small shift in this weight so our delta
w is only 0.001 of the actual delta w of
the full change we're going to compute
from the atom and then we want to go
ahead and train it so our training or
set up a training
variable or function and this is going
to equal our optimizer minimize cross
entropy and we make sure we go ahead and
run this
so it's loaded in there and then we're
almost ready to train our model before
we do that we need to create one more
variable in here and we're going to
create a variable to initialize all the
global tf variables and when we look at
this
the tf global variable initializer this
is a tensorflow
object it goes through there and it
looks at all our different setup that we
have going under our tensorflow and then
initializes those variables
so it's kind of like a magic wand
because it's all hidden in the back end
of tensorflow all you need to know about
this is that you have to have the
initialization on there which is an
operation
and you have to run that once you have
your setup going so we'll go ahead and
run this piece of code and then we're
going to go ahead and train our data so
let me run this let's load it up there
and so now we're going to go ahead and
run the model by creating a graph
session graph session is a tensorflow
term so you'll see that coming up it's
one of the things that throws me because
i always think of graphics and spark and
graph as just general graphing uh but
they talk about a graph session so we're
going to go ahead and run the model and
let's go ahead and walk through this uh
what's going on here and let's paste
this data in here and here we go so
we're going to start off with a with a
tf session as sess so that's our actual
tf session we've created uh so we're
right here with the tf uh
session our session we're creating we're
going to run tf global variable
initializer so right off the bat we're
initializing our variables here and then
we have for i in range 500 so what's
going on here remember 500 we're going
to break the data up and we're going to
batch it in at 500 points each we've
created our session run so we're going
to do with tf session as session
right here we've created our variable
session and then we're going to run
we're going to go ahead and initialize
it so we have our tf global variables
initializer that we created that
initializes our our session in here the
next thing we're going to do is we're
going to go for i in range of 500 batch
equals ch.nextbatch
so if you remember correctly this is
loading up
100 pictures at a time and
this is going to loop through that 500
times so we are literally doing uh what
is that 500 times 100 is
50 000. so that's 50 000 pictures we're
going to process right there and the
first process is we're going to do a
session run we're going to take our
train we created our train variable or
optimizer in there we're going to feed
it the dictionary we had our feed
dictionary that we created and we have x
equals batch 0 coming in y true batch
one hold the probability point five and
then just so that we can keep track of
what's going on we're going to every 100
steps we're going to run a print so
currently on step format
accuracy is
i'm going to look at matches equals
tf.equal tf argument y prediction one t
f dot arg max y true comma one so we're
going to look at this is how many
matches it has and here our acc
all we're doing here is we're going to
take the matches how many matches they
have it creates it generates a chart
we're going to convert that to float
that's what the tfcast does and then we
just want to know the average we just
want to know the average of the accuracy
and then we'll go ahead and print that
out
print session run accuracy feed
dictionary so it takes all this and it
prints out our accuracy on there so
let's go ahead and take this oops
screen's there let's go ahead and take
this and let's run it and this is going
to take a little bit to run
so let's see what happens on my old
laptop and we'll see here that we have
our current uh we're currently on step
0. it takes a little bit to get through
the accuracy and this will take just a
moment to run we can see that on our
step 0 it has an accuracy of 0.1 or
0.1028
and as it's running we'll go ahead you
don't need to watch it run all the way
but this accuracy is going to change a
little bit up and down so we've actually
lost some accuracy during our step two
but we'll see how that comes out let's
come back after we run it all the way
through and see how the different steps
come out he's actually reading that
backwards
the way this works is the closer we get
to one the more accuracy we have so you
can see here we've gone from a point one
to a point three nine um and we'll go
ahead and pause this and come back and
see what happens when we're done with
the full run all right now that we've
prepared the mill got it in the oven and
pulled out my finished dish here if
you've ever watched any of the old
cooking shows let's discuss a little bit
about this accuracy going on here and
how do you interpret that we've done a
couple things first we've defined
accuracy the reason i got it backwards
before is you have
loss or accuracy and with loss you'll
get a graph that looks like this it goes
oops that's an s by the way there we go
you get a graph that curves down like
this and with accuracy you get a graph
that curves up this is how good it's
doing now in this case uh one is
supposed to be really good accuracy that
means it gets close to one but it never
crosses one so if you have an accuracy
of one that is phenomenal in fact that's
pretty much impos you know unheard of
and the same thing with loss if you have
a loss of zero that's also unheard of
the zero's actually on this this axis
right here as we go in there so how do
we interpret that because you know if i
was looking at this and i go oh 0.51
that's uh 51 you're doing 50 50. no this
is not percentage let me just put that
in there it is not percentage uh this is
log rhythmic what that means is that
two is twice as good as point one and uh
when we see point four that's twice as
good as point two real way to convert
this into a percentage you really can't
say this is is a direct percentage
conversion what you can do though is in
your head if we were to give this a
percentage uh we might look at this as
we're just guessing equals 0.1 and if 50
percent roughly equals 0.1 that's we
started up here at the top remember at
the top here here's our 0.1028 the
accuracy of 50
then 75 percent is about 0.2 and so on
and so on don't quote those numbers
because that doesn't work that way they
say that if you have point nine five
that's pretty much saying a hundred
percent and if you have anywhere between
you'd have to go look this up let me go
and remove all my drawings there uh so
the magic number is 0.5 we really want
to be over a 0.5 in this whole thing and
we have
both 0.504 remember this is accuracy if
we were looking at loss then we would be
looking the other way but 0.05 you know
instead of how high it is we want how
low it is uh but with accuracy being
over 0.5 is pretty valid that means this
is pretty solid and if you get to a 0.95
then it's a direct correlation that's
what we're looking for here in these
numbers you can see we finished with
this model at 0.5135
so still good um and if we look at uh
when they ran this in the other end
remember there's a lot of randomness
that goes into it when we see the
weights uh they got
.5251 so a little better than ours but
that's fine you'll find your own comes
up a little bit better or worse
depending on just that randomness and so
we've gone through the whole model we've
created we trained the model and we've
also gone through on every 100th run to
test the model to see how accurate it is
welcome to the rnn tutorial that's the
recurrent neural network do you know how
google's autocomplete feature predicts
the rest of the words a user is typing i
love that autocomplete feature as i'm
typing away saves me a lot of time i can
just kind of hit the enter key and it
auto fills everything and i don't have
to type as much well first there's a
collection of large volumes of most
frequently occurring consecutive words
this is fed into a recurrent neural
network analysis the data by finding the
sequence of words occurring frequently
and builds a model to predict the next
word in the sentence and then google
what is the best food to eat in loss i'm
guessing you're going to say loss mexico
no it's going to be las vegas uh so the
google search will take a look at that
and say hey the most common autocomplete
is going to be vegas in there and
usually it gives you three or four
different choices so it's a very
powerful tool it saves us a lot of time
especially when we're doing a google
search or even in microsoft words has a
some people get very mad at it auto
fills with the wrong stuff but you know
you're typing away and it helps you
autofill i have that in a lot of my
different packages it's just a standard
feature that we're all used to now so
before we dive into the rnn and getting
into the depths let's go ahead and talk
about what is a neural network neural
networks used in deep learning consist
of different layers connected to each
other and work on the structure and
functions of a human brain you're going
to see that thread human in human brain
and human thinking throughout deep
learning the only way we can evaluate an
artificial intelligence or anything like
that is to compare it to human function
very important note on there and it
learns from a huge volumes of data and
it uses complex algorithm to train a
neural net so in here we have image
pixels of two different breeds of dog
one looks like a nice floppy eared lab
and one a german shepherd you know both
wonderful breeds of animals that image
then goes into an input layer uh that
input layer might be formatted at some
point because you have to let it know
like you know different pictures are
going to be different sizes and
different color content then it'll feed
into hidden layers so each of those
pixels or each point of data goes in and
then splits into the hidden layer which
then goes into another hidden layer
which then goes to an output layer r and
n there's some changes in there which
we're going to get into so it's not just
a straightforward propagation of data
like we've covered in many other
tutorials and finally you have an output
layer and the output layer has two
outputs it has one that lights up if
it's a german shepherd and another that
lights up is if it's a labrador so
identify as a dog's breed set networks
do not require memorizing the past
output so our forward propagation is
just that it goes forward and doesn't
have to be memorized stuff and you can
see there that's not actually me in the
picture uh dressed up in my suit
i haven't worn a suit in years so as
we're looking at this we're going to
change it up a little bit before we
cover that let's talk about popular
neural networks first there's the feed
forward neural network used in general
regression and classification problems
and we have the convolution neural
network used for image recognition deep
neural network used for acoustic
modeling deep belief network used for
cancer detection and recurrent neural
network used for speech recognition now
taking a lot of these and mixed them
around a little bit so just because it's
used for one thing doesn't mean it can't
be used for other modeling but generally
this is where the field is and this is
how those models are generally being
used right now so we talk about a feed
forward neural network in a feed forward
neural network information flows only in
the forward direction from the input
nodes through the hidden layers if any
into the output nodes there are no
cycles or loops in the network and so
you can see here we have our input layer
i was talking about how it just goes
straight forward into the hidden layers
so each one of those connects and then
connects to the next hidden layer
connects to the output layer and of
course we have a nice simplified version
where it has a predicted output the
refer to the input is x a lot of times
in the output as y decisions are based
on current input no memory about the
past no future scope why recurrent
neural network issues in feed forward
neural network so one of the biggest
issues is because it doesn't have a
scope of memory or time a feed forward
neural network doesn't know how to
handle sequential data it only considers
only the current input so if you have a
series of things and because three
points back affects what's happening now
and what your output affects what's
happening that's very important so
whatever i put as an output is going to
affect the next one um a feed forward
doesn't look at any of that it just
looks at this is what's coming in and it
cannot memorize previous inputs so it
doesn't have that list of inputs coming
in solution to feed forward neural
network you'll see here where it says
recurrent neural network and we have our
x on the bottom going to h going to y
that's your feed forward but right in
the middle it has a value c so there's a
whole another process was memorizing
what's going on in the hidden layers and
the hidden layers as they produce data
feed into the next one so your hidden
layer might have an output that goes off
to y
but that output goes back into the next
prediction coming in what this does is
this allows it to handle sequential data
it considers the current input and also
the previously received inputs and if
we're going to look at general drawings
and solutions we should also look at
applications of the rnn image captioning
rnn is used to caption an image by
analyzing the activities present in it a
dog catching a ball in midair that's
very tough i mean you know we have a lot
of stuff that analyzes images of a dog
and the image of a ball but it's able to
add one more feature in there that's
actually catching the ball in midair
time series prediction any time series
problem like predicting the prices of
stocks in a particular month can be
solved using rnn and we'll dive into
that in our use case and actually take a
look at some stock one of the things you
should know about analyzing stock today
is that it is very difficult and if
you're analyzing the whole stock the
stock market at the new york stock
exchange in the u.s produces somewhere
in the neighborhood if you count all the
individual trades in fluctuations by the
second um it's like three terabytes a
day of data so we're gonna look at one
stock just analyzing one stock is really
tricky in here we'll give you a little
jump on that so that's exciting but
don't expect to get rich off of it
immediately
another application of the rnn is
natural language processing text mining
and sentiment analysis can be carried
out using rnn for natural language
processing and you can see right here
the term natural language processing
when you stream those three words
together is very different than i if i
said processing language natural leap so
the time series is very important when
we're analyzing sentiments it can change
the whole value of a sentence just by
switching the words around or if you're
just counting the words you might get
one sentiment where if you actually look
at the order they're in you get a
completely different sentiment when it
rains look for rainbows when it's dark
look for stars both of these are
positive sentiments and they're based
upon the order of which the sentence is
going in machine translation given an
input in one language rnn can be used to
translate the input into a different
languages as output i myself very
linguistically challenged but if you
study languages and you're good with
languages you know right away that if
you're speaking english you would say
big cat and if you're speaking spanish
you would say cat big so that
translation is really important to get
the right order to get there's all kinds
of parts of speech that are important to
know by the order of the words here this
person is speaking in english and
getting translated and you can see here
a person is speaking in english in this
little diagram i guess that's denoted by
the flags i have a flag i own it no um
but they're speaking in english and it's
getting translated into
chinese italian french german and
spanish languages some of the tools
coming out are just so cool so somebody
like myself who's very linguistically
challenged i can now travel into worlds
i would never think of because i can
have something translate my english back
and forth readily and i'm not stuck with
a communication gap so let's dive into
what is a recurrent neural network
recurrent neural network works on the
principle of saving the output of a
layer and feeding this back to the input
in order to predict the output of the
layer sounds a little confusing when we
start breaking it down it'll make more
sense and usually we have a propagation
forward neural network with the input
layers the hidden layers the output
layer with the recurrent neural network
we turn that on its side so here it is
and now our x comes up from the bottom
into the hidden layers into y and they
usually draw very simplified x to h with
c as a loop a to y where a b and c are
the perimeters a lot of times you'll see
this kind of drawing in here digging
closer and closer into the h and how it
works going from left to right you'll
see that the c goes in and then the x
goes in so the x is going upward bound
and c is going to the right a is going
out and c is also going out that's where
it gets a little confusing so here we
have x n
c n and then we have y out and c out and
c is based on h t minus one so our value
is based on the y and the h value are
connected to each other they're not
necessarily the same value because h can
be its own thing and usually we draw
this or we represent it as a function h
of t equals a function of c where h of t
minus 1 that's the last h output and x
of t going in so it's the last output of
h combined with the new input of x where
h t is the new state fc is a function
with the parameters c that's a common
way of denoting it h t minus 1 is the
old state coming out and then x of t is
an input vector at time of step t
well we need to cover types of recurrent
neural networks and so the first one is
the most common one which is a
one-to-one single output
one-to-one neural network is usually
known as a vanilla neural network used
for regular machine learning problems
why because vanilla is usually
considered kind of a just a real basic
flavor but because it's very basic a lot
of times they'll call it the vanilla
neural network which is not the common
term but it is like kind of a slang term
people will know what you're talking
about usually if you say that then we
run one to mini so you have a single
input and you might have a multiple
outputs in this case uh image captioning
as we looked at earlier where we have
not just looking at it as a dog but a
dog catching a ball in the air and then
you have mini to one network takes in a
sequence of inputs examples sentiment
analysis where a given sentence can be
classified as expressing positive or
negative sentiments and we looked at
that as we were discussing if it rains
look for a rainbow so positive sentiment
where rain might be a negative sentiment
if you're just adding up the words in
there and then the course if you're
going to do a one-to-one mini to one one
to many there's many to many networks
takes in a sequence of inputs and
generates a sequence of outputs example
machine translation so we have a lengthy
sentence coming in in english and then
going out in all the different languages
you know just a wonderful tool very
complicated set of computations if
you're a translator you realize just how
difficult it is to translate into
different languages
one of the biggest things you need to
understand when we're working with this
neural network is what's called the
vanishing gradient problem while
training an rnn your slope can be either
too small or very large and this makes
training difficult when the slope is too
small the problem is known as vanishing
gradient and you'll see here they have a
nice
image loss of information through time
so if you're pushing not enough
information forward that information is
lost and then when you go to train it
you start losing the third word in the
sentence or something like that or
doesn't quite follow the full logic of
what you're working on exploding
gradient problem oh this is one that
runs into everybody when you're working
with this particular neural network when
the slope tends to grow exponentially
instead of decaying this problem is
called exploding gradient issues in
gradient problem long training time poor
performance bad accuracy and i'll add
one more in there your computer if
you're on a lower end computer testing
out a model will lock up and give you
the memory error explaining gradient
problem consider the following two
examples to understand what should be
the next word in the sequence the person
who took my bike and blank a thief the
students who got into engineering with
blank from asia and you can see in here
we have our x value going in we have the
previous value going forward and then
you back propagate the error like you do
with any neural network and as we're
looking for that missing word maybe
we'll have the person took my bike and
blank was a thief and the student who
got into engineering with a blank were
from asia consider the following example
the person who took the bike so we'll go
back to the person who took the bike was
blank a thief in order to understand
what would be the next word in the
sequence the rnn must memorize the
previous context whether the subject was
singular noun or a plural noun so was a
thief is singular the student who got
into engineering well in order to
understand what would be the next word
in the sequence the rnn must memorize
the previous context whether the subject
was singular noun or a plural noun and
so you can see here the students who got
into engineering with blank were from
asia it might be sometimes difficult for
the air to back propagate to the
beginning of the sequence to predict
what should be the output so when you
run into the gradient problem we need a
solution the solution to the gradient
problem first we're going to look at
exploding gradient where we have three
different solutions depending on what's
going on one is identity initialization
so the first thing we want to do is see
if we can find a way to minimize the
identities coming in instead of having
it identify everything just the
important information we're looking at
next is to truncate the back propagation
so instead of having
whatever information it's sending to the
next series we can truncate what it's
sending we can lower that particular set
of layers make those smaller and finally
is a gradient clipping so when we're
training it we can clip what that
gradient looks like and narrow the
training model that we're using when you
have a vanishing gradient the option
problem we can take a look at weight
initialization very similar to the
identity but we're going to add more
weights in there so it can identify
different aspects of what's coming in
better choosing the right activation
function that's huge so we might be
activating based on one thing and we
need to limit that we haven't talked too
much about activation functions so we'll
look at that just minimally there's a
lot of choices out there and then
finally there's long short term memory
networks the lstms and we can make
adjustments to that so just like we can
clip the gradient as it comes out we can
also
expand on that we can increase the
memory network the size of it so it
handles more information and one of the
most common problems in today's uh setup
is what they call long-term dependencies
suppose we try to predict the last word
in the text the clouds are in the and
you probably said sky here we do not
need any further context it's pretty
clear that the last word is going to be
sky suppose we try to predict the last
word in the text i have been staying in
spain for the last 10 years i can speak
fluent maybe you said portuguese or
french no you probably said spanish the
word we predict will depend on the
previous few words in context here we
need the context of spain to predict the
last word in the text it's possible that
the gap between the relevant information
and the point where it is needed to
become very large
lstms help us solve this problem so the
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning
long-term dependencies remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default behavior all recurrent
neural networks have the form of a chain
of repeating modules of neural network
connections in standard rnns this
repeating module will have a very simple
structure such as a single tangent h
layer lstms's
also have a chain-like structure but the
repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning
long-term dependencies remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default behavior ls tmss also have
a chain-like structure but the repeating
module has a different structure instead
of having a single neural network layer
there are four interacting layers
communicating in a very special way as
you can see the deeper we dig into this
the more complicated the graphs get in
here i want you to note that you have x
of t minus one coming in you have x a t
coming in and you've got x at t plus one
and you have h of t minus one and h of t
coming in and h of t plus one going out
and of course uh on the other side is
the output a
in the middle we have our tangent h but
it occurs in two different places so not
only when we're computing the x of t
plus one or we getting the tangent h
from x to t but we're also getting that
value coming in from the x at t minus
one so the short of it is as you look at
these layers not only does it does the
propagate through the first layer goes
into the second layer back into itself
but it's also going into the third layer
so now we're kind of stacking those up
and this can get very complicated as you
grow that in size it also grows in
memory too and in the amount of
resources it takes but it's a very
powerful tool to help us address the
problem of complicated long-sequential
information coming in like we were just
looking at in the sentence and when
we're looking at our long short term
memory network uh there's three steps of
processing in the lstms that we look at
the first one is we want to forget
irrelevant parts of the previous state
you know a lot of times like you know is
as in a unless we're trying to look at
whether it's a plural noun or not they
don't really play a huge part in the
language so we want to get rid of them
then selectively update cell state
values so we only want to update the
cell state values that reflect what
we're working on and finally we want to
put only output certain parts of the
cell state so whatever is coming out we
want to limit what's going out too and
let's dig a little deeper into this
let's just see what this really looks
like
so step one decides how much of the past
it should remember first step in the
lstm is to decide which information to
be omitted in from the cell in that
particular time step it is decided by
the sigmoid function it looks at the
previous state h to t minus 1 and the
current input x of t and computes the
function so you can see over here we
have a function of t
equals the sigmoid function of the
weight of f the h at t minus 1 and then
x of t plus of course you have a bias in
there with anywhere neural network so we
have a bias function so f of t equals
forget gate decides which information to
delete that is not important from the
previous time step considering an stm is
fed with the following inputs from the
previous and present time step alice is
good in physics john on the other hand
is good in chemistry so previous output
john plays football well he told me
yesterday over the phone that he had
served as a captain of his college
football team that's our current input
so as we look at this the first step is
the forget gate realizes there might be
a change in context after encountering
the first full stop compares with the
current input sentence of x a t so we're
looking at that full stop and then
compares it with the input of the new
sentence the next sentence talks about
john so the information on alice is
deleted okay that's important to know so
we have this input coming in and if
we're going to continue on with john
then that's going to be the primary
information we're looking at the
position of the subject is vacated and
is assigned to john and so in this one
we've seen that we've weeded out a whole
bunch of information and we're only
passing information on john since that's
now the new topic so step two is then to
decide how much should this unit add to
the current state in the second layer
there are two parts one is a sigmoid
function and the other is the tangent h
in the sigmoid function it decides which
values to let through zero or one
tangent h function gives a weightage to
the values which are passed deciding
their level of importance minus one to
one and you can see the two formulas
that come up the i of t equals the
sigmoid of the weight of i h to t minus
one x of t plus the bias of i and the c
of t equals the tangent of h of the
weight of c of h of t minus one x of t
plus the bias of c so our i of t equals
the input gate determines which
information to let through based on its
significance in the current time step if
this seems a little complicated don't
worry because a lot of the programming
is already done when we get to the case
study understanding though that this is
part of the program is important when
you're trying to figure out these what
to set your settings at you should also
note when you're looking at this it
should have some semblance to your
forward propagation neural networks
where we have a value assigned to a
weight plus a bias very important steps
than any of the neural network layers
whether we're propagating into them the
information from one to the next or
we're just doing a straightforward
neural network propagation let's take a
quick look at this what it looks like
from the human standpoint as i step out
of my suit again consider the current
input at x of t john plays football well
he told me yesterday over the phone that
he had served as a captain of his
college football team that's our input
input gate analysis the important
information john plays football and he
was a captain of his college team is
important he told me over the phone
yesterday is less important hence it is
forgotten this process of adding some
new information can be done via the
input gate now this example is as a
human form and we'll look at training
this stuff in just a minute uh but as a
human being if i wanted to get this
information from a conversation maybe
it's a google voice listening in on you
or something like that um how do we weed
out the information that he was talking
to me on the phone yesterday well i
don't want to memorize that he talked to
me on the phone yesterday or maybe that
is important but in this case it's not i
want to know that he was the captain of
the football team i want to know that he
served i want to know that john plays
football and he was a captain of the
college football team those are the two
things that i want to take away as a
human being again we measure a lot of
this from the human viewpoint and that's
also how we try to train them so we can
understand these neural networks finally
we get to step three decides what part
of the current cell state makes it to
the output the third step is to decide
what will be our output first we run a
sigmoid layer which decides what parts
of the cell state make it to the output
then we put the cell state through the
tangent h to push the values to be
between -1 and 1 and multiply it by the
output of the sigmoid gate so when we
talk about the output of t we set that
equal to the sigmoid of the weight of 0
of the h of t minus 1 and back one step
in time by the x of t plus of course the
bias the a t equals the outer t times
the tangent of the tangent h of c of t
so our o t equals the output gate allows
the passed in information to impact the
output in the current time step let's
consider the example to predicting the
next word in the sentence john played
tremendously well against the opponent
and one for his team for his
contributions brave blank was awarded
player of the match there could be a lot
of choices for the empty space current
input brave is an adjective adjectives
describe a noun john could be the best
output after brave thumbs up for john
awarded player of the match and if you
were to pull just the nouns out of the
sentence team doesn't look right because
that's not really the subject we're
talking about contributions you know
brave contributions or brave teen brave
player brave match
so you look at this and you can start to
train this these this neural network so
it starts looking at and goes oh no john
is what we're talking about so brave is
an adjective
john's going to be the best output and
we give john a big thumbs up and then of
course we jump into my favorite part the
case study use case implementation of
lstm let's predict the prices of stocks
using the lstm network based on the
stock price data between 2012 2016.
we're going to try to predict the stock
prices of 2017. and this will be a
narrow set of data we're not going to do
the whole stock market it turns out that
the new york stock exchange generates
roughly three terabytes of data per day
that's all the different trades up and
down of all the different stocks going
on in each individual one
second to second or nanosecond to
nanosecond but we're going to limit that
to just some very basic fundamental
information so don't think you're going
to get rich off this today but at least
you can give an eye you can give a step
forward in how to start processing
something like stock prices a very valid
use for machine learning in today's
markets
use case implementation of lstm
let's dive in we're going to import our
libraries we're going to import the
training set and get the scaling going
now if you watch any of our other
tutorials a lot of these pieces just
start to look very familiar because it's
very similar setup let's take a look at
that and just a reminder we're going to
be using anaconda the jupiter notebook
so here i have my anaconda navigator
when we go under environments i've
actually set up a cross python 36 i'm in
python36 and uh nice thing about
anaconda especially the newer version i
remember a year ago messing with
anaconda in different versions of python
in different environments anaconda now
has a nice interface
and i have this installed both on a
ubuntu linux machine and on windows so
it works fine on there you can go in
here and open a terminal window and then
in here once you're in the terminal
window this is where you're going to
start
installing using pip to install your
different modules and everything now
we've already pre-installed them so we
don't need to do that in here but if you
don't have them installed in your
particular environment you'll need to do
that and of course you don't need to use
the anaconda or the jupiter you can use
whatever favorite python id you like i'm
just a big fan of this because it keeps
all my stuff separate you can see on
this machine i have specifically
installed one for cross since we're
going to be working with cross under
tensorflow we go back to home i've gone
up here to application and that's the
environment i've loaded on here and then
we'll click on the launch jupiter
notebook now i've already in my jupiter
notebook um have set up a lot of stuff
so that we're ready to go kind of like
uh martha stewart's in the old cooking
show so we want to make sure we have all
our tools for you so you're not waiting
for them to load and if we go up here to
where it says new you can see where you
can
create a new python 3. that's what we
did here underneath the setup so it
already has all the modules installed on
it and i'm actually renamed this if you
go under file you can rename it we've
i'm calling it rnn stock and let's just
take a look and start diving into the
code let's get into the exciting part
now we've looked at the tool and of
course you might be using a different
tool which is fine let's start putting
that code in there and seeing what those
imports and uploading everything looks
like now first half is kind of boring
when we hit the run button because we're
going to be importing numpy as np that's
uh the number python which is your numpy
array and the matplot library because
we're going to do some plotting at the
end
and our pandas for our data set our
pandas is pd and when i hit run it
really doesn't do anything except for
load those modules just a quick note let
me just do a quick draw here oops shift
alt there we go you'll notice when we're
doing this setup if i was to divide this
up oops i'm going to actually let's
overlap these here we go
this first part that we're going to do
is
our data
prep
a lot of prepping involved
um in fact depending on what your system
is since we're using cross i put an
overlap here uh but you'll find that
almost
maybe even half of the code we do is all
about the data prep and the reason i
overlapped this with uh cross let me
just put that down because that's what
we're working in uh is because cross has
like their own preset stuff so it's
already pre-built in which is really
nice so there's a couple steps a lot of
times that are in the kara setup we'll
take a look at that to see what comes up
in our code as we go through and look at
stock and the last part is to evaluate
and if you're working with
shareholders or
classroom whatever it is you're working
with uh the evaluate is the next biggest
piece
so the actual code here crossed is a
little bit more but when you're working
with some of the other packages you
might have like three lines that might
be it all your stuff is in your
pre-processing and your data since cross
has is is cutting edge and you load the
individual layers you'll see that
there's a few more lines here and
crosses a little bit more robust and
then you spend a lot of times like i
said with the evaluate you want to have
something you present to everybody else
and say hey this is what i did this is
what it looks like so let's go through
those steps this is like a kind of just
general overview and let's just take a
look and see what the next set of code
looks like and in here we have a dataset
train and it's going to be read using
the pd or pandas.readcsv
and it's a googlestockpricetrain.csv
and so under this we have trainingset
equals datasettrain.ilo
and we've kind of sorted out part of
that so what's going on here let's just
take a look at let's look at the actual
file and see what's going on there now
if we look at this
ignore all the extra files on this i
already have a train and a test set
where it's sorted out this is important
to notice because a lot of times we do
that as part of the pre-processing of
the data we take
20 percent of the data out so we can
test it and then we train the rest of it
that's what we use to create our neural
network that way we can find out how
good it is uh but let's go ahead and
just take a look and see what that looks
like as far as the file itself and i
went ahead and just opened this up in a
basic word pad and text editor just so
we can take a look at it certainly you
can open up an excel or any other kind
of spreadsheet
and we note that this is a comma
separated variables we have a date
open high low close volume this is the
standard stuff that we import into our
stock or the most basic set of
information you can look at in stock
it's all free to download in this case
we downloaded it from google that's why
we call it the google stock price um and
this specifically is google this is the
google stock values from as you can see
here we started off at 1 3 2012. so when
we look at this first setup up here
we have a data set train equals pd
underscore csv and if you noticed on the
original frame
let me just go back there they had it
set to home ubuntu downloads google
stock price train i went ahead and
changed that because we're in the same
file where i'm running the code so i've
saved this particular python code and i
don't need to go through any special
paths or have the full path on there and
then of course we want to take out
certain values in here and you're going
to notice that we're using
our data set
and we're now in pandas
so pandas basically it looks like a
spreadsheet
and in this case we're going to do i
location which is going to get specific
locations the first value is going to
show us that we're pulling all the rows
in the data and the second one is we're
only going to look at columns one and
two and if you remember here from our
data as we switch back on over columns
we so we start with zero which is the
date and we're going to be looking at
open
and high which would be one and two
we'll just label that right there so you
can see now
when you go back and do this you
certainly can extrapolate and do this on
all the columns
but for the example let's just limit a
little bit here so that we can focus on
just some
key aspects of stock
and then we'll go up here and run the
code and again i said the first half is
very boring whenever you hit the run
button it doesn't do anything because
we're still just loading the data and
setting it up
now that we've loaded our data we want
to go ahead and scale it we want to do
what they call feature scaling and in
here we're going to pull it up from the
sk learn or the sk kit pre-processing
import min max scalar and when you look
at this you got to remember that
biases in our data we want to get rid of
that so if you have something that's
like a really high value let's just draw
a quick graph
and i have something here like the maybe
the stock has a value one stock has a
value of a hundred and another stock has
a value of five
um you start to get a bias between
different stocks and so when we do this
we go ahead and say okay 100 is going to
be the max
and 5 is going to be the min
and then everything else goes and then
we change this so we just squish it down
i like the word squish so it's between 1
and zero so 100 equals one or one equals
a hundred and zero equals five and you
can just multiply it's usually just a
simple multiplication we're using uh
multiplication
so it's going to be uh minus five and
then 100 divided or 95 divided by one so
or whatever value is is divided by 95.
and once we've actually created our
scale we're telling is going to be from
zero to one we want to take our training
set and we're going to create a training
set scaled and we're going to use our
scalar sc and we're going to fit we're
going to fit and transform the training
set uh so we can now use the sc this
this particular object will use it later
on our testing set because remember we
have to also scale that when we go to
test our model and see how it works and
we'll go ahead and click on the run
again it's not going to have any output
yet because we're just setting up all
the variables
okay so we paste the data in here and
we're going to create the data structure
with the 60 time steps and output
first note we're running 60 time steps
and that is where this value here also
comes in so the first thing we do is we
create our x train and y train variables
and we set them to an empty python array
very important to remember what kind of
array we're in what we're working with
and then we're going to come in here
we're going to go for i in range 60 to
1258 there's our 60 60 time steps and
the reason we want to do this is as
we're adding the data in there there's
nothing below the 60. so if we're going
to use 60 time steps we have to start at
point 60 because it includes everything
underneath of it otherwise you'll get a
pointer error and then we're going to
take our x train and we're going to
append training set scaled this is a
scaled value between 0 and 1. and then
as i is equal to 60 this value is going
to be
60 minus 60 is 0. so this actually is 0
to i so it's going to be 0 60 1 to 61.
let me just circle this part right here
1 to 61 2 to 62 and so on and so on and
if you remember i said 0 to 60 that's
incorrect because it does not count
remember it starts at 0 so this is a
count of 60. so it's actually 59.
important to remember that as we're
looking at this and then the second part
of this that we're looking at so if you
remember correctly here we go we go from
0 to 59 of i and then we have a comma a
0 right here and so finally we're just
going to look at the open value now i
know we did put it in there for one to
two
if you move correctly it doesn't count
the second one so it's just the open
value we're looking at just open
um and then finally we have y train dot
append training set i to zero and if you
remember correctly i two or i comma zero
if you remember correctly this is 0 to
59 so there's 60 values in it so we do i
down here this is number 60. so we're
going to do this is we're creating an
array and we have 0
to
59 and over here we have number 60 which
is going into the y train it's being
appended on there and then this just
goes all the way up so this is down here
is a
0 to 59 and we'll call it 60 since
that's the value over here and it goes
all the way up to 12
58. that's where this value here comes
in that's the length of the data we're
loading
so we've loaded two arrays we've loaded
one array that has uh which is filled
with arrays from zero to 59 and we
loaded one array which is just the value
and what we're looking at you want to
think about this as a time sequence uh
here's my open open open openopenopen
what's the next one in the series so
we're looking at the google stock and
each time it opens we want to know what
the next one uh 0 through 59 what's 60 1
through 60 what's 61 2 through 62 what's
62 and so on and so on going up and then
once we've loaded those in our for loop
we go ahead and take x train and y train
equals
np.arrayxtrain.npraytrain we're just
converting this back into a numpy array
that way we can use all the cool tools
that we get with numpy array including
reshaping so if we take a look and see
what's going on here we're going to take
our x train
we're going to reshape it
wow what the heck does reshape mean
that means we have an array if you
remember correctly so many numbers by
60.
that's how wide it is
and so we're when you when you do x
train dot shape that gets one of the
shapes and you get
x train dot shape of one gets the other
shape and we're just making sure the
data is formatted correctly and so you
use this to pull the fact that it's 60
by
in this case where's that value
60 by 1199
1258 minus 60 11.99 and we're making
sure that that is shaped correctly so
the data is grouped into
11 99 by 60 different arrays and then
the one on the end just means at the end
because this when you're dealing with
shapes and numpy they look at this as
layers and so the in layer needs to be
one value that's like the leaf of a tree
where this is the branch and then it
branches out some more um and then you
get the leaf np dot reshape comes from
and using the existing shapes to form it
we'll go ahead and run this piece of
code again there's no real output and
then we'll import our different cross
modules that we need so from cross
models we're going to import the
sequential model dealing with sequential
data we have our dense layers we have
actually three layers we're going to
bring in our dents our lstm which is
what we're focusing on and our dropout
and we'll discuss these three layers
more in just a moment but you do need
the with the lstm you do need the
dropout and then the final layer will be
the dents but let's go ahead and run
this and that'll bring port our modules
and you'll see we get an error on here
and if you read it closer it's not
actually an error it's a warning what
does this warning mean these things come
up all the time when you're working with
such cutting edge modules are completely
being updated all the time we're not
going to worry too much about the
warning all it's saying is that the
h5py module which is part of cross is
going to be updated at some point and if
you're running new stuff on cross and
you start updating your cross system you
better make sure that your h5 pi is
updated too otherwise you're going to
have an error later on and you can
actually just run an update on the h5 pi
now if you wanted to not a big deal
we're not going to worry about that
today and i said we were going to jump
in and start looking at what those
layers mean i meant that and we're going
to start off with initializing the rnn
and then we'll start adding those layers
in and you'll see that we have the lstm
and then the dropout lstm then dropout
lstm then dropout what the heck is that
doing so let's explore that we'll start
by initializing the rnn regressor equals
sequential because we're using the
sequential model and we'll run that and
load that up and then we're going to
start adding our lstm layer and some
dropout regularization and right there
should be the q dropout regularization
and if we go back here and remember our
exploding gradient well that's what
we're talking about the dropout drops
out unnecessary data so we're not just
shifting huge amounts of data through
the network so and so we go in here
let's just go ahead and add this in i'll
go ahead and run this and we had three
of them so let me go ahead and put all
three of them in and then we can go back
over them there's the second one and
let's put one more in let's put that in
and we'll go ahead and put two more in i
mean i said one more in but it's
actually two more in and then let's add
one more after that and as you can see
each time i run these they don't
actually have an output so let's take a
closer look and see what's going on here
so we're going to add our first lstm
layer in here we're going to have units
50. the units is the positive integer
and it's the dimensionality of the
output space this is what's going out
into the next layer so we might have 60
coming in but we have 50 going out we
have a return sequence because it is a
sequence data so we want to keep that
true and then you have to tell it what
shape it's in well we already know the
shape by just going in here and looking
at x train shape so input shape equals
the x train shape of one comma one makes
it real easy you don't have to remember
all the numbers and put in 60 or
whatever else is in there you just let
it tell the regressor what model to use
and so we follow our stm with a dropout
layer now understanding the dropout
layer is kind of exciting because one of
the things that happens is we can over
train our network that means that our
neural network will memorize such
specific data that it has trouble
predicting anything that's not in that
specific realm to fix for that each time
we run through the training mode we're
going to take 0.2 or 20 percent of our
neurons and just turn them off so we're
only going to train on the other ones
and it's going to be random that way
each time we pass through this we don't
over train these nodes come back in in
the next training cycle we randomly pick
a different 20. and finally i see a big
difference as we go from the first to
the second and third and fourth the
first thing is we don't have to input
the shape because the shapes already the
output units is 50 here this item the
next step automatically knows this layer
is putting out 50 and because it's the
next layer it automatically sets that
and says oh 50 is coming out from our
last layer that's coming up you know
goes into the regressor and of course we
have our dropout and that's what's
coming into this one and so on and so on
and so the next three layers we don't
have to let it know what the shape is it
automatically understands that and we're
going to keep the units the same we're
still going to do 50 units it's still a
sequence coming through 50 units and a
sequence now the next piece of code is
what brings it all together let's go
ahead and take a look at that and we
come in here we put the output layer the
dense layer and if you remember up here
we had the three layers we had uh lstm
dropout and dents dens just says we're
going to bring this all down into one
output instead of putting out a sequence
we just know i want to know the answer
at this point and let's go ahead and run
that and so in here you notice all we're
doing is setting things up one step at a
time so far we've brought in our way up
here we brought in our data we brought
in our different modules we formatted
the data for training it we set it up
you know we have our y x train and our y
train we have our source of data and the
answers where we know so far that we're
going to put in there we've reshaped
that we've come in and built our cross
we've imported our different layers and
we have in here if you look we have what
uh five total layers now cross is a
little different than a lot of other
systems there's a lot of other systems
put this all in one line and do it
automatic but they don't give you the
options of how those layers interface
and they don't give you the options of
how the data comes in karass is cutting
edge for this reason so even though it's
a lot of extra steps in building the
model this has a huge impact on the
output and what we can do with this
these new models from cross so we
brought in our dense we have our full
model put together a regressor so we
need to go ahead and compile it and then
we're going to go ahead and fit the data
we're going to compile the pieces so
they all come together and then we're
going to run our training data on there
and actually recreate our regressor so
it's ready to be used so let's go ahead
and compile that and i'll go ahead and
run that and if you've been looking at
any of our other tutorials on neural
networks you'll see we're going to use
the optimizer atom atom is optimized for
big data there's a couple other
optimizers out there beyond the scope of
this tutorial but certainly atom will
work pretty good for this and loss
equals mean squared value so when we're
training it this is what we want to base
the loss on how bad is our error we're
going to use the mean squared value for
our error and the atom optimizer for its
differential equations you don't have to
know the math behind them but certainly
it helps to know what they're doing and
where they fit into the bigger models
and then finally we're going to do our
fit fitting the rnn to the training set
we have the regressor.fit x train y
train epics and batch size so we know
where this is this is our data coming in
for the x train our y train is the
answer we're looking for of our data our
sequential input epics is how many times
we're going to go over the whole data
set we created a whole data set of x
trains so this is each each of those
rows which includes a time sequence of
60. and bad size another one of those
things where cross really shines is if
you were pulling the save from a large
file instead of trying to load it all
into ram it can now pick smaller batches
up and load those indirectly we're not
worried about pulling them off a file
today because this isn't big enough to
cause a computer too much of a problem
to run not too straining on the
resources but as we run this you can
imagine what happened if i was doing a
lot more than just one column in one set
of stock in this case google stock
imagine if i was doing this across all
the stocks and i had instead of just the
open i had open close high low and you
can actually find yourself with about 13
different variables times 60 because
there's a time sequence suddenly you
find yourself with a gig of memory
you're loading into your ram which will
just completely you know if it's just if
you're not on multiple computers or
cluster you can start running into
resource problems but for this we don't
have to worry about that so let's go
ahead and run this and this will
actually take a little bit on my
computer because it's an older laptop
and give a second to kick in there there
we go all right so we have epic so this
is going to tell me it's running the
first run through all the data and as
it's going through it's batching them in
32 pieces so 32 lines each time and
there's 1198 i think i said 11.99
earlier but it's 1198 is off by one and
each one of these is 13 seconds so you
can imagine this is roughly 20 to 30
minutes run time on this computer like i
said it's an older laptop running at 0.9
gigahertz on a dual processor and that's
fine what we'll do is i'll go ahead and
stop go get a drink of coffee and come
back and let's see what happens at the
end and where this takes us and like any
good cooking show
i've kind of gotten my latte i also have
some other stuff running in the
background so you'll see these numbers
jumped up to like 19 seconds 15 seconds
but you scroll through and you can see
we've run it through 100 steps or 100
epics so the question is what does all
this mean one of the first things you'll
notice is that our loss can is over here
it kind of stopped at 0.0014 but you can
see it kind of goes down until we hit
about 0.014 three times in a row so we
guessed our epic pretty close since our
losses remain the same on there so to
find out what we're looking at we're
going to go ahead and load up our test
data the test data that we didn't
process yet and a real stock price data
set test eye location this is the same
thing we did when we prepped the data in
the first place so let's go ahead and go
through this code and we can see we've
labeled it part three making the
predictions and visualizing the results
so the first thing that we need to do is
go ahead and read the data in from our
test csv you see i've changed the path
on it for my computer and then we'll
call it the real stock price and again
we're doing just the one column here and
the values from i location so it's all
the rows and just the values from these
that one location that's the open stock
open let's go ahead and run that so
that's loaded in there and then let's go
ahead and create we have our inputs
we're going to create inputs here and
this should all look familiar because
this is the same thing we did before
we're going to take our data set total
we're going to do a little panda concat
from the datastate train now remember
the end of the data set train is part of
the data going in let's just visualize
that just a little bit here's our train
data let me just put tr for train and it
went up to this value here but each one
of these values generated a bunch of
columns it was 60 across and this value
here equals this one and this value here
equals this one and this value here
equals this one and so we need these top
60 to go into our new data so to find
out we're looking at we're going to go
ahead and load up our test data the test
data that we didn't process yet and a
real stock price data set test eye
location this is the same thing we did
when we prep the data in the first place
so let's go ahead and go through this
code and we can see we've labeled it uh
part three making the predictions and
visualizing the results so the first
thing we need to do is go ahead and read
the data in from our test csv you see
i've changed the path on it for my
computer and then we'll call it the real
stock price and again we're doing just
the one column here and the values from
i location so it's all the rows and just
the values from these that one location
that's the open stock open let's go
ahead and run that so that's loaded in
there and then let's go ahead and create
we have our inputs we're going to create
inputs here and this all look familiar
this is the same thing we did before
we're going to take our data set total
we're going to do a little panda concat
from the datastate train now remember
the end of the data set train is part of
the data going in let's just visualize
that just a little bit here's our train
data let me just put tr for train and it
went up to this value here but each one
of these values generated a bunch of
columns it was 60 across and this value
here equals this one and this value here
equals this one and this value here
equals this one and so we need these top
60 to go into our new data because
that's part of the next data or it's
actually the top 59. so that's what this
first setup is over here is we're going
in we're doing the real stock price and
we're going to just take the data set
test and we're going to load that in and
then the real stock price is our data
test test location so we're just looking
at that first column the open price and
then our data set total we're going to
take pandas and we're going to concat
and we're going to take our data set
train for the open and our dataset test
open and this is one way you can
reference these columns we've referenced
them a couple different ways we've
referenced them up here with the one two
but we know it's labeled as a panda set
as open so pandas is great that way lots
of versatility there and we'll go ahead
and go back up here and run this there
we go and you'll notice this is the same
as what we did before we have our open
data set where pended our two different
or concatenated our two data sets
together we have our inputs equals data
set total length data set total minus
length data set minus test minus 60
values so we're going to run this over
all of them and you'll see why this
works because normally when you're
running your test set versus your
training set you run them completely
separate but when we graph this you'll
see that we're just going to be we'll be
looking at the part that we didn't train
it with to see how well it graphs and we
have our inputs equals inputs dot
reshapes or reshaping like we did before
we're transforming our inputs so if you
remember from the transform between zero
and one and uh finally we want to go
ahead and take our x test and we're
going to create that x test and for i in
range 60 to 80. so here's our x test and
we're appending our inputs i to 60 which
remember is 0 to 59 and i comma 0 on the
other side so it's just the first column
which is our open column and once again
we take our x test we convert it to a
numpy array we do the same reshape we
did before and then we get down to the
final two lines and here we have
something new right here on these last
two lines let me just highlight those or
or mark them predicted stock price
equals regressor dot predicts x test so
we're predicting all the stock including
both the training and the testing model
here and then we want to take this
prediction and we want to inverse the
transform so remember we put them
between zero and one well that's not
going to mean very much to me to look at
a float number between zero and one i
want the dollar amount so i want to know
what the cash value is and we'll go
ahead and run this and you'll see it
runs much quicker than the training
that's what's so wonderful about these
neural networks once you put them
together it takes just a second to run
the same neural network that took us
what a half hour to train add and plot
the data we're going to plot what we
think it's going to be and we're going
to plot it against the real data what
the google stock actually did so let's
go ahead and take a look at that in code
and let's uh pull this code up so we
have our plt that's our oh if you
remember from the very beginning let me
just go back up to the top we have our
matplotlibrary.piplot as plt that's
where that comes in and we come down
here we're going to plot let me get my
drawing thing out again we're going to
go ahead and plt is basically kind of
like an object it's one of the things
that always through me when i'm doing
graphs in python because i always think
you have to create an object and then it
loads that class in there well in this
case plt is like a canvas you're putting
stuff on so if you've done html5 you'll
have the canvas object this is the
canvas so we're going to plot the real
stock price that's what it actually is
and we're going to give that color red
so it's going to be in bright red we're
going to label it real google stock
price and then we're going to do our
predicted stock and we're going to do it
in blue and it's going to be labeled
predicted and we'll give it a title
because it's always nice to give a title
to your graph especially if you're going
to present this to somebody you know to
your shareholders in the office and uh
the x label is going to be time because
it's a time series and we didn't
actually put the actual date and times
on here but that's fine we just know
they're incremented by time and then of
course the y label is the actual stock
price plt.legend tells us to build the
legend on here so that the color red in
real google stock price show up on there
and then the plot shows us that actual
graph so let's go ahead and run this and
see what that looks like and you can see
here we have a nice graph and let's talk
just a little bit about this graph
before we wrap it up here's our legend i
was telling you about that's why we have
the legend to show the prices we have
our title and everything and you'll
notice on the bottom we have a time
sequence we didn't put the actual time
in here now we could have we could have
gone ahead and
plotted the x since we know what the
dates are and plotted this to dates but
we also know that it's only the last
piece of data that we're looking at so
last piece of data which in somewhere
probably around here on the graph i
think it's like about 20 of the data
probably less than that we have the
google price and the google price has
this little up jump and then down and
you'll see that the actual google
instead of a turn down here just didn't
go up as high and didn't load go down so
our prediction has the same pattern but
the overall value is pretty far off as
far as
stock but then again we're only looking
at one column we're only looking at the
open price we're not looking at how many
volumes were traded like i was pointing
out earlier we talk about stock just
right off the bat there's six columns
there's open high low close volume then
there's weather i mean volume shares
then there's the adjusted open adjusted
high adjusted low adjusted close they
have a special formula to predict
exactly what it would really be worth
based on the value of the stock and then
from there there's all kinds of other
stuff you can put in here so we're only
looking at one small aspect the opening
price of the stock and as you can see
here we did a pretty good job this curve
follows the curve pretty well it has
like a little jumps on it bins they
don't quite match up so this bin here
does not quite match up with that bin
there but it's pretty darn close we have
the basic shape of it and the prediction
isn't too far off and you can imagine
that as we add more data in and look at
different aspects in the specific domain
of stock we should be able to get a
better representation each time we drill
in deeper of course this took a half
hour for my program my computer to train
so you can imagine that if i was running
it across all those different variables
it might take a little bit longer to
train the data in today's exciting world
of ai artificial intelligence we're
going to cover some of the many uses
it's being applied to healthcare
entertainment composing music image
coloring robotics image captioning
advertising earthquake prediction and
there's many more it's just an exciting
time to be in the field of ai and deep
learning and artificial intelligence now
all these fields are just booming it's
just amazing what's going on so let's
take a quick glance at some of the
things going on and we'll start with our
health care we take a look at health
care deep learning is reshaping
healthcare industry by delivering new
possibilities to improve people's lives
and we have computer-aided disease
detection i know a number of startups
have come up where they're working on
you take a picture like if you have some
kind of irritation or rash and they use
that or even you know some infection in
the eye and they use the deep learning
to help identify what it is hey this is
um 99.99
nothing don't worry about it or this is
93 chance um it usually doesn't come out
93 chance if you do deep learning but it
says hey you know you should probably
take this into the doctor you know have
them take a look at it and see what it
is these are the things it could be
analyzing genomes that's a big one very
controversial nowadays with all the
different genome editing and options
they have and things they're doing but
deep learning is definitely diving into
the genome projects we have discovering
new drugs and this there's so many
directions for new drugs going on it's
like one of the booming industries
especially in the us but all across the
world and they range from
exploring different plants and the
opening up of let's say marijuana in the
u.s a number of cities are exploring
that for medical use to how do you
reprogram t cells in the human body to
combat disease there's whole industries
in data analysis another one is
chemistry how do you use a chemical cell
or a chemistry molecule not cell a
chemical molecule to imitate the t cell
so you can then put those molecules in
there and then they grab the diseased
cells out or the cancer cells or
whatever out just like the human body
would so discovering new drugs and how
to apply that is just a huge industry
all these are huge industries and
medical imaging we'll even take a glance
closer at that but being able to analyze
you know you get your mri you get your
cat scans the doctors can spend a long
time looking at those and taking careful
measurements and most of that's done by
hand but as we start applying deep
learning the deep learning can do a lot
of that work not only do it the same but
it'll be uniform from one hospital to
the next meaning that as a industry it
continues to progress and you get better
results and better services so deep
learning is reshaping healthcare
industry by delivering new possibilities
to improve people's life and deep
learning helps in early detection of
cancer cells and tumors improves a
time-consuming process of synthesizing
new drugs and inverse sophisticated
medical instruments and not even
sophisticated they're using iphones and
deep learning to help with medical
diagnosis so it's at all levels it's
just amazing what they're doing in the
healthcare industry with deep learning
and they've just barely tapped what
there's possible they're just now
evolving into the beginning of this
where it's exploding out there so
entertainment that's always a fun one a
lot of people go into the entertainment
and deep learning because it's just fun
you know what's my favorite movie um all
that fun stuff deep learning is used in
the entertainment industry such as
netflix amazon and filmmaking and you
have like your recommendations that's
probably the most common one you see and
you can see here where they have uh
india transform the true story the third
pillar now markets in the state leave so
it comes up and says hey this is based
on whoever and of course this is showing
up on amazon or amazon prime netflix
does a good job of grouping movies for
you and says since you like these movies
you might like these movies over here
same thing with vivo it does that also
amazon netflix and vivo use recommender
systems to provide personalized
experience to its viewers using their
show preferences time of access history
etc so really this is one of the cool
things is instead of having to dig for
the information deep learning starts
doing that for you so instead of
spending hours trying to figure out what
you want to watch you can actually just
enjoy the movies and have them come up
deep learning is used in the
entertainment industry such as netflix
amazon and filmmaking continue on in
deep learning we have things like the
ibm watson this is just really cool i
didn't know this until i read this until
we did this slide wimbledon 2018 used
ibm watson to analyze player emotions
and expressions through hundreds of
hours of footage then it auto generated
highlights for the telecast so you can
imagine somebody sitting there looking
through all the boring stuff i want to
look at the interesting stuff it helps
us sort that out again you know just
like the netflix and referral it helps
you find your choices without having to
do all the heavy work of digging through
really bad b rated movies and music and
audio generation another huge part of
the industry and this kind of blends
right in with video and movie making
voice and audio recognition technology
can be used to train deep learning
network to produce music compositions so
it learns the patterns and generates new
music google's wavenet and beidou's deep
speech can train a computer to learn the
patterns and the statistics that are
unique to the music it can then generate
a complete new composition that's a
little scary i always thought that
creativity would always be the human
factor that we'd always have our
creativity but you know computers can do
some of that too and then we have our
reed's lip movements um oxford and
google scientists created a neural
network called lipnet that could read
people's lips with 93 success this can
be used to add sounds to silent movies i
like that it'd be fun to hear what they
actually were saying back there they
probably said something totally
different than what's actually on the
movie that'd be pretty funny on the
scary note this would allow surveillance
equipment to pull what people are saying
even if they're really far away as long
as they can see the lips that's a little
scary coloring images and videos deep
learning can be used to color images and
videos by taking the objects in their
context within the photograph so you
have your black and white images fed in
and you have a convolutional neural
network is used to learn the patterns
and usually you train it you train it
with hundreds of black and white photos
that you already have the color image
for so you know what to expect and they
take the new one and it recreates the
image by adding the colors and this is
also used in the movie industry to add
in special effects
there's all kinds of cool things they
can do with this it goes way beyond just
coloring pictures of course the coloring
pictures is something that you can
probably do in your own lab on your own
computer and build your own neural
network to do that robotics one of my
favorites robotics all these tools that
make them so exciting is that you can go
out and even now it used to be you'd
have to spend four five six ten thousand
us dollars to buy your own robot and
then start programming it and doing
neural networks now it's around two
thousand dollars and that continues to
plummet uh there's even kid robots much
cheaper robotic hands all of that that
you can purchase and generate your own
neural network and start trying to
figure out how to get it to do things
and so we talk about deep learning it's
heavily used these days in building
robots to perform human-like tasks
robots are built to understand the world
around them very important how to figure
out what's what i remember if you go
back 20 years they could not get a robot
to figure out the difference between a
coke can and a pencil because they're
both cylinders and he just they just had
no idea how to do that back then you
know they did the beginning of robotics
really the neural networks was mid-90s
where it started really taking off and
the theory started coming in and so you
go back to that time and figuring out
those differences was almost impossible
before then and they trained to make
better and safer decisions without
supervision and you can see in this case
you know in outer space having a robot
up there uh you know if the window blows
out air pressure's lost the robot is you
know not going to be hurt by it because
they don't need air and oxygen and their
decisions usually instead of being like
a human's tired in this case the robot
never is tired so you know there's
definitely a lot of tasks for a robot
that can be used to replace humans would
be safer think uh nuclear reactors that
melted down after the tsunami in japan
using robotics to go in there and clean
up would be really important instead of
putting a person in a hazmat suit that
might or might not protect him from the
radiation in boston dynamics we have
spot mini he's fun to watch if we pull
up the video or the atlas robots by
boston dynamics react to people pushing
them around get up when they fall can
unload a dishwasher and do other tasks
as well so we're starting to see this
kind of robotics coming into the house
the atlas obviously is a very expensive
robot but there is certainly more common
ones you can actually bring into the
house and then spot mini is fun to watch
run you can i forget how fast he goes
but he goes pretty fast image caption
generation another part of the industry
in deep learning deep learning is used
to display the contents of an image i
love this with my google photos the
system is trained with very large
convolutional neural networks for
detecting objects in the photographs and
then a recurring neural network like an
lstm is used to turn the labels into
coherent sentence dog catching a ball so
this is awesome this is like you go into
your google photos and you say hey i
want all the pictures of my dog or i
want all the pictures of
kids or whatever it is and they get to
the point where you can now do i want
pictures where my dog is catching the
ball advertising one of the better paid
fields in ai is in marketing and
advertising especially if you are
working on bonuses and commissions so
advertising and advertising deep
learning allows optimizing a user's
experience so deep learning helps
publishers and advertisers to increase
the relevancy of the ads and boost the
advertising campaigns allows the network
to reduce costs by dropping the cost per
acquisition of a campaign from sixty to
thirty dollars create data-driven
predictive advertising real-time bidding
of their ads and target display
advertising and again this goes uh from
experimental where i'm just going to
guess what people want and we'll put out
a pink sign that says
you want to add on widget to your order
well nobody wants widgets and nobody
wants to see the pink sign maybe you got
three people want to see the pink sign
and you find out that the blue sign a
lot of people are reading that and they
really want a widget number two whatever
that is uh so when you talk about
advertising it also deals with marketing
and also uh preference of merchandise so
it becomes really huge as far as what
you're advertising and generating profit
and sales for a company and that's
across the board whether you're talking
big real estate or
property management and rentals or
amazon uses this for all their
merchandise coming out of their
warehouses any of those are generated
from the ai generates more sales and
that's the bottom dollar business is
always looking at the bottom dollar
where can i make money on this
earthquake prediction so now we're
getting to something safety human safety
you can also think weather predictions
all those fun things deep learning model
can be used to predict earthquakes by
considering a factor called von mice's
yield criterion scientists at harvard
use deep learning to teach a computer
perform viscoelastic computations that
is quite the mouthful which are used in
prediction of earthquakes this
application helped to improve the
earthquake calculation by 50 000 percent
that's amazing we went from just
guessing when an earthquake is going to
happen where we have almost no
reliability to being able to have a
decent gas as when the earthquakes are
going to hit today we're going to help
you prepare for interview questions
dealing with deep learning and we're
going to go from the very basics of
neural networks and deep learning into
some of the more commonly used models so
you can have understanding of what kind
of questions are going to come up and
what you need to know in interview
questions we'll start with a very
general concept of what is deep learning
this is where we take large volumes of
data in this case on cats and dogs or
whatever a lot of times you use
a training setup to train your model
remember it's kind of like a magic black
box going on there then we use that to
extract features or extract information
and in this case classify the image of a
cat and a dog so the primary takeaway
we're talking about deep learning is it
learns from large volumes of structured
and even unstructured data and uses
complex algorithms to train neural
network it also performs complex
operations to extract hidden patterns
and features and if we're going to
discuss deep learning in this very
simplified overview and we also have to
go over what is a neural network this is
a common image you'll see of a drawing
of a forward propagation neural network
and it's it's a human brain inspired
system which replicates the way humans
learn so this is inspired how our own
neurons in our brain fire but at a much
simplified level obviously it's not
ready to take over the human uh
population and be our leader yet not for
many years it's very much in its infant
stage but it's inspired by how our
brains work and they use a lot of other
inspirations you can study brains of
moths and other animals that they've
used to figure out how to improve these
neural networks the most common one
consists of three layers of network and
this is generally how you view these
networks is you have an input you have a
hidden layer and an output and the
neural network is uh broken up into many
pieces but we focus just on the neural
network it's always on the hidden layers
that we're making all the adjustments
and figuring out how to best set up
those hidden layers for their functions
to both train faster and to function
better when we look at this of course we
have our input hidden and output each
layer contains neurons called as nodes
perform various operations and you can
see here we have the list of the nodes
we have both our input nodes and our
output nodes
let's start with what is a multi-layer
perceptron or mlp a lot of time is
referred to and you'll see these
abbreviations i'll be honest i have to
write them down on a piece of paper and
go through them because i never remember
what they all mean even though i play
with them all the time what is a
multi-layer perceptron well if you look
at the image on the right it's very
similar to what we just looked at you
have your input layer your hidden layer
and your output layer and that's exactly
what this is it has the same structure
of a single layer perceptron with one or
more hidden layers except the input
layer each node in the other layers uses
a non-linear activation function what
that means is your input layer is your
data coming in and then your activation
function is based upon all those nodes
and weights being added together and
then it has the output mlp uses
supervised learning method called back
propagation for training the model very
key word there is back propagation
single layer perceptron can classify
only linear separable classes with
binary output 0 1 but the mlp can
classify non-linear classes so let's
break this down just a little bit the
multi-layer perceptron with an input
layer and a hidden layer and an output
layer as you see that it comes in there
it has adds up all the numbers and
weights depending on how your setup is
that then goes to the next layer that
then goes to the next hidden layer if
you have multiple hidden layers and
finally to the output layer the back
propagation takes the error that it sees
so whatever the output is it says hey
this has an error to it it's wrong and
it sends that error backwards from where
it came from and there's a lot of
different functions used to
train this based on that error and how
that error goes backwards in the notes
so forward is you get your answers
backward is for training you see this
every day even my uh google pixel phone
has this it they train the neural
network which takes a lot more data to
train than it does to use and then they
load up that neural network into in this
case i have a pixel 2 which actually has
a built-in neural network for processing
pictures and so it's just the forward
propagation i use when it processes my
photos but when they were training it it
used the back propagation to train it
with the errors they had we'll be coming
back to different models that are used
for right now though multi-layer
perceptron mlp but that dumb is your
vocabulary word and of course back
propagation what is data normalization
and why do we need it this is so
important we spend so much time in
normalizing our data and getting our
data clean and setting it up so we talk
about data there's a pre-processing step
to standardize the data so whatever we
have coming in we don't want it to be a
uh you know one gigabyte file here a two
gigabyte picture here and a three
kilobyte text there even as a human i
can't process those all in the same
group i have to reformat them in some
way that loops them together so the
standardized format we use this
data normalization in pre-processing to
reduce it and eliminate data redundancy
a lot of times the data comes in and you
end up with two of the same images or
the same information in different
formats then we want to rescale values
to fit into a particular range for
achieving better convergence what this
means is with most neural networks they
form a bias we've seen this in recently
in attacks on neural networks where they
light up one pixel or one piece of the
view and it skews the whole answer so
suddenly
because one pixel is really bright it
doesn't know what to do but when we
start rescaling it we put all the values
between say minus one and 1 and we
change them and refit them to those
values it helps get rid of that bias
helps fix for some of those problems and
then finally we restructure the data and
improve the integrity we want to make
sure that we're not missing values or we
don't have partial data coming in one
way to look at this is
bad data in bad data out
so you want clean data in and you want
good answers coming out one of the most
basic models used is a boltzmann machine
so let's address what is a boltzmann
machine and if you know we just did the
mlp multi-layer perceptron so now we're
going to come into almost a simplified
version of that and in this we have our
visible input layer and we have our
hidden layer the boltzmann machines are
almost always shallow they're usually
just two layer neural nets that make
stochastic decisions whether a neuron
should be on or off true false yes no
first layer is a visible layer and
second layer is the hidden layer nodes
are connected to each other across
layers but no two nodes of the same
layer are connected hence it is also
known as restricted boltzmann machine
now that we've covered a basic mlp or
multi-layer perceptron and we've gone
over the boltzmann machine also known as
the restricted boltzmann machine let's
talk a little bit about activation
formulas and this is a huge topic that
can get really complicated but it also
is automated so it's very simple so you
have both a complicated and a simple at
the same time so what is the role of
activation functions in a neural network
activation function decides whether a
neuron should be fired or not that's the
most basic one and that actually changes
a little bit because it's either whether
fired or not in this case activation
function or what value should come out
when it's fired but in these models
we're looking at just the boltzmann
restricted layers so this is what causes
them to fire either they don't or they
do it's a yes or no true false all or
nothing it accepts a weighted sum of the
inputs the bias as input to any
activation function so whatever
activation function is it needs to have
the sum of the weights times the input
so each input if you remember on that
model and let's just go back to that
model real quick and then you always
have to add a bias and you can look at
the bias if you remember from your
euclidean geometry you draw a straight
line formula for that line has a
y-coordinate at the end it's always
cx plus m or something like that where m
is where it crosses the y coordinates if
you're doing a straight line with these
weights it's very similar but a lot of
times we just add it in as its own
weight we take it as a node of a one
value coming in and then we compute its
new weight and that's how we compute
that bias just like we compute all the
other weights coming in the node which
gets fires depends on the y value and
then we have a step function and the
step function this is where remember i
said is going to get complicated and
simple all at the same time we have a
lot of different step functions we have
the sigmoid function we have just the
standard step function we have the relu
it's pronounced like ray the ray from
the sun and liu like a name so relu
function and we have the tangent h
function and if you look at these they
all have something similar they all
either force it to be
one value or the other they force it to
be in the case of the first three a zero
or one and in the last one it's either a
minus one or a one and you can easily
convert that to a zero one yes no true
false and on this one of the most common
ones is the step function itself because
there is no middle value there is no
discrepancy that says well i'm not quite
sure but as you get into different
models probably the most commonly used
used to be the sigmoid was most commonly
used but i see the relu used more often
really depending on what you're doing
you just have to play with these and
find out which one works best
depending on the data and your output
the reason to have a non-zero one answer
or something kind of in the middle is
when you're looking at this and it's
coming out you can actually process that
middle ground as part of the answer into
another neural network so it might be
that the rayleigh function says hey this
is only a 0.6 not a 1. and even though
the 1 is what's going into the next
neural network or the next hidden layer
as an input the 0.6 value might also be
going in there to let you know hey this
is not a straight up one or straight up
zero is someplace in the middle this is
a little uncertain what's coming out
here so it's a very powerful tool but
the basic neural network you usually
just use the step function it's yes or
no let's take a a big step back and take
a kind of an overview the next function
is what is a cost function that we're
going to cover this is so important
because this is your end result that
you're going to do over and over again
and use to decide whether the model is
working or not whether you need to try a
different step function whether you need
to try a different activation whether
you need to try a fully different model
used so what is the cost function cost
function is the measure to evaluate how
good your model's performance is it is
also referred as loss or error used to
compute the error of the output layer
during back propagation there's our back
propagation where we're training our
model that's one of our key words mean
squared error is an example of a popular
cost function and so here we have the
cost function c equals half of y minus y
predicted and then you square that so
the first thing is
you know real quick if you haven't done
statistics this is not a percentage it's
not a percentage of how accurate it is
it's just a measurement of the error and
we take that error for training it and
we push that error backwards through the
neural network and we use that through
the different training functions
depending on what model you're using to
train the neural network so when you
deploy the network you're usually done
training it because it takes a lot of
computational force to train it this is
a very simple model and so you deploy
the trained one but we want to know how
your error is and so how do we do that
well you split your data part of your
data is for trading and part of your
data is for testing and then we can also
test the error on there so it's very
important and then we're going to go one
more step on this we've got to look at
both the local and the global setup it
might work great to test your data on
what you have on your computer but
that's different than in the field so
when we're talking about all these
different tests in the error test as far
as your loss you don't you want to make
sure that you're in a closed environment
when you do initial testing but you also
want to open that up and make sure you
follow up with the testing on the larger
scale of data because it will change it
might not fit the larger scale there
might be something in there and the way
you brought the data in specifically or
the data group you used or any of those
could cause an error so it's very
important to remember that we're looking
at both the local and the global context
of our error and just one other side
note on a lot of the newer models of
neural networks by comparing the error
we get on the data our training data
with a portion of the test data we can
actually figure out how good the model
is whether it's over fitted or not we'll
go into that a little bit more as we go
into some of the different models so we
have our output we're able to
figure out the error on it based on the
square means usually although there's
other functions used so we want to talk
about what is gradient descent another
vocabulary word gradient descent is an
optimization algorithm to minimize the
cost function or to minimize the error
aim is to find the local or global
minima of a function determine the
direction the model should take to
reduce the error so as we're looking at
this we have our squared error that we
just figured out the co based on the
cost function it says how bad is my
model fitting the data i just put
through it and then we want to reduce
that error so how do you figure out what
direction to do that in well it could be
that you're looking at just that line
that line of data coming in so that
would be a local minima we want to know
the error of that particular setup
coming in and then you have your global
your global minima we want to minimize
it based on the overall data we're
putting through it and with this we can
figure out the global minimum cost we
want to take all those local minimum
cost of each piece of data coming in and
figure out the global one how we're
going to adjust this model to fit all
the data we don't want it to be biased
just on three or four lines of data
coming in we wanted to kind of
extrapolate a general answer for all the
data coming in but this of course we
mentioned it briefly about back
propagation this is where really comes
in handy is training our model neural
network technique to minimize the cost
function helps to improve the
performance of the network back
propagates the error and updates the
weights to reduce the error so as you
can see here is a very nice depiction of
a back propagation we have our
predicted y coming out and then we have
since it's a training set we already
know the answer and the answer comes
back and based on case of square means
was one of the functions we looked at
one of the activation functions based on
cost function that cost function then
depending on what you choose for your
back propagation method and there's a
number of them we'll change the weights
it will change the weight going to each
of the one of those nodes in the hidden
layer and then based upon the error
that's still being carried back it'll
change the way it's going to the next
hidden layer and then it computes an
error level on that and sends that back
up and you're going to say well if it
computes the air into the first hidden
layer and fixes it why would it stop
there well remember we don't want to
create a biased neural network so we
only make small adjustments on these
weights we don't make a big adjustment
that changes everything right off the
bat so no matter how far back you go
you're always going to have a small
amount of error and that's still going
to continue to go all the way back up to
hidden layers for right now focus on the
back propagation is taking that error
and moving it backwards on the neural
network to change the weights and help
program it so that it'll have the
correct answers so far we've been
talking about forward propagation neural
networks everything goes forwards goes
left to right but let's just take a
little detour let's see what is the
difference between a feed forward neural
network and a recurrent neural network
now this is in the function not when
we're training it using the back
propagation so you've got new
information coming in and you want to
get the answer and there's a couple
different networks out there and we want
to know we have a feed forward neural
network and we have a new vocabulary
term recurrent neural network a feed
forward neural network signals travel in
one direction from input to output no
feedback loops considers only the
current input cannot memorize previous
inputs one example of one of these feed
forward neural networks and we've
covered a number of them but one of the
ones that has a big highlight nowadays
is the cnn a convolutional neural
network tensorflow the one put out by
google is probably most known for their
cnn where the information goes forward
it first takes a picture splits it apart
goes through the individual pixels on
the picture so it picks up a different
reading then calculates based on that
goes into a regular feed forward neural
network and then gives your
categorization on there now we're not
covering the cnn today but we do have a
video out that you can look up on
youtube put out by simply learn the
convolutional neural network wonderful
tutorial check that out and learn a lot
more about the convolutional neural
network but you do need to know that the
cnn is a forward propagation neural
network only so it's only moving in one
direction so we will look at a recurrent
neural network signals travel in both
directions making it a looped network
considers the current input along with
the previous received inputs for
generating the output of a layer has the
ability to memorize past data due to its
internal memory and you can see they
have a nice image here we have our
input and for some reason they always do
the recurrent neural network
in reverse from bottom up in the images
kind of a standard although i'm not sure
why your x goes into your hidden layer
and your hidden layer the answer for
part of the answer from that it
generates feeds back into the hidden
layer so now you have an input of both x
and part of the hidden layer and then
that feeds into your output now if we go
back to the forward let me just go back
a slide and we're looking at our forward
propagation network one of the tricks
you can do to use just a forward
propagation network is if you're in a
what they call a time sequence that's a
good uh term to remember are a time
series meaning that a sequential data
each term comes after the other you can
trick this by creating your input nodes
as with the history so if you know that
you have values 1 5 and 7 going in and
you know what the output is from when
what those outputs are you can expand
the input to include the history input
that's one of the ways to trick a
forward propagation network into looking
at that but when you do with the
recurrent neural network you let the
hidden layer do that for you it sends
that data and reprocesses it back into
itself what are some of the applications
of recurrent neural network the rnn can
be used for sentiment analysis and text
mining getting up early in the morning
is good for health it's a positive
sentiment one of the catches you really
want to look at this when you're looking
at the language is that i could switch
this around and totally negate the
meaning of what i'm doing so would no
longer be positive so when you're
looking at a sentence knowing the order
of the words is as important as the
meaning of the words you can't just
count how many good words there are
versus bad words to get some positive
sentiment you now have to know what
they're addressing and there's lots of
other different uses uh kids are playing
football or soccer as we call it in the
us rn can help you caption an image so
based on previous information coming in
it refeeds that back in and you have a
image setter and then time series
problems like predicting the prices of
stocks in a month or quarter or sell a
product can be solved using an rnn and
this is a really good example you have
whatever your stocks were doing earlier
this month will have a huge effect on
what they're doing today if you're
investing so having an rnn model a
recurrent neural network feeding into
itself what's happening previously
allows it to take that model and program
in the whole series without having to
put in the whole a month at a time of
data you can only put in one day at a
time but if you keep them in order it
will look back and say oh this because
what happened yesterday i need some
information from that and i'm going to
use that to help predict today's and so
on and so on we're going to go back to
our activation functions remember i told
you rayleigh was one of the most common
functions used so let's talk a little
bit more about relu and also softmax
softmax is an activation function that
generates the output between 0 and 1. it
divides each output such that the total
sum of the outputs is equal to 1. it is
often used in the output layers soft max
l of the n equals e to l on the n over
the absolute value of e to the l so what
does this function mean i mean what is
actually going on here so we have our
output notes and our output nodes are
giving us let's say they give us 1.2 0.9
and 0.4 as a human being i look at that
and i say well the greatest value is 1.2
so whatever category that is if you have
three different categories maybe you're
not just doing if it's a cat or it's a
dog or well let's say it's a cow and we
had cats and dogs earlier why the cats
and dogs are hanging out with a cow i
don't know but we have a value and it
might say 1.2 is a cat 0.9 is the dog
and 0.4 is a cow for some reason it
thinks that there's a chance of it being
any one of these three items and that's
how it comes out of the output layer
well as a human i can look at 1.2 and
say this is definitely what it is it's
definitely a cat or whatever it is maybe
it's looking at different kinds of cars
might be a bitter whether it's a car
truck or a motorcycle maybe that'd be a
better example well from a computer
standpoint that might be a little
confusing because they're just numbers
waving at us and so with the soft max we
want all those numbers to always add up
to one so when i add three numbers
together i want the final output to be
one on there and so it goes through this
formula changes each of these numbers in
this case it changes them to 0.46 0.34
and 0.20 they all add up to 1. and
that's a lot easier to register because
it's very set it's a set output it's
never going to be more than one it's
never going to be less than 0. and so
you can see here that there's probably a
pretty high chance that it's the first
one so you're a human being we have no
problem knowing that but this output can
then also go into say another input so
it might be
an automated car that's picking up
images and it says that image in front
of us is probably a big truck we should
deal with it like it's a big truck it's
probably not a motorcycle or whatever
those categories are that's the soft max
part of it but now we have the relu well
what where's the relu coming from well
the relu is what's generating the 1.2
and the 0.9 and the 0.4 and so if you
remember our relu stands for rectified
linear unit and is the most widely used
activation function we looked at a
number of different activation functions
including tangent h the step function
remember i said the step function is
really used if that's what your actual
output is because then you know it's a
zero or one but the ray loop if you have
that as your output you now have a
discrepancy in there and if that's going
into another neural network or another
process having that discrepancy is
really important and it gives an output
of x if x is positive and 0 otherwise so
it says my x value is going to be
somewhere between 0 or 1 and then the
usually unless it's really uncertain the
output's usually a 1 or zeros and then
you have a little piece of uncertainty
there that you can send forward to
another network or you can look at to
know that there's uncertainty involved
and is often used in the hidden layers
this is what's coming out of the hidden
layers into the output layer usually or
as we reference the convolutional neural
network the cnn you'd have to go to
another video to review the relu is the
most common used
for
convolutional part of that network it
has a bunch of little pieces that are
very simplified looking at all the
different images or different sections
of the map and the rayleigh works really
good for that like i said there's other
formulas used but that this is the most
common one and you'll see that in the
hidden layers going maybe between one
layer and the next layer so just a quick
recap we have our soft max which means
that if you have numerous categories
only one of them is going to be picked
but you also want to have some value
attached to it how well it picked it and
you put that between 0 1 so it's very
standardized so we have our soft max we
looked at that let's go back one we
looked at that here where it transforms
the numbers and then we have our relu
function which takes the information and
the summation and puts it between a zero
and a one where it's either clearly a
zero or depending on how confident our
model is it'll go between the zero and
one value what are hyper parameters well
this is a great interview question hyper
parameters when you are doing neural
networks this is what you're playing
with most the time once you've gotten
the data formatted correctly a
hyperparameter is a parameter whose
value is set before the learning process
begins determines how a network is
trained and the structure of the network
this includes things like the number of
hidden units how many hidden layers are
you going to have and how many nodes in
each layer learning rate learning rate
is usually multiplied once you've
figured out the error and how much you
want to change the weights we talked
about or i mentioned it earlier just
briefly you don't want to just make a
huge change otherwise you're going to
have a biased model so you only take
some little incremental changes and
that's what the learning rate is is
those small incremental changes epics
how many times are you going to go
through all the data in your training
set so one epic is one trip through all
the data and there's a lot of other
things depending on which model you're
working with and which programming
script you're working with like the
python sk learn package will have a
slightly different than say google's
tensorflow package which will be a
little bit different than the spark
machine learning package so these are
just some examples of the hyper
parameters and so you see in here we
have a nice image of our data coming in
and we train our model then we do a
comparison to see how good our model is
and then we go back and we say hey this
this model is pretty good but it's
biased so and we send it back and we
change our hyper parameters to see if we
get an unbiased model or we can have a
better prediction on it it matches our
data closer what will happen if learning
rate is set too low or too high we have
a nice couple graphs here we have one
over here says the learning rate set to
load you can see that it slowly works
its way down the curve and on the right
you can see a learning rate set too high
it's just bouncing back and forth when
your learning rate is too low that's
what we studied at two slides over
that's what the learning rate was
training of the model will progress very
slowly as we are making very tiny
updates to the weights we'll take many
updates before reaching the minimum
point so i just mentioned epic going
through all the data you might have to
go through all the data a thousand times
instead of 500 times for it to train
learning rate too high causes
undesirable divergent behavior to the
loss function due to drastic updates and
weights at times it may fail to converge
or even diverge so if you have your
learning rate set too high and it's
training too quickly maybe you'll get
lucky and it trains after one epic run
but a lot of times it might never be
able to train because the weights are
changing too fast they flip back and
forth too easy and you see down here
we've introduced two new terms converge
and diverge a converge means that our
model has reached a point where it's
able to give a fairly good answer for
all the data we put in all those weights
have adjusted and it's minimized the
error diverged means that the data is so
chaotic that it can never manage to to
train to that data the data is just too
chaotic for it to train so we have two
new words there converge and diverge are
important to know also what is dropout
and batch normalization dropout is a
technique of dropping out hidden and
visible units of a network randomly to
prevent overfitting of data it doubles
the number of iterations needed to
converge the network so here we have our
standard neural network and then after
applying dropout now it doesn't mean we
actually delete the node the node is
still there and we're still going to use
that node what it means is that we're
only going to work with a few of the
nodes
a lot of times i think the most common
one right now used is 20 percent uh so
you'll drop out 20 of the nodes when you
do your training you reverse propagate
your data and then you'll randomly pick
another 20 nodes the next time you go
through an epic data training so each
time you go through one epic you will
randomly pick 20 of those nodes not not
to mess with and this allows for less
overfitting of the data so by randomly
doing this you create some i guess it
just kind of pulls some nodes off to the
side it says we're going to handle the
data later on so we don't over fit batch
normalization is a technique to improve
the performance and stability of neural
network the idea is to normalize the
inputs in every layer so that they have
mean output and activation of zero and
standard deviation of one this question
covers a lot of different things which
is great it's a great uh interview
question because it pulls in that you
have to understand what the mean value
is so a mean output activation of zero
that means our average activation is
zero so when you normalize remember
usually we're going between minus one
and one on a lot of these it's a very
standard setup so you have to be very
aware that this is your mean output
activation of zero and then we have our
standard deviation of one so we wanna
keep our error down to just a one value
the benefits of this doing a batch
normalization is it provides
regularization it trains faster higher
learning rates and weights are easier to
initialize what is the difference
between batch gradient descent and
stochastic gradient descent batch
gradient descent batch gradient computes
the gradient using the entire data set
it takes time to converge because the
volume of data is huge and weights
update slowly so you can look at the
batches a lot of times if you're using
big data batch the data in but you still
go through a full epic you still go
through all the data on there so batch
gradient descent means you're going to
use it to fit all the data and look for
convergence there stochastic gradient
descent stochastic gradient computes the
gradient using a single sample it
converges much faster than batch
gradient because it updates weight more
frequently explain overfitting and
underfitting and how to combat them
overfitting happens when a model learns
the details and noise and the training
data to the degree that it adversely
impacts execution of the model on the
new information it is more likely to
occur with non-linear models that have
more flexibility when learning a target
function an example of this would be if
you're looking at say cars and trucks
and motorcycles it might only recognize
trucks that have a certain box-like
shape it might not be able to notice a
flatbed truck unless it's only a
specific kind of flatbed truck or only
ford trucks because that's what it saw
on the training set this means that your
model performs great on your train data
and great on maybe a small test amount
of data but when you go to use it in the
real world it leaves out a lot and
starting is not very functional outside
of your small area your slow laboratory
data coming in under fitting doing the
opposite when you under fit your data
underfitting alludes to a model that is
neither well trained on training data
nor can generalize to new information
usually happens when there is less and
improper data to train a model has a
verb performance and accuracy so if
you're using underfitted data and you
generate a model and you distribute that
in a commercial zone you'll have a lot
of people unhappy with you because it's
not going to give them very good answers
so we've explained overfitting and under
fitting so now we want to ask how to
combat them combating overfitting and
underfitting resampling the data to
estimate the model accuracy k-fold cross
validation having a validation data set
to evaluate the model so we do the
resampling we're randomly going to be
picking out data and we'll run it a few
times to see how that works depending on
our random data and how we sample the
data to generate our model and then we
want to go ahead and validate the data
set by having our training data and then
keeping some data on the side testing
data to validate it how are weights
initialized in a network initializing
all weights to zero all the weights are
set to zero this makes your model
similar to a linear model so if you have
linear data coming in doing a basic
setup like that might work all the
neurons in every layer perform the same
operation given the same output and
making the deep net useless right there
is a key word it's going to be useless
if you initialize everything to zero at
that point be looking into some other
machine learning tools initializing all
weights randomly here the weights are
assigned randomly by initializing them
very close to zero it gives better
accuracy to the model since every neuron
performs different computations and here
we have the weights are set randomly we
have our input layer the hidden layers
and the output layer and w equals np
random random in layer size l layer size
l minus one this is the most commonly
used is to randomly generate your
weights what are the different layers in
cnn convolutional neural network first
is the convolutional layer that performs
a convolutional operation we have our
other video out if you want to explore
that more so go into detail exactly how
the c the convolutional layer works on
the cnn as far as creating a number of
smaller picture windows to go over the
data the second step is as a rayleigh
layer relu brings non-linearity to the
network and converts all the negative
pixels to zero output is rectified
feature map so it goes into a mapping
feature there pooling layer pooling is a
down sampling operation that reduces the
dimensionality of the feature map so we
have all our relu layer which is pulling
all these little maps out of our
convolutional layer it's taking that
picture and little creating little tiny
neural networks to look at different
parts of the picture uh then we need to
pull it together and then finally the
fully connected layer so we flatten our
pulling layer out and we have a fully
connected layer recognizes and
classifies the objects in the image and
that's actually your forward propagation
reverse propagation training model
usually i mean there's a number of
different models out there of course
what is pooling in cnn and how does it
work pooling used to reduce the spatial
dimensions of a cnn performs down
sampling operation to reduce the
dimensionality creates a pooled feature
map by sliding a filter matrix over the
input matrix i mentioned that briefly on
the previous slide it's important to
know that you have if you see here they
have a rectified feature map and so each
one of those colors like the yellow
color that might be one of the a smaller
little neural network using the relu
you'll look at it'll just kind of go
over the main picture and look at all
the different areas on the main picture
so you might step one two three four
spaces and then you have another one
that's also looking at features and it
has a two seven eight five each one of
those is a map so it might be the first
one might be a map looking for cat ears
the second one looking for human eyes
when it does this you then have this
rectified feature map looking at these
different features and the max pooling
with the two by two filters and a a two
stride means instead of skipping every
pixel you're gonna go every two pixels
you take the maximum values and you can
see over here we look at a pull feature
map one of the features says hey i had a
max value of eight so somewhere in here
we saw a human eye labeled as eight
pretty high label and maybe seven was a
human hand and maybe four was cat
whiskers or something that we thought
might be cat whiskers four is kind of a
low number in this particular case
compared to the other ones so you have
your full pool feature map you can see
the process here is we have our stepping
we look for the max value and then we
create a pool feature map of the max
values how does a lstm network work
that's long short-term memory so the
first thing to know is that an lstms are
a special kind of recurrent neural
network capable of learning long-term
dependencies remembering information for
long periods of time is their default
behavior we did look at the rnn briefly
talked about how the hidden layer feeds
back into itself with the lstm has a
much more complicated feedback and you
can see here we have the hidden layer of
t minus one and the hidden layer that's
what the h stands for hidden layer of t
and the formula is going in as we can
see here we have the hidden layers we
have t minus one and then h of t where t
stands for time so this is a series
remember working with series we want to
remember the past and you can see you
have your x your input of t and that
might be a frame in a
video as the frame comes in they usually
use in this one the tangent h activation
formula but you also see that it goes
through a couple other formulas the
omega formula and so when it combines
these that then goes into the next layer
your next hidden layer that then goes
into the data that's submitted to the
next input so you have your x of t plus
one so when you have that coming in then
you have your h values coming forward
from the last process and depending on
how many of these omega structures you
put in there depends on how long term
the memory gets so it's important to
remember this is more for your long term
recurrent neural networks the three
steps in an lstm step one decides what
to forget and what to remember step 2
selectively update cell state values so
based on what we want to remember and
forget we want to update those cell
values and then decides what part of the
current state make it to the output so
now we have to also have an output on
there what are vanishing and exploding
gradients this is a great question that
affects all our neural networks while
training an rnn your slope can become
either too small or too large and this
makes the training difficult when the
slope is too small the problem is known
as vanishing gradient so our slope we
have our change in x and our change in y
when the slope decreases gradually to a
very small value sometimes negative and
makes training difficult when the slope
tends to grow exponentially instead of
decaying this problem is called
exploding gradient the slope grows
exponentially you can see a nice graph
of that here issues in gradient problem
long training time poor performance and
low accuracy what is the difference
between epic batch and iteration in deep
learning epic an epic represents one
iteration over the entire data set so
that's everything you're going to go
ahead and put into that training model
batch we cannot pass the entire data set
into the neural network at once so we
divide the data set into a number of
batches and then iteration if we have 10
000 images as data and a batch size of
200 then the epic should run 10 000
times over 200 so that means we have our
total number over the 200 equals 50
iterations so in each epic we're running
over all the data set we're going to
have 50 iterations and each of those
iterations includes a batch of 200
images in this case why tensorflow is
the most preferred library in deep
learning well first tensorflow provides
both c plus plus and python apis that
makes it easier to work on has a faster
compilation time than other deep
learning libraries like cross and torch
tensorflow supports both cpus and gpus
computing devices so right now
tensorflow is at the top of the market
because it's so easy to use for both
programmer side and for hardware side
and for the speed of getting something
up and running what do you mean by
tensor in tensorflow tensor is a
mathematical object represented as a
rays of higher dimension these arrays of
data with different dimensions and ranks
that are fed as input to the neural
network are called tensors you can see
here we have a tensor of dimensions five
comma four so it's a two dimensional
tensor coming in you can look at an
image like this that each one of those
pixels is a different value if it's a
black and white so it might be zero and
ones and then each one represents a
black and white image in a color photo
you might
either find a different value system or
you might have a tensor value that has
the x y coordinates as we see here plus
the colors so you might have three more
different dimensions for the three
different images the red the blue and
the yellow coming in and even as you go
from one layer or one tensor to the next
these layers might change we might
flatten them might bring in numerous in
the case of the convergence neural
network we have all those smaller
different mappings of features that come
in so each one of those layers coming
through is a tensor if it has multiple
dimensions coming in and weights
attached to it what are the programming
elements in tensorflow well we have our
constants constants are parameters whose
value does not change to define a
constant we use tf.constant command
example a equals tf.constant 2.0 tf
float 32 so it's a tensor float value of
32. b equals tf constant 3.0 print a b
if we did a print of a b we'd have
tf.constant and then of course b is that
instance of it variables variables allow
us to add new trainable parameters to
graph to divide a variable we use
tf.variable command and initialize them
before running the graph in session
example w equals tf variable 0.3 d type
tfloat32 or b equals the tf variable
minus 3 comma d type float32
placeholders placeholders allow us to
feed data to a tensorflow model from
outside a model it permits a value to be
assigned later to define a placeholder
we use tf placeholder command example a
equals tf placeholder b equals a times
two with the tf session as sess result
equals session run b comma feed
dictionary equals a 3.0 print result so
we have a nice example there replace
holder session a session is run to
evaluate the nodes this is called as the
tensorflow run time so for example you
have a equals tf constant 2.0 b equals
tf constant 4.0 c equals a plus b and at
this point you'd go ahead and create a
session equals tf session and then you
could evaluate the tensor c print
session run c that would input c as an
input into your session what do you
understand by a computational graph
everything in tensorflow is based on
creating a computational graph it has a
network of nodes where each node
performs an operation nodes represent
mathematical operation and edges
represent tensors since data flows in a
form of a graph it is also called a data
flow graph and we have a nice visual of
this graph or graphic image of a
computational graph and you can see here
we have our input nodes our add multiply
nodes and our multiply node at the end
and then we have the edges where the
data flows so we have from a going to c
a going to d you can see we have a two
flowing four flowing explain generative
adversarial network along with an
example suppose there is a wine shop
that purchases wine from dealers which
they will resell later so we have a
dealer going to the wine or shop owner
that then sells it for a profit but
there are some malfactor dealers who
sell fake wine in this case the shop
owner should be able to distinguish
between fake and authentic wine the
forge will try to different techniques
to sell fake wine and make sure certain
techniques go past the shop owner's
check so here's our forager fake wine
shop owner the shop owner would probably
get some feedback from the wine experts
that some of the wine is not original
the owner would have to improve how he
determines whether a wine is fake or
authentic goal of forger to create wines
that are indistinguishable from the
authentic ones goal of shop owner to
accurately tell if the wine is real or
not there are two main components of
generative adversarial network and we
refer to as a noise vector coming in we
have our forger who's going to generate
fake wine and then we have our real
authentic wine and of course our shop
owner who has to figure out whether it's
real or fake the generator is a cnn that
keeps producing images that are closer
in appearance to the real images while
the discriminator tries to determine the
difference between real and fake images
the ultimate aim is to make the
discriminator learn to identify real and
fake images what is an auto encoder the
network is trained to reconstruct its
inputs it is a neural network that has
three layers here the input neurons are
equal to the output neuron the network's
target outside is same as the input it
uses dimensionality reduction to
restructure the input input image comes
in we have our latin space
representation and then it goes back out
reconstructing the image it works by
compressing the input to a latin space
representation and then reconstructing
the output from this representation what
is bagging and boosting bagging and
boosting are ensemble techniques where
the idea is to train multiple models
using the same learning algorithm and
then take a call so we have in here
where we're bagging we take a data set
and we split it we're gonna have our
training data and our test data very
standard thing to do then we're going to
randomly select data into the bags and
train your model separately so we might
have bag one model one bag two model two
bag three model three and so on in
boosting the emphasis is to select the
data points which give wrong output in
order to improve the accuracy so in
boosting we have our data set again we
split it to test data and train data and
we'll take a bag 1 and we'll train the
model data points with wrong predictions
then go into bag two and we then train
that model and repeat i hope this helps
you in your interview with that we've
reached the end of this complete deep
learning tutorial i hope you guys
enjoyed this video do like and share it
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simplylearn
[Music]